WALKING TO THE JOINT HEARING OF
THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEES ON THE CENSUS.
WE'RE JUST OVER ONE YEAR OUT
FROM CENSUS DAY APRIL FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY AND TODAY IS THE
FIRST HEARING OF THIS SESSION
AND THE NEWLY RECONSTITUTED
SELECT COMMITTEES.
THAT WERE APPOINTED BY SPEAKER
RENDON AND SENATE PRESIDENT PRO
TEM ATKINS.
I WANT TO WELCOME BACK DOCTOR
PAN MY PARTNER ON CENSUS MATTERS
THIS PAST YEAR AS WELL AS
WELCOME SENATOR UMBERG.
AS CO CHAIR OF THE SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE IN OUR NEW PARTNER.
THANK YOU TO OUR COLLEAGUES NEW
AND RETURNING IT WILL BE SERVING
ON THIS LIKE COMMITTEES OVER THE
NEXT YEAR PLUS.
AS MANY OF YOU ALREADY KNOW THIS
WILL BE THE MOST CHALLENGING
CENSUS COUNT CALIFORNIA HAS EVER
UNDERTAKEN.
WE'RE THE HARDEST ACCOUNT STATE
IN THE COUNTRY.
ON TOP OF THAT THERE IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED UNPRECEDENTED
LEVEL OF FEAR AND ANXIETY IN OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES.
ARE PARTICIPATING IN ANYTHING
RELATED TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WHICH HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO LEAD TO AN EVEN
LARGER UNDERCOUNT THE NORMAL.
FORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA STARTED
PLANNING EARLY AND IS ALREADY
MADE A SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
INVESTMENT IN ACHIEVING A
COMPLETE COUNT.
THUS FAR THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR ALLOCATED MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO FIND
OUT REACHING COMMUNICATION
EFFORTS TO ENSURE AN ACCURATE
AND SUCCESSFUL COUNT.
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY PROPOSED GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL
FIFTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS TO
EXPAND THE STATE'S EFFORTS.
IN TOTAL THIS IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
FOUR POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS --
PROPOSED TO BE INVESTED WHICH
BROUGH TODAY'S COMMITTEES AGENDA.
TODAY'S HEARING WILL FOCUS ON
THE STATE'S CENSUS TWENTY TWENTY
PROGRAM.
THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
WAS TASKED TO WORK WITH THE AC
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COMPLETE
COUNT OFFICE TO DEVELOP OUR
REGION COMMUNICATION PROGRAMS TO
REACH THE HARDEST ACCOUNT
CALIFORNIANS.
TESTIMONY TODAY WILL PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE PROGRESS
THAT HAS BEEN MADE SINCE THE
JUNE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
BUDGET ALLOCATION.
SIGNIFICANT DECISIONS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN MADE CONCERNING THE
PROGRAMS OVERALL FUNDING AND THE
ALLOCATIONS THAT ARE TO BE GIVEN
TO MAJOR STRUCTURAL COMPONENTS.
AS I STARTED IT --
IN MY OPENING.
WE ARE NOW JUST OVER ONE YEAR
FROM CENSUS DAY SO WE NEED TO BE
TRANSITIONING FROM PLANNING TO
ACTION.
I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING ABOUT
THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE TO
DATE AND WHAT REMAINS TO BE DONE --
AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO TURN
IT OVER TO MY CO CHAIRS --
FOR ANY OPENING REMARKS --
AND THEN WE'LL GET STARTED.
SO I SENATOR UMBERG.
WELL I I COULD BE SHORT JUST SAY
WHAT HE SAID.
BUT BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR CONVENING
THIS SESSION.
A COUPLE OF THINGS.
THERE ARE A FEW THINGS WE DO IN
GOVERNMENT THAT ARE AS IMPORTANT
AS IS MAKING SURE THAT THAT WE
BOTH.
PROVIDE ACCURATE INFORMATION.
AND ALSO WE PROVIDE ADEQUATE
RESOURCES. TO TO FUND THE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES OF GOVERNMENT
THE CENSUS IS A CRITICAL AND I
CAN'T UNDERLINE THAT ENOUGH
CRITICAL.
COMPONENT OF ENSURING THE THAT
WE PROVIDE ACCURATE INFORMATION
AND THAT WE DO WHAT WE CAN TO
MAKE SURE THE THAT WE HAVE AN
ACCURATE.
RENDERING OF THE COUNT SO THAT
RESOURCES ARE ACCURATELY
APPROPRIATED FOR US HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
OF AND I'M SURE WE'LL GET INTO
THIS IS IN MY VIEW OF IN
INSIDIOUS ATTEMPT TO THWART THAT
PROCESS THE QUESTION OF
CITIZENSHIP.
ON THE BALLOT I'M NOT SURE THAT
EVEN REASONABLE MINDS CAN DIFFER
THAT IT'S GOING TO HAVE AN
IMPACT.
ON THE CENSUS SO I'M INTERESTED
IN HEARING A BIT MORE ABOUT THAT
BUT ALSO IN IN TALKING ABOUT
WHAT WE CAN DO.
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE THAT I
THINK AGAIN IS IS JUST
ABSOLUTELY OBVIOUS THAT THE
PERSON THAT QUESTION IS --
TO INTIMIDATE FOLKS SO THANKS
AGAIN MISTER CHAIR FOR CONVENING
US AND I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY
CULTURE.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD
AFTERNOON NO I THINK EVERYONE
HIS PRESENCE HERE I SPECIALLY
WANT TO THANK --
LIKE --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN HIS ONCE
AGAIN THAT SHARING THE SIMPLY
SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE CENSUS
AND REALLY APPRECIATED WORKING
WITH YOU THIS PAST.
YEAR LOOKING FORWARD TO OUR
CONTINUED WORK TOGETHER I'M ALSO
EXCITED TO HAVE A CO CHAIR AT
THIS YEAR ON MY SIDE AS WELL SO
CENTER BURKE.
I SINCERELY LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
PARTNERSHIP AS COACH OF THE
SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE
CENSUS IS WEEKEND THIS CRITICAL
YEAR AND WHICH WEHAVE ONE
CHANCE ONE CHANCE TO GET IT
RIGHT AND APPROACH OF SINCE THE
STATE WHICH IS JUST ABOUT A YEAR
OF WEIGHTS IN APRIL.
OF OF TWENTY TWENTY I ALSO WANT
TO RECOGNIZE GOV OPS FOR THEIR
CONTINUING LEADERSHIP OF THE
CENSUS AND ALL OUR SPEAKERS ARE
HERE TODAY TO HELP US KICK OFF.
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN A CENSUS
EFFORTS I WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT
THE CENSUS IS IN THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES AND IN THE CONSTITUTION I
STATES EXPLICITLY SAY STATES.
THAT WE CANNOT EVERYONE WE CAN'T
EVERYONE WHO'S IN THE UNITED
STATES THAT'S WHAT THE CENSUS IS
ABOUT IT'S A BEDROCK OF OUR
DEMOCRACY.
SO IT'S GREAT TO SEE SUCH
INTEREST IN THE SENSE OF TRISTEN
THE CENSUS HAS CERTAINLY GROWN
SIGNIFICANTLY AND PEOPLE
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE CENSUS.
TODAY OUR GOAL IS TO LEARN HOW
FAR WE'VE COME SINCE LAST YEAR'S
HEARINGS AND IDENTIFY THE NEW
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES
THAT LIE AHEAD OVER THE NEXT
YEAR.
WHILE MUCH OF THE OVERALL
STRUCTURE OF THE SENSES OUTREACH
EFFORTS HAVE BEEN ARRAY BEEN
DETERMINED RIGHT NOW WE'RE AT A
CRITICAL POINT WHERE WE CAN
STILL SHAPE EXACTLY HOW WE
LEVERAGE.
THE SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES WHICH
HAVE BEEN ALLOTTED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE AND APPROVED BY THE
GOVERNOR AND NOW IS ALSO TIME TO
IDENTIFY ANY GAPS THAT EXIST
BETWEEN A CURRENT CAPACITIES AND
OUR ULTIMATE GOAL WHICH IS THE
COUNT.
EVERY CALIFORNIANS SO WITH THAT
I LOOKING FORWARD TO OUR PANEL I
KNOW THAT MANY OF OUR MEMBERS --
HERE AT THE END IT DOES ANYONE
WISH TO MAKE ANY ADDITIONAL.
REMARKS ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
I JUST WANT TO SAY TO THE CHEERS
YOU FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING.
MY INTEREST IN THIS --
COMES FROM A NUMBER OF OF
DIFFERENT ANGLES FIRST IS THE
CHAIR OF THE API LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS ALONG WITH OUR GREAT VICE
CHAIR DR PAN.
OUR API CAUCUS WITH THE
INCREDIBLE DIVERSITY OF API
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE STATE.
ARE KEENLY KEENLY KEENLY FOCUSED
ON ENSURING THAT WE GET IT RIGHT
AND THAT WE CAN EVERYONE --
BUT CERTAINLY TEN YEARS AGO WITH
THE TWO THOUSAND TEN CENSUS WHEN
I WAS THE PRESIDENT OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
IN OUR CITY WE INVESTED HEAVILY
ENSURING THAT EVERYONE WAS
COUNTED AND WORK CLOSELY WITH
CEOS AND GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
AND BECAUSE OF THE PROACTIVE
INVESTMENT WE MADE WE WERE ONE
OF THE FEW CITIES IN THE STATE
THAT DID NOT SEE ARE HARD TO
COUNT POPULATION NUMBERS GO DOWN.
AND THIS IS WHY ALONG WITH I
THINK EVERYONE ON THIS PANEL --
WERE ALL VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
ENSURING THAT WE GET THE
RESOURCES TO THE RIGHT PLACES TO
MOVE THAT FORWARD.
AND THEN I WOULD SAY WITH
REGARDS TO WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
THE CENSUS WE KNOW WE HAVE A
PRESIDENTIAL MINISTRATION.
THAT IS NOT A SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
AS WE WOULD NEED THEM TO BE AND
AS ONE OF A MORE ALONG WITH
OTHER LEGISLATORS. ONE OF THE
PARTIES TO THE LAWSUIT AGAINST
THE CITIZENSHIP QUESTION --
WE HAVE AN UP HILL BATTLE AND
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE
WORKING TOGETHER ACROSS OUR
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES --
TO ADDRESS THIS THERE'S SO MUCH
AT STAKE IN WITHOUT LOOKING FOR
TO WORKING WITH THE CHAIRS OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEES TO GET IT
RIGHT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES I MADE A QUICK --
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEN OF THE FIFTY
NINE TO SENATE DISTRICTS SOUTH
LOS ANGELES.
AND THE FACT THAT WE PROBABLY
HAD THE WORST COUNT.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I'M
HERE TO MAKE SURE WE DO NOT HAVE
THE WORST COUNTY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
HOPEFULLY EVER AGAIN IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE NOT ONLY GET
EVERYONE COUNTED.
BUT GROUPS THAT ARE THAT ARE
FEARFUL.
SHE WAS SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN
GROUP THAT ARE FEARFUL TO COME
OUT OF THE SHADOWS AND BE
COUNTED.
BECAUSE SOME ADVERSE THINGS MAY
HAPPEN TO THEM --
I AM KEENLY AWARE THAT AND WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE SAFE --
WHEN THEY DO GET COUNTED AND
THEN THERE CAN'T KEEP DOING THE
SAME THING OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN THE WAY WE COUNT
EXPECT?
A DIFFERENT RESULT WE'RE OFF TO
DO SOME INNOVATIVE THINGS TO GET
THESE DISCOUNT UP AND I'M HERE
TO PUSH THE ENVELOPE AND WHEN I
SAY PUSH THE ENVELOPE --
I'VE ALREADY TALKED TO BOTH
CHAIR STATE --
I'M VERY --
KEEN TO TRYING TO DO SOME THINGS
THAT ARE --
OUT OF THE BOX AND I DON'T CARE
TO FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND LIKE
IT WE NEED TO GET DISCOUNT DONE
AND GET IT DONE RIGHT.
RIGHT THANK YOU THANKS MUCH
CENTER THIRD ROUNDS.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THE
THANK YOU SOMEONE MEMBER.
AND OUR SENATORS --
FOR CHERRY AND CO CHAIRING --
WHAT I'M MOST CONCERNED ABOUT AS
WE DIG INTO THIS IS THAT THERE
IS APPEARS TO BE A VERY?
ORGANIZED DELIBERATE.
OF STRATEGY AND PLAN TO NOT
COUNT OUR COMMUNITIES --
THROUGHOUT A CALIFORNIA.
AND OF THE DISTRICT THAT I
REPRESENT IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES IS VERY DIVERSE OR ITS
API -- AND
LET.
AND AFRICAN AMERICANS.
THIS IS OF THE BIGGEST CONCERN
BUT IF WE'RE NOT SUFFICIENT NICE --
IN CALIFORNIA --
THERE WE WILL BE ABLE.
TO RESPOND AND THE DRESS THE WAY
THAT THIS ORGANIZED OPPOSITION
IS TO DOING ACCOUNTS WHICH WE
NEVER THOUGHT WE'D SEE SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR DOING
THIS THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU I'M I THINK THIS IS.
POTENTIALLY ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT SELECT COMMITTEES WE
HAVE -- AND
AM HAPPY THAT I AM ABLE TO SERVE
YOU KNOW I ACTUALLY REMEMBER AS
A YOUNG GIRL.
WALKING --
NEIGHBORHOOD BLACKS WITH MY
MOTHER --
WHILE SHE PARTICIPATED IN A
SENSE IS BY BEING A CENSUS
COUNTER SHE WAS A SEASONAL
WORKER.
AND WE WALKED UP AND DOWN BLOCKS
IN BROOKLYN AND IN NEW YORK CITY --
COUNTING AND I DIDN'T.
I WAS DOING WITH HER.
BUT SHE TOOK GREAT PRIDE IN
DOING THIS.
AND SHE KNEW THAT IT WAS ABOUT
COUNTING EVERY SINGLE PERSON SO
THAT ADEQUATE APPROPRIATE
RESOURCES WOULD BE ALLOCATED TO
THOSE COMMUNITIES OFTENTIMES
POOR COMMUNITIES OFTENTIMES
BLACK BROWN PORTER RICAN
COMMUNITIES --
IN BROOKLYN.
AND IN NEW YORK.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THINGS
DIFFERENTLY CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
CONSISTENTLY UNDER COUNTED.
AND SO HOW ARE WE GOING TO SHIFT
THE PARADIGM. TO BECOMING A
STATE WHERE WE ARE APPROPRIATELY
COUNTED.
AND ALSO BEING VERY HONEST WITH
HOW FAMILIES ARE LIVING NOW.
WE ARE ALL NOT JUST ONE FAMILY
IN ONE HOUSE WE ARE DOUBLED UP
WE ARE TRIPLED UP WE DON'T HAVE
HOMES.
AND SO WE WILL HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO LOOK AT NEW
TECHNIQUES FOR HOW TO GET THE
INFORMATION OUT WITH HOW TO
COMMUNICATE WITH FOLKS IN A WAY
THAT THEY SEE CREDIBILITY AND
THE FOLKS DELIVERING THE MESSAGE.
AND IN MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
TRYING NEEDS TO GET THIS
INFORMATION ACROSS AND TO GET
OURSELVES COUNTED WE HAVE TOO
MUCH AT STAKE AND I THINK WE
SHOULD ALL BE SCARED.
AT THE POSSIBILITY OF LOSING
SEATS AS A RESULT OF BEING UNDER
COUNTY.
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING THE
PRESENTATIONS AND PARTICIPATING
IN WAYS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S
RELATES TO THE CENSUS.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER OPENING
REMARKS ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA
BEGIN.
YES PLEASE DO YES FROM THE RIVER.
IN MANY RESPECTS SIDE THERE'S NO
ISSUE MORE IMPORTANT TO
CALIFORNIA THEN THE TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS SO THANK YOU BOTH
SO MUCH --
FOR ALL THREE FOR BRINGING THIS
HEARING TOGETHER TO LOOK FOR TO
PARTICIPATING.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT.
OKAY SEEN OTHER OPENING REMARKS --
I WANT TO WELCOME UP OUR FIRST
PANEL.
THAT -- INC
LIKE TO INVITE UP SECRETARY OF
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY --
MARIBEL BACHELOR AND DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR THE SENSES JUSTIN
HOWARD AND ADRIANA MARTINEZ STEP
THE DIRECTOR OF OUTREACH AND
TRIBAL LIAISON AND THIS FIRST
PANEL BE DISCUSSING THE
CALIFORNIA CENSUS TWENTY TWENTY
FUNDING AND OPERATIONS WELCOME
AND WILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
LOOK FOR TO YOUR REMARKS.
YEAH OKAY AND SO I WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN --
AND THEN I SURE TO BE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS AS WELL SO THANK YOU --
THANK YOU MISTER CO CHAIR AND
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERY MUCH AND
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
WE'RE DELIGHTED TO BE HERE
BEFORE YOU AS HAS BEEN STATED
THERE'S NOTHING MORE IMPORTANT
THAN WE CAN AND MUST DO IN
CALIFORNIA THAN --
THE SENSES AND GET IT RIGHT SO
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME AND THE STAFF
FROM THE CENSUS HERE TODAY WE
HAVE MANY STAFF MEMBERS.
RIGHT BACK HERE IN THE FIRST
COUPLE ROWS.
AND JUSTIN AND ADRIANA WILL BE --
WILL PROVIDE YOU A MUCH GREATER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE WORK WE
HAVE BEEN DOING BUT I WANTED TO
TAKE JUST A FEW MOMENTS. TO GIVE
YOU AN OVERVIEW OF THE
ACTIVITIES SINCE LAST JULY.
AS YOU WELL KNOW THE US COMMERCE
DEPARTMENT IS CONSTITUTIONALLY
REQUIRED TO CONDUCT A NATIONWIDE
CENSUS EVERY TEN YEARS.
AND FOR THE PAST TWO CENSUS
COUNTS THE STATE HAS CARRIED OUT
A LARGE SCALE OUT REACH AND
COMMUNICATIONS CAMPAIGN TO
ENSURE A COMPLETE AND ACCURATE
COUNT.
OF ALL CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.
I KNOW THAT I NEEDN'T TELL YOU
THAT.
THE OUTRAGE CAMPAIGN FOR THE
SENSE CALL FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS AS MANUEL STATED
BY MANY OF YOU TODAY.
WE ARE FACING A NUMBER OF UNIQUE
CARE --
CIRCUMSTANCES ALSO THAT HAS BEEN
NOTED BY MEMBERS.
THE CONTROVERSY AND UNCERTAINTY
OF THE PROPOSED CITIZENSHIP
QUESTION.
INTRODUCTION OF THE FIRST
DIGITAL U. S. CENSUS SURVEY FORM.
THE UNIQUE DIVERSITY DENSITY AND
SIZE THAT MAKE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL ALSO MEANS THOSE SENSORS
CHALLENGES WILL BE PARTICULARLY
DIFFICULT.
WE ARE HOME TO MORE THAN 12% OF
THE NATION'S POPULATION YET WE
ACCOUNT FOR MORE THAN 30% OF
THOSE WHO ARE CONSIDERED HARD TO
COUNT.
LOS ANGELES AS IT'S BEEN STATED
IS THE HARDEST ACCOUNT CITY IN
THE HARDEST ACCOUNT COUNTY IN
THE HARDEST YOU COUNT STATE.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS ALSO ONLY
SECOND TO NEW YORK FOR HOLDING
THE LARGEST POPULATION OF
HOMELESS PEOPLE IN THE NATION.
AN ACCURATE COUNT OF THE
POPULATION IS ESSENTIAL FOR THE
EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION OF
FEDERAL FUNDS AND POLITICAL
REDISTRICTING.
IT ALSO PLAYS A VITAL ROLE IN
MANY AREAS OF PUBLIC LIFE
INCLUDING THE IMPORTANT
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS.
WITHOUT A COMPLETE COUNT THE
STATE FACES A POTENTIAL LOSS OF
A CONGRESSIONAL SEAT AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND MUCH
NEEDED FEDERAL FUNDING. FOR
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS PLANNING
WORK STARTED IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND THEN MOVED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH IN JULY.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE CALIFORNIA
COMPLETE COUNT SENSES TWENTY
TWENTY OFFICE WAS MOVED TO THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY FOR
WHICH I AM THE SECRETARY.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT LAUNCHING
THE STATE CENSUS CAMPAIGN HAS
BEEN A HUGE ENDEAVOR.
THERE'S NO PRECEDENT IN THE
STATE.
IN TWENTY TEN THERE WERE TWO
FULL TIME STAFF AND THREE LOANED
PEOPLE FROM OTHER DEPARTMENTS
WITH A BUDGET OF JUST TWO
MILLION DOLLARS.
COMPARE THAT TO THE TWENTY
TWENTY CAMPAIGN WE HAVE THE
FUNDS FOR THIRTY THREE FULL TIME
STAFF AND A BUDGET OF A HUNDRED
POINT THREE MILLION WITH FIFTY
FOUR MILLION MORE PROPOSED IN
GOVERNOR NUISANCE BUDGET.
BUT MORE THAN A STAB MACHINE AND
OFFICE WITH ALL OF ITS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PROCEDURES
AND FUNDING METHODOLOGIES WE ARE
CREATING A REPEATABLE PROCESS SO
THAT IN.
TWENTY THIRTY MUCH OF THE WORK
WE WILL WE ARE DOING NOW HAVE
WILL HAVE BEEN DONE.
THAT NEW TEAM.
WILL HAVE TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS
BUT NOT START FROM SCRATCH AS WE
HAVE DONE IN SO MANY PARTS OF
OUR PLANNING PROCESS.
SO AT A HIGH LEVEL WE LET ME
SHARE WITH YOU SOME OF OUR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND THEN JUSTIN
IN ADRIAAN A WILL GOING TO FAR
GREATER DETAIL.
WE HOSTED TWENTY FOUR REGIONAL
CONVENIENCE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WHICH STARTED BEFORE JULY AND
WRAPPED UP IN AUGUST WE HELD
THREE TRIBAL CONSULTATIONS IN
NORTHERN SOUTHERN AND CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA AND A TRIBAL WEAPON
ARE.
OPENED OFFICES IN SACRAMENTO LOS
ANGELES SAN DIEGO FRESNO AND
OAKLAND.
OF OUR THIRTY THREE FULL TIME
STAFF WE HAVE HIRED TWENTY SEVEN
STAFF MADE OFFERS FOR THREE MORE
AND RECRUITING. FOR THE FINAL.
THREE DEVELOPED OUR FUNDING
METHODOLOGY AND ANNOUNCED IT ON
MEMBER.
EIGHT TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE SENT
LETTERS TO COUNTIES TRIBES
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
ASKING IF THEY WANT TO OPT IN TO
STATE FUNDING.
JUSTIN WILL GO INTO MORE DETAIL
ABOUT HOW AM OR EXCUSE ME WHO
HAS RESPONDED AND HOW MUCH THEY
WILL RECEIVE.
IF WE ISSUED THREE REQUEST FOR
PROPOSAL RFPS TO THE REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THE CBO'S.
STATEWIDE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS OUTRAGE AND PUBLIC
RELATIONS LAST TUESDAY WE
ANNOUNCE THE TEN WINNERS OF THE
REGIONAL ADMINISTRATIVE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
RFPS.
LAUNCHED WE LAUNCHED --
FIRST PHASE OF SWARD REGION
RAPID DEPLOYMENT ONLINE PORTAL.
WE HAVE BROUGHT ON OUR FIRST
COHORT IMPORTANT PARTNERS THE
COUNTIES AND WILL BE BRINGING
THE ADMINISTRATIVE.
COUNTY BASED ORGANIZATIONS ON
BOARD IN THE NEXT TWO WEEKS.
WE HAVE HOSTED FIVE CALIFORNIA
COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEE
MEETINGS.
THIS IS ALL.
AT THIS ALL IS IN ADDITION TO
THE ROUTINE ROUTINE BUT
IMPORTANT TASKS OF BUILDING A
WEBSITE GETTING THE SACRAMENTO
AND FIELD OFFICES SET UP.
AND ALL OF THE LOGISTICAL ISSUES
THAT ENTAIL.
I AM VERY PROUD OF THE WORK --
WE HAVE DONE SINCE JULY THE TASK
OF COUNTING ALL OF CALIFORNIA IS
CRUCIAL AND I KNOW EVERYONE
WORKING ON THIS EFFORT FEELS ITS
IMPORTANCE AND IS PASSIONATE
ABOUT IT.
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A FOUNDATION
FOR A REAL SUSTAINABLE EFFORT
AND I WILL TURN NOW OVER TO
JUSTIN TO GIVE YOU MORE DETAILS
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
I'M VERY WILK I WELCOME YOUR
QUESTIONS AFTER THE PANELISTS
FINISHED THANK YOU IT WILL TAKE
QUESTIONS ANSWERED POUND THANK
YOU WELCOME.
GREAT --
THANK YOU FOR HAVING.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY JUSTIN HOWARD ON THE
DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR CENSUS OF
THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY.
HOPEFULLY EACH OF YOU HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU --
HAND OUT THAT WAS A POWER POINT
I WAS PUT TOGETHER --
JUST FOR SOME TALKING POINTS
THAT I WANT TO GO THROUGH AND
SOME DETAIL HERE KIND OF WHERE
ALL THE ALL THE FUNNY THING
PROPOSED TO GO.
AS PART OF OUR EFFORTS --
RELATED AS THE SECRETARY HAD
MENTIONED AS A MENTION OPEN
REMARKS THE STATE IS INVESTING
AN UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNT OF
FUNDING TOWARDS --
OUT OF REACH AND FOR THAT TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS THIS ALL STARTED
BACK IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WITH
ABOUT TEN MILLION DOLLARS I WAS
ALLOCATED TO BOTH --
OPR IN THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
MOST OF THAT WAS RELATED TO OUR
INITIAL WHAT WE CALL THE LOCAL
UPDATE A CENSUS ADDRESS AT THE
OPPORTUNITY WHERE THAT.
A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA CAN UPDATE THEIR
MASTER DRESSED VIOLENCE IN THOSE
ADDRESSES AND TO THE US CENSUS
BUREAU WHY IS THAT CRITICAL
THAT'S CRITICAL BECAUSE THIS IS
AN ADDRESS BASED ENUMERATIONS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL THE
CORRECT ADDRESSES ARE SENT TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO THAT.
WHEN THEY DO THEIR --
CAMPESINA MAY DO SEND OUT ALL
THEIR ON POSTCARDS WITH THE
ONLINE NUMBERS THAT EVERYONE WHO
HAS AN ADDRESS IN CALIFORNIA
WILL BE ABLE TO RECEIVE THAT
INFORMATION.
AND THE OTHER THREE AND THE
OTHER PORTION WAS REALLY FAR
INITIAL PLANNING.
ACTIVITIES THROUGH OPR AND
FUNDING MANY OF THE CONVENIENCE
OF THE SECRETARY MENTIONED --
IN PART --
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ON NINETY POINT THREE
MILLION WAS ALLOCATED BY THE BY
THE LEGISLATURE TO PUT TOGETHER
BASICALLY A COMPREHENSIVE
STATEWIDE AND COMMUNITY OUTREACH
STRATEGY --
AND AS YOU KNOW AS PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE ARE
PROPOSING ANOTHER FIFTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS TO BASICALLY
SUPPLEMENT OUR EFFORTS AS WIND
AS WE HAVE FOUND THAT THERE ARE
SOME GAPS THAT WE NEED --
TO FIND AS PART OF A IS TO
DEVELOP A CALL COMMUNITY GAUGE
UTILIZES TRUSTED MESSENGERS IN
THE COMMUNITY YOU DIDN'T WANT TO
UTILIZE PEOPLE LIKE ME HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WE WANT TO UTILIZE.
FOLKS WERE ON THE GROUND IN THE
COMMUNITIES IN ORDER TO DO THAT
WE RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAD TO PUSH
THAT FUNDING DOWN BASICALLY TO
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND NOT CONTROL
IT UP HERE AT THE STATE LEVEL --
OUR ACTIONS ARE SUPPOSED TO
SUPPLEMENT THE SIX US CENSUS
BUREAU'S EFFORTS AND THEY ALSO
REQUIRE COLLABORATION AND
COORDINATION AMONG STAKEHOLDERS
AND HAVE SUCH WITH THAT
COLLABORATION CORONATION WE CAN
HELP AVOID THE DUPLICATES AND
OTHER.
OF EFFORTS BETWEEN ALL OF OUR
PARTNER--
ORGANIZATIONS SO AGAIN OUR
STRATEGIES TO MAXIMIZE THOSE
RESOURCES ON THE GROUND WHY IS
THAT IMPORTANT WILL HELP BUILD
THAT STRONG BASE OF TRUSTED
COMMUNITY VOICES IT ALSOALLOWS.
FOR WHAT WE WHAT WE CALL AN IN
AN IN PERSON IMPRESSIONS
IMPRESSIONS BASED ON HOW MANY
TIMES CAN YOU YOU KNOW REACH A
HARD O COUNT INDIVIDUAL --
WHAT WE KNOW IS IT'S GOING TO
TAKE MULTIPLE IMPRESSIONS ON
THESE FOLKS WE CAN'T JUST
TELLING ONCE WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
TELL IN MULTIPLE TIMES?
IN ORDER TO GET THEM TO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE AND
HOPEFULLY PARTICIPATE IN THE
CENSUS --
THIS IS ALSO BY PUSHING THE
FUNDING DOWN LOCALLY IT ALSO
HELPS TO FACILITATE THAT
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE
ENGAGEMENT WITHIN OUR HARD
ACCOUNT COMMUNITIES AND AS WELL
AS A WILL HELP BREAK DOWN
LANGUAGE ACCESS BARRIERS WE
THINK ABOUT IT THE LOOK THE OUT
REACH THAT'SGOING TO BE DONE BY
OUR PARTNERS.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IT'S GOING TO
HAVE TO BE AND THE CULTURALLY
COMPETENT AND LINGUISTICALLY
ACCURATE MANNER --
FEAR DOING OUTREACH TO A
PARTICULAR ETHNIC GROUP IS GOING
TO NEED TO BE AND THE LANGUAGE
THAT THEY THAT THEY
PREDOMINATELY SPEAK --
ALSO BY PER --
WHETHER OR NOT AND WE'RE GETTING
BASICALLY FROM THE FROM THE FROM.
ENTITIES OUT THERE WHO ARE
TRYING TO DISSUADE PEOPLE'S
PARTICIPATION IN THE CENSUS AND
BY HAVING THE MONEY AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL WILL BE ABLE TO BASICALLY
ALLOWS FOR RAPID RESPONSE ISN'T
HIS SHIFT RESOURCES WHERE NEEDED
TO HELP COMBAT SOME OF THOSE --
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGNS THAT
MAY ARISE THROUGHOUT THE
ENUMERATION PROCESS --
SO ON THE NEXT SLIDE YOU KIND OF
SEE THE THE THE OVERALL FUNDING
ALLOCATION APPROACH I'M NOT
GOING TO LIE TO DO HERE COME TO
SPEAK TO THIS AND THE OTHER
PAGES BUT THIS KIND OF GIVES YOU
JUST A HIGH LEVEL CHARTER OF
WHERE ALL THE FUNDING IS BEING.
PROPOSED AGO AS PART OF OUR
EFFORTS --
SO WHAT I WANT TO FOCUS ON FIRST
IS REALLY WHAT WE CALL OUR
GROUND GAME OUR GROUND GAME IS.
IS HOW WE ARE TARGETING ARE HARD
TO COUNT POPULATION SO THAT'S
BASICALLY WHERE THE HARD TO
COUNT POPULATION LIVES AND
THAT'S DONE THROUGH GEOGRAPHIC
BASED OUT REACH.
AND WE DO THAT AND ONE OF THREE
WAYS OR COUNTIES THERE ARE A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS --
AND OUR TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS SO
THAT'S KIND OF OUR GEOGRAPHIC
BASE AND THEN WHAT WE'RE DOING
IS WE'RE LOOKING AT OUR WHO THE
HARD TO COUNT OUR THAT IS THE
SECOND KIND OF LAKE HERE AND
IT'S REALLY.
WE TARGETED ABOUT FOURTEEN
SPECIFIC --
DEMOGRAPHIC AREAS AND WE ARE LOW
A WHITE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO TARGET WHO
THESE POPULATIONS ARE.
AND THEN THE THIRD AREA IS
REALLY OUR SECTOR BASE OUR
REGION THIS IS HOW DO WE GET TO
THEM WHO DO THEY ENGAGE WITH IN
THE COMMUNITY SO THAT WE CAN.
SO THAT WE CAN TARGET THOSE
EFFORTS BASED ON WHO THEY
INTERACT WITH ON A FREQUENT
BASIS.
IT'S UP HEADING INTO COUNTY OUT
REACH TO DATE WE'VE PROVIDED
TWENTY SIX POINT SEVEN MILLION
HAS BEEN ALLOCATED FOR DIRECT
ALLOCATIONS THE COUNTY
GOVERNMENT --
COUNTIES ARE TO SERVE AS THE
FISCAL AGENTS WITHIN THEIR
GEOGRAPHICAL AREA IN THOSE
COUNTIES HAVE ALSO BEEN GIVEN
SPECIFIC INFORMATION RELATED TO
THE CITY'S --
WITHIN THEIR AREA --
ARE ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY IS
PREDOMINATELY BASED UPON WHAT WE
CALL THE CALIFORNIA HARD TO
COUNT INDEX.
AND IF THIS IS WHAT REALLY MAKES
SOMEONE CAN HARD TO COUNT IT'S
MORE THAN JUST ETHNICITY BASE
THERE'S A LOT OF INFORMATION
THAT GOES IN THERE IT'S AN COM
IT'S DO YOU HAVE ACCESS TO
BROADBAND.
THEIR SPORT THERE'S FOURTEEN
DIFFERENT FACTORS THAT GO INTO
WHAT MAKES SOMEONE HARD TO COUNT
AND WHAT WE'VE DONE WITH THE
FUNDING AS WE'VE ALLOCATED OUT.
BASED UPON WHERE THEY LIVE AND
WHETHER OR NOT YOUR CONSIDER HOW
TO COUNT BY THE CALIFORNIA HARD
TO COUNT IN THAT.
SO ON THE NEXT PAGE YOU CAN KIND
OF GET A SENSE OF WHERE OUT WITH
ARE COUNTING OUT REACH WE HAVE
FORTY FIVE OF OUR FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES WHO HAVE CHOSEN TO
PARTICIPATE AND ARE STATEWIDE
CAMPAIGN.
ON WHICH IS REALLY GOOD THOSE
COUNTY CONDOS THE LETTERS WENT
OUT TO COUNTIES BACK IN NOVEMBER
AND THE DEADLINE WAS IN EARLY
FEBRUARY FOR COUNTIES TO GET
BACK TO THE STATE REGARDING
THEIR PARTICIPATION. FOR THOSE
COUNTIES WERE NOT CHOSEN OPT
INTO THE OUT TO THE OUTREACH
PROGRAM IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
THEY'RE NOT PARTICIPATING THAT
JUST MEANS THEY CHOSE NOT TO
SERVE AS THE FISCAL AGENT AND DO
THE ADMINISTRATIVE WORK SOMEONE
MAKE THAT CLEAR WE DO HAVE
COUNTIES WHO HAVE OPTED OUT.
THEY'RE GOING TO PARTICIPATE
WHERE THEY CAN SERVE AS THE
FISCALLY THAT SO WHAT ARE WE
DOING WITH THOSE THAT THOSE
COUNTIES WALTER I'LL GIVE YOU TO
THE BIG ONES --
FIRST ONE IS SAN DIEGO --
SAND ACT HAS STEPPED UP TO SERVE
AS THE FISCAL AGENT FOR THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO WHICH IS
VERY IMPORTANT SAN DIEGO IS ONE
OF OUR HARDEST TO COUNTY AREAS
IN THE STATE.
I'M WITH A VERY DIVERSE
POPULATIONS THAT THE OTHER ONE
IS I SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY --
WHERE THEY ALSO CHOSE NOT TO
PARTICIPATE BUT WHAT WE'VE DONE
THERE IT'S KIND OF TWOFOLD AS
WE'VE REACHED OUT AND HAVE BEEN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE CITY OF
STOCKTON IN THE CITY OF STOCKTON
IS STEPPING UP TO SERVE AS THE
FISCAL AGENT FOR THEIR
INCORPORATED CITY?
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA WORK WHAT
THEY AWARDED COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION FOR THAT REGION FOR
THE OTHER AREAS WITHIN THAT
COUNTY.
AND THAT PREDOMINATELY IS WHAT
WE ARE DOING FOR ALL THE OTHER
COUNTIES OPTED OUT IS WE'RE
GONNA BE THAT MONEY WILL STAY
WITHIN THE COUNTY SO WE HAVE
ALLOCATED RESOURCES TO DROUGHT
REACHING A COUNTY.
WE PLANET STAYING THERE AND
WE'RE GONNA DO THAT BY GIVING
THAT THOSE RESOURCES TO OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WITH THE DIRECTION THAT THEY ARE
TO WORK.
IS TO DO THE OUR REGION THE
COUNTY WITH THOSE DOLLARS.
OUR NEXT AREA HAS BEEN A IS OUR
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT OUT REACH
HISTORICALLY THE NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBAL POPULATIONS HAVE BEEN
VERY DIFFICULT TO COUNT --
SO WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IT'S
KIND OF A UNIQUE --
THEY HAVE A LOT OF UNIQUE
CHALLENGES WHAT WE'RE DOING IS A
VERY MULTI PRONGED APPROACH FOR
DEALING WITH OUR TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS AND NATIVE AMERICAN
POPULATIONS SO WHAT WE'RE DOING
IS WE'RE DIRECTLY FROM FUNNY
FUNDING DIRECTLY --
TO THE THE TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS IN
THEIR GEOGRAPHICAL SERVICE AREAS
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY GIVEN THAT
A LARGE AMOUNT OF THAT
POPULATION DOESN'T LIVE WITHIN
THEIR GEOGRAPHIC AREAS WHERE
FUNDING SUBSTANTIAL --
CONTRACTS THERE ARE COMMUNITY
BASED STATEWIDE ORGANIZATIONS TO
TARGET BASICALLY OUR URBAN
INDIAN POPULATION WHO LIVE
OUTSIDE OF THOSE POPULATIONS WE
PLAN ON EXECUTING MULTIPLE
CONTRACTS TO MULTIPLE
ORGANIZATIONS TO DO THIS --
OUT RESTORE TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS
IN ADDITION TO THAT AS WE WORK
WITH OUR ADMINISTRATIVE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THEY WILL ALSO BE CONDUCTING OUR
RATES TO TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS I'M
FROM THE RESOURCES THAT THEY ARE
PROVIDING AND THEN FINALLY AS WE
LOOK TO OUR OUR REGION PUBLIC
RELATIONS CONTACT WHICH IS
BASICALLY.
OUR MEDIA EFFORTS WE ALSO BE
FUNDING SIGNIFICAN OUR EXPORTS
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS THROUGH OUR
MEDIA --
EFFORTS AS WELL.
AND THE NEXT COUPLE OF SLIDES IS
GOING TO GIVE AN UPDATE ON THE
DIRECT ALLOCATIONS ONLY --
SO WE WERE PROVIDED THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO THOUSAND
FOR DIRECT ALLOCATIONS --
WE BASE THIS ON FUNDING TEARS
RELATED TO HOW MANY HOUSING
UNITS ARE IN A GEOGRAPHICAL
SERVICE AREA FOR TRY MOST OF
THEM HAVE VERY LOW NUMBERS OF
HOUSING UNITS THERE'S NOT A LOT
OF POPULATION AND LIVE ON THOSE
TRIED SO WE'VE REALLY DONE IS
PROVIDED A LOT OF MICRO.
FUNDING AMOUNTS FOR ASKING THEM
TO HOLD ONE COMMUNITY EVENT COME
SINCE IT'S TIME TO BRING
TOGETHER THOSE TWENTY FIVE TO
FIFTY HOUSEHOLDS TO TALK ABOUT
THE CENSUS.
AND I'VE BEEN GIVEN THE FINAL
ONE MINUTE SO --
THE NEXT LIKE CAN GIVE YOU A
BREAK ON WHERE WE STAND WITH OUR
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT OUR REACH --
AS YOU CAN SEE WE HAVE TWELVE
TRIBES OF OPTED IN WE HAVE
FOURTEEN MORE WITH COMMITTED TO
OPT IN AND AND WARRANT STRONG
CONVERSATIONS WITH ANOTHER
NINETEEN TRIBES --
WE WE'VE WE'VE WE FIRMLY BELIEVE
MOST OF THOSE WILL ALSO COME IN
AT THE END OF THE DAY AND WE'RE
STILL TRYING TO REACH ANOTHER --
TWENTY TWO TRIBES TO GARNER
PARTICIPATION.
AS IT RELATES TO OUR REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE --
AS YOU MAY IT MAY BE AWARE THE
STATE IS DIVIDED UP INTO TEN
REGIONS AND WE MADE THOSE TEN
AWARDS TODAY WE'VE PROVIDED
TWENTY TWO POINT NINE MILLION TO
THOSE ADMINISTRATIVE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND WE ARE
PROPOSING ANOTHER TEN AS PART OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
WHICH THAT ADDITIONAL TEN WILL
REALLY GO FOR WHAT WE CALL OUR
NON RESPONSE FOLLOW UP PERIOD
THAT'S REALLY THE CRUCIAL POINT
WHERE WE NEED TO DO CAMPESINA
DOOR KNOCKING. TO ENSURE
PARTICIPATION IN THE CENSUS FOR
THOSE WHO DENNIS RESPOND EARLY
ON THE NEXT FIGHT --
REALLY GOES INTO THE METHODOLOGY
THAT WAS RELATED TO HOW WE MEET
OUR AWARDS --
WE'VE ON MARCH TWELFTH WE MADE
THE AWARD WINNING TEN
ADMINISTRATIVE COMMUNITIES
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO FIND THESE ORGANIZATIONS
PARTICIPATED IN A COMPETITIVE
BIDDING PROCESS SOMEONE MAKE
THAT CLEAR THIS WAS A
COMPETITIVE BIDDING PROCESS --
WINNING BIDDERS WERE CHOSEN
BASED ON THEIR ABILITY TO
PARTNER WITH A DIVERSE SET OF
SUBCONTRACTORS TO REACH THOSE
HARD ACCOUNT POPULATIONS.
SO ON THE NEXT PAGE IT GOES INTO
WHO THE AUTHORITIES ARE AND YOU
CAN SEE THE AT TEN FORTY AS I
BELIEVE THAT WAS IN YOUR NOTES
AS WELL SOLVE KINDA.
TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT OUR STATE
WIDE CTO RATE OUR REACH WERE
PROPOSING TEN MILLION FOR THAT
INITIAL OUR INITIAL AMOUNT IS
FOUR FOUR MILLION.
AND WE'RE PROPOSING AN
ADDITIONAL SIX MILLION AS PART
OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT'S
THE TARGET THE SIXTEEN
ORGANIZATION --
SIX OF THE FOURTEEN SPECIFIED
DEMOGRAPHIC GROUPS --
WE PLAN TO MAKE THOSE
ANNOUNCEMENTS AND MOUNT ON
FRIDAY WHO'S GOING TO GET THOSE
INITIAL SET OF AWARDS --
I WILL SKIP OVER THE NEXT FIGHT
IT HEAD ON TO EDUCATION SO ONE
OF OUR SECTOR --
EFFORTS IS RELATED TO EDUCATION
WE'RE PROPOSING TO GIVE ONE
POINT SEVEN NINE SEVEN FIVE
MILLION TO FORTY COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION WERE TARGETING
TITLE ONE TITLE --
THREE CHILDREN WHO ARE IN THOSE
SCHOOLS WILL BY DOING THESE
FORTY AND COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION DEPARTMENT WHAT WE'RE
WE'RE GONNA CAPTURE 98% OF ALL
THOSE KIDS WHO READS WHO MEET
THAT CRITERIA --
OTHER SECTOR OUT REACH OUR OTHER
SECTOR OUT REACH PLAN IS STILL
IN DEVELOPMENT WE HOPE TO COME
OUT WE COME UP WITH THAT COME
OUT WITH THAT FAIRLY SOON --
BUT WE HAVE A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DEDICATED OUT WREATHS --
RELATED TO UNION FAITH BASED
COMMUNITIES BUSINESS
INCORPORATIONS TECHNOLOGY --
AND INNOVATION AND ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY AND YOU'LL SEE THAT
PLAN HERE IN THE VERY NEAR
FUTURE WE'RE ALSO PROPOSE IN
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DEDICATED FOR HEALTH CARE SECTOR --
HEALTH CARE AS WELL --
ESPECIALLY --
THROUGH THE WHAT PROGRAM WHERE
WE HAVE A LOT OF INTERACTION
WITH THE POPULATION THAT WE'RE
TARGETING --
IN THAT WILL HELP US REACH THAT
POPULATION --
THE NEXT SLIDE REALLY STARTS
GOING INTO OUR MEDIA CAMPAIGN
THERE'S NOT MUCH I CAN SAY HERE
BECAUSE WE JUST PUT OUT THE ART
PIECE OR AN ACTIVE SOLICITATION
MODE AT THIS POINT --
WE HAVE SIXTEEN POINT ONE
MILLION A WERE --
ALLOCATED FOR OUR MEDIA CAMPAIGN
AND WE'RE PROPOSING ANOTHER
THIRTY AS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET BUDGET YOU CAN SEE A TIME
LINE HERE --
WE HOPE TO MAKE THE ANNOUNCEMENT
FOR THE WAR THAT CONTRACT AND
STARTING AT THE END OF JUNE --
THE OUTREACH AND PUBLIC
RELATIONS ARE P. REALLY FOCUSES
ON THE CALIFORNIA'S HARD TO
COUNT --
THERE ARE COMPOUND CONTRACTOR
WILL BE REQUIRED TO WORK WITH
LOCAL ETHNIC MEDIA SO THAT WE
CAN TARGET THE HARD TO COUNT
POPULATIONS IN THE BEST MANNER
POSSIBLE THERE WILL BE MESSED
THIS TESTING AND THAT IN
REQUIRED AS PART OF THAT
CONTRACT.
IN THE PRIORITY DEMOGRAPHIC
AUDIENCES ARE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDERS AFRICAN AMERICAN
POPULATIONS LATINO POPULATIONS
ARE TRAVEL POPULATION AS WELL AS
MIDDLE EASTERN NORTH AFRICAN
POPULATION --
THE NEXT LIKE KIND OF GOES INTO
SOME OF THE PROCESS THAT WE'RE
GONNA GO THROUGH RELATED TO
ACTUALLY --
ON MAKING THE WAR THERE'S GOING
TO BE A BETTER CONFERENCE HELD
ON MARCH TWENTY NINTH WE WILL
RANK THE BETTER THE BIDS AS THEY
COME IN AND WE WILL ACTUALLY
CONDUCT ORAL INTERVIEWS WITH THE
TOP.
THREE METERS AND THE WILL
POTENTIALLY NEGOTIATE WITH ONE
OR TWO BETTERS --
AT THE END OF THE DAY TO MAKE
SURE WE GET THE BEST DEAL
POSSIBLE FOR CALIFORNIA.
ON THE NEXT SLIDE TALKS TO OUR
LANGUAGE ACCESS --
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS A CRUCIAL
PART OF EVERYTHING WE DO AND AS
MENTIONED EARLIER LANGUAGE
ACCESS IS AT THE CORE OF
EVERYTHING WE DO HERE IN THE
CENSUS OFFICE.
AT ALL THE OUT REACH SUPPOSED TO
BE DONE AND THE LINGUISTICALLY
APPROPRIATE MANNER --
OUR PARTNERS AS THEY DEVELOP
THEIR MATERIALS WILL MAKE MAKE
SURE THAT THIS HAPPENS --
WE ARE DEVELOPING STANDARDS THAT
WE WANT OUR PARTNER
ORGANIZATIONS TO FOLLOW --
THOSE STANDARDS WE PUT OUT A
DRAFT OF THE STANDARDS AND WE'RE
EXPECTING FEEDBACK ON THAT DRAFT --
OVER THE NEXT --
FEW WEEKS DRAFT ONCE WE RECEIVE
THAT INITIAL FEEDBACK AND FOR
PEOPLE TO REVIEW ONCE AGAIN
GIVEN THE CRITICALITY OF
LANGUAGE ACCESS WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET THIS RIGHT.
OTHER FUNDED EFFORTS INCLUDES A
SET ASIDE OF WHAT WE'VE DONE IS
BASICALLY SATISFIED A SMALL
AMOUNT OF MONEY ONLY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR CONTINGENCIES
EMERGENCIES WE PLAN TO DEPLOY
THESE RESOURCES.
DURING ACTUAL ENUMERATION
PERIODS SO AS EVENTS UNFOLD ON
THE GROUND --
WE CAN QUICKLY AUGMENT --
OUR PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS THE
DOESN'T RESOURCES WHERE WE SEE
AREAS POP UP OF CONCERN SOMEONE
TO MAKE THIS REALLY CLEAR HERE
IS ALL THE CONTRACTS OR
EXECUTING ARE BEING EXECUTED IN
A WAY THAT ALLOW US TO BE VERY
NIMBLE.
SO THAT WE CAN QUICKLY AUGMENT --
EFFORTS ON THE GROUND IF NEED BE.
ADDITIONALLY WILL BE DOING SOME
STATE AGENCY WORKING GROUP
ACTIVITIES THAT WE CAN LEVERAGE
OUR OWN STATE DEPARTMENTS AND
THEY'RE BASICALLY THE TOUCH AS
THEY HAVE WITH THE POPULATIONS
THAT THEY SERVE.
AND WE'VE ALSO AS MENTIONED
EARLIER WE DID THE LOCAL UPDATE
SINCE IT'S THE DRESSES WERE ALSO
PROPOSING A LITTLE BIT OF
FUNDING FOR WHAT'S CALLED TE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING POPULATION
SAMPLE NUMERATION.
AND THEN WE HAVE OUR MINISTRY OF
COSTS AND WHAT WE'RE PRO
PROPOSING AS PART OF OUR OVERALL
OPERATIONS TO ENSURE THAT WE
KEEP OUR MINISTRY OF COSTS NO
MORE THAN 10%.
AND WE'RE HOPING THAT OUR
PARTNERS CAN DO THE SAME AS WELL.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER --
TO OUTREACH EFFORTS AND TEAM.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE INFORMATION
WITH ALL OF YOU.
I'M OTHER IN A MOUNTAINOUS
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF FOR OUT REACH
AND ALSO TRIBAL LIAISON. FOR FOR
ME YOU KNOW IT'S A PLEASURE TO
BE ASKED TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
GROWING TEAM WHICH WE HAVE BEEN
BUILDING SINCE SEPTEMBER WHEN I
CAME ON BOARD SEPTEMBER OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHEN I THINK --
THE THE COMPLETE CAL COMMITTEE
SECRETARY BADGER OR DIRECTOR DE
DESK AT TARGET.
FORMER CHAIRMAN DAN THOUGHT IS --
AND ALSO OUR CHIEF DEPUTY OTHER
THAN US AND HOUSE.
FOR CHOOSING ME. TO TAKE ON THIS
MONUMENTAL CHALLENGE WHICH I
FEEL IS THE DREAM JOB FOR ME AND
EVERY SINGLE PERSON THAT WE HAVE
THE PLEASURE OF INTERVIEWING WHO
HAS COME ON TO THE TEAM.
HAS A LOT OF LIKE WHY SAID THIS
IS THEIR DREAM JOB.
SO THAT WAS FIRST AND FOREMOST
WHAT -- I
PERSONALLY LOOK FOR IN YOU KNOW
REVIEWING OVER A HUNDRED RESUMES
AND EVENTUALLY --
INTERVIEWING FOLKS IS THAT THERE.
THERE ARE HARD AND THEIR SOUL AS
IN ADDITION TO THEIR TALENTS
THEIR SKILLS --
THEIR BACKGROUND.
THAT THEY MUST HAVE THAT
ATTRIBUTE IN ORDER TO JOIN.
A TEAM WHICH IS REALLY.
US A SELECTIVE OF YOU KNOW WE WE
ONLY HAVE FIFTEEN WE HAVE
ROUGHLY.
HALF OF THE COMPLETE COUNT
OFFICE SO THAT'S YOU KNOW AGAIN
A PRIVILEGE WE WE HAVE.
A LOT OF WORK AHEAD OF US --
BUT WERE ALL VERY MUCH
PASSIONATE DOING AND I ONE
ACTUALLY US THE TEAM MEMBERS TO
STAND AGAINST A FEW OF THEM ARE
HERE NOT ALL OF THEM BECAUSE
THEY'RE SCATTERED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE BUT IF YOU.
COULD PLEASE STAND IN.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
YOU KNOW THE THE INDIVIDUAL THAT
YOU SEE HERE AND SOME OF WHICH
ARE LISTENING AND LA OR SAN
DIEGO -- OF
FRESNO WITH THAT'S THE ONE
VACANCY WE STILL HAVE BUT I MUST
SAY THAT.
VALENTINES DAY OF TWENTY
NINETEEN WE HAVE YOU KNOW.
ROUGHLY 70% OF THE TEAM ON BOARD
TWO WEEKS AGO WE GOT TO ABOUT
90% WITH OUR TWO OF OUR LEADS --
AND I'LL TALK ABOUT THAT IN A
SECOND --
AND BOARD AND YOU NOW WE'RE DOWN
TO HIRING ONE MORE ACTUALLY TWO
ONE IS THE FRESNO REGIONAL
PROGRAM MANAGER AND ALSO AN
OFFICE TECH TECH TO SUPPORT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
BUT LIKE I SAID YOU KNOW THE
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE YOU SEE
HERE -- IN A
NUTSHELL. 100% OF US.
IDENTIFY WITH HAVE WORKED
DIRECTLY WITH HARD TO COUNT --
INDIVIDUALS OF ACROSS THE STATE --
I WOULD SAY 90% OF FIRST IN OUR
FAMILY WHETHER IT'S FIRST TO GO
TO COLLEGE --
FIRST TO OWN A HOME --
IMMIGRANTS OURSELVES --
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES SO.
YOU KNOW FIRST FIRST HAND
KNOWLEDGE IN TERMS OF
UNDERSTANDING THE COMPLEXITIES
THE CHALLENGES.
OF ACHIEVING A COMPLETE COUNT
AMONG OUR UNIQUE CALIFORNIA
DEMOGRAPHIC.
AND OUR FOCUS ARE THESE
INDIVIDUALS THE PEOPLE.
BEHIND THE LABELS IF YOU WILL --
THAT ARE THE FIFTEEN HARD TO
COUNT DEMOGRAPHIC POPULATIONS
THAT WE HAVE IDENTIFIED.
AND THAT'S REALLY THE FOCUS OF
OUR PROGRAM.
AND IT IS AGAIN WE ARE LOOKING --
FOR PASSION IN PURSUING THIS
WORK ON THE GROUND AND ALSO VERY
MUCH EQUALLY IMPORTANT IS
GUARDING THE PUBLIC.
TAX DOLLARS THAT ARE BEING
INVESTED THAT WE HAVE BEEN
CHARGED BY ALL OF YOU AND THE
GOVERNOR TO INVEST A
STRATEGICALLY ON WISELY AS
POSSIBLE.
IN REACHING.
THE IN EVERY COMMUNITY ACROSS
OUR STATE. TO ACHIEVE A COMPLETE
COUNT AMONG A 100% OF THE
INHABITANTS ACROSS THE STATE AND
SOMEONE SAID BY CONSTITUTION.
INCLUDING THE HARD TO COUNT.
KNOWING THAT CALIFORNIA'S
CHALLENGES ARE UNIQUE AND YOU
LAYER ON TOP OF THAT THE UNIQUE
ASPECTS OF THIS CENSUS COUNT.
TWENTY TWENTY THE ONLINE OF
DIGITAL RESPONSE THAT IS
EXPECTED BY THE US CENSUS BUREAU
SO WE'RE VERY MINDFUL OF THAT
AND VERY LASER FOCUSED ON MAKING
SURE THAT.
OUR STRATEGIES AND TACTICS ON
THE GROUND BY WORKING WITH OUR
CONTRACTORS --
ARE VERY MUCH THERE WOULD IN ON
THAT.
THE CHIEF ROLES YOU KNOW
FUNDAMENTALLY OF THE REGIONAL
PROGRAM MANAGERS ACROSS THE
STATE AND WE DO HAVE --
FIFTEEN TEAM MEMBERS BUDGETED
FOR AND THAT INCLUDES --
FOR STATEWIDE ROLES BUT THE
REGIONAL PROGRAM MANAGERS WHICH
ARE REGIONALES SIGNED THEIR
FUNDAMENTAL RULES ARE REALLY. TO
MANAGE THE CONTRACTS --
BASICALLY HOLD THE CONTRACTORS
ACCOUNTABLE MAKE SURE THAT THE
PROGRAM --
THERE ARE REACH PROGRAM IS SOUND
AND REALLY REFLECTS THE HIGH
ACCOUNTABILITY STANDARDS
COORDINATION AND TRANSPARENCY
THAT WE HAVE EMBEDDED YOU KNOW
IN TERMS --
YOU KNOW I ALWAYS SAY THIS TO
THE TEAM YOUR LEADERS WITHIN
YOUR YOU YOU'RE THE REGIONAL
PROGRAM MANAGERS WHO WILL.
BE CHARGED WITH --
CONVENING FACILITATING
CONNECTING THE DOTS CONNECTING
PEOPLE IN THE YOU KNOW EACH OF
YOUR REGIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT
AGAIN WE'RE COORDINATING TO
ACHIEVE THE MOST COMPLETE COUNT
POSSIBLE.
AND OUR STATE WAY MATT --
MANAGERS --
INCLUDED LANGUAGE AND
COMMUNICATIONS ACCESS MANAGERS
SO THAT'S LANGUAGE ACCESS AND
ALSO MAKE SURE WE HAVE ACCESS
FOR PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES SO THOSE ARE
EQUALLY IMPORTANT.
AND WE ALSO HAVE A SECTORS --
REACH MANAGER THAT PERSON IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR MAKING SURE WE
ARE LEVERAGING WHAT I CALL LOW
HANGING FRUIT EIGHT SECTORS THAT
WE WILL WORK WITH CLOSELY FROM
AS JUSTIN MENTION FAITH BASED
HEALTH SERVICES.
AMONG OTHERS WHICH WE CAN GET
INTO BUT MY TIME IS RUNNING OUT
AND WE HAVE AN EDUCATION
OUTREACH MANAGER FOR ONE FULL
TIME POSITION BECAUSE THAT IT
THAT WAS LIKE.
BY FAR ONE OF THE SECTORS AS
JUST A MAN CORD FIVE K. THROUGH
TWELVE HIGHER ED.
AND ALSO ADULTS AND VOCATIONAL
EDUCATION --
SYSTEMS.
AND THEN WE HAVE A DEPUTY TRIBAL
LIAISON WHO WORKS WITH ME SHE'S
REALLY THE DAY TO DAY --
FOR ME SHE'S BASED IN SAN DIEGO
AND SHE ALSO WEARS A SECOND HAD
OF BEING REGIONAL PROGRAM
MANAGER SO WE'RE LEAN AND MEAN
AND WE'RE READY TO GO WE KNOW OR
WHATEVER MANDATE IS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND BEFORE GETS --
TO STARTED WITH A COLLEAGUE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AND JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE FOR FOLKS IN
THE PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE WITH US
TODAY. TO MAKE SURE THAT IF YOU
WANT TO SPEAK WILL HAVE A PERIOD
OF PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THE HEARING JUST MAKE SURE TO
SIGN YOUR NAME --
DOWN THE DESK OF THE SERGEANTS
THAT A SIGN IN SHEET IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK DURING THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD.
AND SO WITH THAT ONE TURN OKAY.
MISTER JONES SOURCE.
THANKS.
FOR SO --
I'M REALLY CONCERNED
SPECIFICALLY OF OF ABOUT MY
DISTRICT TO FIFTEEN ACT ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT.
AND I THINK I MENTIONED TO
EARLIER ABOUT --
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT AFTER
AMERICAN LATINOS NOT BEING
COUNTED.
AND I KNOW SOME OF IT'S JUST
TRIVIAL OR SUBLIMINAL OR
WHATEVER.
BUT EVEN WHEN YOU PRODUCE A MAP
LIKE THIS.
NO NO WHO PRODUCED IT.
AND WE'RE NOT ON THE MAP.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
THAT'S A PROBLEM BECAUSE IT
WE'VE BEEN LEFT OUT BEFORE WE
EVEN STARTED.
SO WHOEVER PUT THIS MAP TOGETHER
LEFT UP TO FIFTY NINE ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT I'M TELL YOU WHERE IT
IS TO SOUNDS LIKE YOU DON'T KNOW
WHERE IT IS.
SINCE SOUTH LOS ANGELES.
NORTHERN BORDER IS THE TEN
FREEWAY EAST WEST BORDERS OF
WESTERN ALREADY ALAMEDA OLLIE
DOWN TO MANCHESTER [inaudible]
AND SO.
LOOKING AT THIS I KNOW YOU HAVE
THE OVERALL NUMBERS.
BUT I NEED TO KNOW WHAT YOU PLAN
TO DO IN MY DISTRICT.
AND I'M I'M SAYING THAT NOT TO
BE SELFISH BUT TO BE SELFISH FOR
MY CONSTITUENTS.
BECAUSE IT'S STILL.
IT JUST DRIVES ME NUTS
[inaudible]
WHEN?
THE INDIVIDUALS WERE SUPPOSED TO
BE TAKING CARE OF US.
LEAVE US OUT OF THE EQUATION.
AND SO IF YOU'RE IN THAT WAY
THAT'S GOING TO BE A HUGE
PROBLEM AND REASON I'M ON THIS
COMMITTEE IS TO MAKE SURE.
THAT PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT ONLY
GET COUNTED.
BUT THE FUNDING THE RESOURCES
ARE EVENLY DISTRIBUTED TO MY
DISTRICT AND THAT WE'RE NOT LEFT
OUT.
YOUR LACK OF FIVE FIFTY NICE YOU
LOOK ALL DAY LONG IS NOT THERE.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW.
OBVIOUSLY NOT HERE.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR NUMBERS ARE THE
LOWEST [inaudible]
GOING [inaudible]
FOR OUR YEAH.
OUR THANK YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENT --
MR JOHNSON WHERE ARE REGIONAL
PROGRAM MANAGER AT SEA SO FLOOR
NóI HUSBAND IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH STAFF FROM YOUR OFFICE --
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
AND THE COMIC OUR COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IS THE JUST SELECTED.
ADMINISTRATIVE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION THAT WILL PROBABLY
GO IN THE NEXT TOWN A LITTLE BIT
MORE IN DEPTH INTO EXACTLY HOW
THEY'RE INCORPORATING.
SOUTH LOS ANGELES THAT IS.
ABSOLUTELY TOP OF MIND I MYSELF
AM FROM BOYLE HEIGHTS.
SO I HEAR YOU LOUD AND CLEAR AND
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENT THAT THE
MAP THAT THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THAT --
OUTLINES THE REGION'S AS
MULTIPLE COUNTIES.
BUT I DO KNOW THAT.
G. I. S. MAPPING LEAD JIM MILLER
WAS PART OF OUR TEAM HAS ALREADY --
BECAUSE WE HAVE WE WANTED TO
HAVE THAT INFORMATION AT THE
DISTRICT LEVEL AT THE CITY LEVEL
SO WE HAVE A BREAK DOWN BY.
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT --
IN TERMS OF WHERE THE HARD TO
COUNT ARE --
WITHIN EACH REGION IN A WITHIN
THESE COUNTY SO WE ARE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH --
YOUR OFFICE AGAIN I BELIEVE
CECIL FLOOR NóI FROM OUR TEAM
OUT REACH TEAM HAS ALREADY
STARTED THOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH
YOUR STUFF AT THE DISTRICT --
FIELD OFFICE THE POINT I'M
MAKING IS I'M NOT IN YOUR
DATABASE [inaudible]
OKAY.
I'M JUST SAYING.
IF. ONE OF YOU KNOW ONE LITTLE.
THING LIKE THIS CAN TURN TO
ANOTHER LITTLE THING TO IN THE
LITTLE THING AND THEN I BEHIND
THE BALL.
ADVANI BUT TRYING TO CATCH UP.
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE ME IN
YOUR LIST OF YOU HAVE MY
DISTRICT IN A LIST OF OF PRIOR.
I'M HERE TO MAKE SURE
[inaudible]
THAT.
WE DON'T HAVE LITTLE SLIP UPS
WHICH COULD BE REALLY BE
PROBLEMATIC AS WE MOVE FORWARD
THAT'S ON TRACK YEAH THANK THANK
YOU SOMEONE NUMBER --
SO I THINK I WAS A SENATOR ALSO --
AND THEN I'M GONNA GO TO SOME OF
THE WORD --
CENTER CUT --
CENTER CABALLERO.
I HAVE A COUPLE OF QUICK
QUESTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
MISTER CHAIR I APPRECIATE --
THE THE TIME AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE TODAY AND
FOR GOING THROUGH THE THE
STRATEGY UP TO THIS POINT HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUICK QUESTIONS ONE IS.
YOU HAVE THE MEDIA OUT REACH AT
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS WITH AN
EXTRA THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS CAN
YOU TELL US WHAT.
IT GENERALLY WHAT YOUR STRATEGY
IS IN TERMS OF USE OF THE MEDIA.
AND AND THEN NUMBER TWO IS YOU
TALKED ABOUT HOLDING THE
CONTRACTORS ACCOUNTABLE AND I
THINK THAT'S BEEN ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES MANY TIMES --
FOR GOVERNMENT INSTITUTIONS IS
HOLDING THE CONTRACTORS
ACCOUNTABLE.
WHAT ARE THE METRICS THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO USE TO HOLD A BIG IT'S
A LOT OF MONEY GOING OUT AND
IT'S GOING OUT IN A REALLY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME --
SOME REAL WELL MEANING
ORGANIZATIONS BUT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE HIRING STAFF AND SO I KNOW
WHAT I DO IN A POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN IN TERMS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY BUT I'M WONDERING
IF YOU HAVE SOME METRICS YOU'RE
GOING TO BE USING.
AND IF YOU COULD TELL US A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW YOU
EVALUATE WHETHER THE MONEY
YOU'RE SENDING TO A PARTICULAR
ORGANIZATION IS BEING WELL SPENT
SPENT.
SURE I AGAIN JUSTIN HOWARD HAD
DEPUTY SECRETARY AT DEVOPS --
TO ANSWER THE THE FIRST PART OF
THE QUESTION ABOUT MEDIA AS AS I
MENTIONED THE MEDIA OF P. IS OUT
THERE WHAT WE'RE PLANNING ON
DOING IS.
POTENTIALLY OR IN A PRIME CONTRA
TO THOSE LOCAL ETHNIC MEDIAS THE
IDEA IS THAT THE THE THE MEDIA
THAT'S BEING DONE WHETHER IT'S
OR MEDIA ARE PAID MEDIA.
IS GOING TO SUPPLEMENT THE
EFFORTS ON THE GROUND SO FOR
HOLDING EVENTS OVER DOING OUT
REACHING A PARTICULAR COMMUNITY
WILL THEN LAYER ON TOP OF THAT
MEDIA IN THAT PARTICULAR AREA AS
WELL -- FROM
THOSE EFFORTS --
IT'S HARD TO GO INTO MORE DETAIL
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA BE PROPOSED
WE'RE REQUESTING PLANTS FROM OUR
FOLKS RIGHT NOW AND WE'LL BE
EVALUATING THOSE PLANS AS THEY
COME IN.
AND AND AS MENTIONED WE'LL GO
THROUGH A PROCESS OF OF
INTERVIEWING THE TOP --
THREE FOR POTENTIAL WAR AND AND
WE COULD ACTUALLY MAKE MORE THAN
ONE WAR AND WE HAVE THAT
FLEXIBILITY THAT WE PROVIDED IN
THE MEDIA CONTRACT --
ARE THEN WE ARE ASKED P. ASKS
ATTY ACCOUNTABILITY KIND OF IT
IS VERY IMPORTANT SOMEWHAT WE
HAVE STRUCTURED IS IS
DELIVERABLE BASE CONTRACTS SO
ALL THE CONTRACTS HAVE A
REQUIREMENT TO SUBMIT CERTAIN
DELIVERABLES TO THE STATE.
WHICH EIGHT RAWNESS TEEN ON THE
REGIONAL PROGRAM MANAGERS --
WILL REVIEW AND APPROVE SO AND
IF YOU DO A DELIVERABLE AND IT'S
NOT APPROVED BY THE TEAM IT
COULD BE A REPORT IT COULD BE IN
A CERTAIN ACTIVITY ON ACTIVITIES
SUCH AS USING OUR STATEWIDE
OUTREACH RAPID DEPLOYMENT TOLL
HAVE YOU BEEN UPLOADING YOUR
ACTIVITY WITH YOUR OUTREACH
ACTIVITIES.
AND THAT DATABASE WILL BE
REVIEWING THOSE AND EVERYONE IS
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT THESE REPORTS
AND THEY DON'T GET PAID UNLESS
THOSE THINGS HAVE BEEN DONE SO
WE CAN SEE WHAT'S GOING ON FROM --
FIGHT A HOLISTIC LEVEL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IMPORTANTLY
TO AS PART OF THAT CHIP SEEN
OTHER THINGS --
WHAT THIS IS GOING TO HELP SHIPS
EXCUSE ME TO CALIFORNIA SOME OF
THE ACTIVITIES THAT --
WE HAVE FUNDED I'M SO WE CAN GET
A SENSE OF WHETHER THE DOLLARS
WERE WELL SPENT OR NOT AND
WHETHER OR NOT OUR MESSAGING WAS
ACTUALLY RECEIVED IN THE
COMMUNITY --
SO BETWEEN OUR OUR ONLINE TOOL
AND OUR QUESTIONNAIRE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO DEVELOP AS PART OF THAT
SAMPLE ENUMERATION WILL HAVE A
GOOD SENSE OF WHETHER OR NOT WE
WERE SUCCESSFUL IN REACHING THE
COMMUNITY --
THE THE COMMUNITY THAT WERE
TARGETING HARD TO COUNT
POPULATIONS.
IF I COULD --
I I GUESS ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
THINGS I WAS HOPING I'D HERE IS
THAT. ONE OF THE METRICS IS THAT
PEOPLE ACTUALLY DO.
FILL OUT THE QUESTION THAT THE
QUESTIONNAIRES OR THAT THEY DO --
DO WHATEVER IT'S REQUIRED
WHETHER IT'S GET ON THE INTERNET
FILL OUT PAPERWORK IT JUST SEEMS
TO ME THAT.
THAT IT'S NOT ENOUGH JUST TO
HOLD MEETINGS AND TO TALK TO
PEOPLE AND TO YOU KNOW.
BE FRIENDLY SURE I MEAN WE
REALLY THIS IS REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT WE WE HAVE SOME
NUMBERS.
THAT HE REALLY INDICATE THAT
PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY DOING WHAT
WE NEED THEM TO DO IN ORDER TO
SATISFY HIS SENSES QUESTION OR
NOT THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND
I FAILED TO MENTION IS ONE THING
THAT WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE U. S.
CENSUS BUREAU WHAT WE'RE GOING.
TO BE GETTING IS REAL TIME
RESPONSES TOOL IS WE'RE GONNA
LAYER IN THOSE RESPONSE RATES
INTO OUR INTERACTIVE MAP MEANS
THAT WE CAN SEE WHERE THOSE
RESPONSE RATES ARE IN RELATION
TO THE OUTREACH EFFORT THAT
WE'RE DOING SO FOR HOLDEN EVENTS
IN A CERTAIN COMMUNITY.
HOW IS THE RESPONSE RATE GOING
IS AT HIGHS AND LOW IN PART OF
THAT IS SO THAT WE CAN THEN
QUICKLY?
CHANGE RESOURCES IF WE NEED TO
ST HEY WE'RE DOING REALLY GOOD
OVER HERE BUT IT'S SUPER LOW
OVER HERE AND WE CAN WE CAN
DIRECTOR CONTRACTORS.
THROUGH THE PROVISIONS IN OUR
CONTRACTS AND YOU NEEDED SHIP TO
RESOURCES FROM THIS AREA TO THIS
YEAR BECAUSE OF THE RESPONSE
RATES ARE COMING IN VERY.
BAD IN THIS AREA SO THOSE ARE
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE MAKE
TO MORE MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
INCLUDED.
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
SANTA ROSA THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
COUPLE QUESTIONS --
WHAT IS THE TOTAL NUMBER
TARGETED?
OF AND WHAT IS THE NUMBER THAT
YOU EXPECT US TO REACH.
WELL I MEAN I I'M SURE YOU HAVE
THAT NOT JUST FOR STATEWIDE BUT
YOU MUST HAVE THAT FOR REGION'S.
SURE SO WE WE CAN GET YOU THE
BREAKDOWN BY REGION THAT WERE
REALLY I BELIEVE THE NUMBERS ALL
THIRTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION --
HARD TO COUNT POPULATION WITHIN
CALIFORNIA OFFICE ACTUALLY --
EVERYONE'S A LITTLE OVER FIFTEEN
MILLION.
LIKE A LITTLE OVER 50% OR LET
THE IN ALL AND THEN THERE'S A
FURTHER BREAKDOWN.
BUT IT'S IT'S OVER FIFTEEN
MILLION AND YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
FACTORS IS THAT OVER 27% OF THAT
HARD TO COUNT.
THEIR FOREIGN BORN SO IT'S
ANOTHER --
UNIQUE CHALLENGE YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S UNIQUE AMONG.
BUT THE THREE OF THEM AT THE END
OF TEN MILLION AS HARD TO COUNT.
TARGETED NUMBER.
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING.
TO GET TO DO WHAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO WHICH IS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CENSUS
CORRECT THAT'S ENOUGH.
OKAY ANOTHER QUESTION IS --
ON THE EDUCATION SECTOR OUT
REACH -- I
KNOW IN TALKING TO SOME FOLKS --
WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT CATION ON
AS INSTITUTIONS --
ESPECIALLY --
K. THROUGH TWELVE OR EVEN
YOUNGER.
THAT WE HAVE OR INFRASTRUCTURE
THERE.
THAT IS VERY EFFECTIVE.
OR COULD BE VERY EFFECTIVE AND I
KNOW THAT PART OF THE POPULATION
OF HARD TO COUNT I HAVE HEARD I
UNDERSTAND.
ART NOT COUNTING OUR BABIES AND
OUR CHILDREN.
SO -- I
DON'T SEE HOW.
A MILLION LESS THAN TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE ENTIRE STATE.
IN THE EDUCATION SECTOR.
COULD POSSIBLY WORK I MEAN IT
SOUNDS IMPOSSIBLE --
IF WE'RE GOING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF SOME OF THE WHAT ALREADY
EXISTS. TO GET THE MOST OUT OF
IT AND MAYBE THERE ARE OTHER --
EDUCATIONAL YOU KNOW MAYBE CARE
PROVIDERS ON THE ANSWER BUT BUT
CERTAINLY OUR K. THROUGH.
TWELVE SO HOW HOW WOULD YOU.
I KNOW YOU SAY CAPTURES 98% OF
TARGETED POPULATION BUT AS
SENATOR CABALLERO SAID.
JUST.
JUST SAYING YOU DID SOMETHING TO
REACH OUT TO THEM DOESN'T MEAN
YOU'VE ACTUALLY CAPTURED THE SO
HOW CAN YOU.
SPEND MORE TIME DESCRIBING THAT.
SURE SO AS PART OF THE AT
EDUCATION SECTOR OUT REACH --
I WOULD I WOULD KEEP IN MIND
FIRST THAT YOU KNOW WHAT THE
POPULATION WERE TARGETING AT
MULTIPLE TOUCHES FROM DIFFERENT
GROUPS RIGHT SO WHAT WE'RE
ASKING OUR EDUCATION BASED
SCHOOLS TO DO IS.
IS BASICALLY --
LOOK AT THAT LOOK AT THE REASON
WE'RE PROVIDING THE RESOURCES TO
IDENTIFY THOSE LOCATIONS WHERE
THEY CAN SET UP KIOSKS WHERE
THEY CAN LEVERAGE THEIR PARENT
RESOURCE CENTERS WHERE THEY CAN
HAPPEN QUESTIONER SYSTEM CENTER
STAY OPEN LATE TO ALLOW PEOPLE
TO COME IN UTILIZED.
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT MANY OF THE
SCHOOLS HAVE RELATED TO BE ABLE
TO HOPEFULLY GO ONLINE AND FILL
OUT THE CENSUS FORM.
WE'RE ALSO ASKING THEM TO REALLY
DO -- BIG
WHAT'S BASICALLY WEEK WE HAVE
TURNED US CENSUS WEEK WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO GO OUT AND DO
AT HAVE ALL THE SCHOOLS AT THE
SAME TIME CONDUCT SINCE THIS
WEEK ACTIVITIES --
RELATED TO THE CENSUS AND WE'RE
ALSO BUILDING IN --
FOR OUR FOR OUR SCHOOLS EFFORTS
RELATED --
TO A CURRICULUM AND GROUPS --
SO THAT WE CAN TEACH ABOUT THE
CENSUS DURING THE ACTUAL --
SPRING PERIOD WHEN THE CENSUS IS
GOING ON TO MAKE IT --
FRESH IN EVERYONE'S MIND WITH
THE WITH THE GOAL THAT IF YOU
TEACH ABOUT IT NOW THEY'LL REACH
REMEMBER IT FOR THE LONG TERM
CONTINUE.
TO PAY IT FORWARD AS THEY THE
LONG THROUGH THEIR LIFESTYLE AND
HOPEFULLY THE CHRISTIAN CAN THEN
GET EMBEDDED IN THE SCHOOL --
OVERALL CORRECT THEM ON ONGOING
BASIS SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE.
TO JUST DO IT ONCE EVERY TEN
YEARS.
THE YOUR MUCH AS A RUNNING
PLEASE SIT AT THIS ONE NOTE ON
THE ZERO FIVE THAT'S ACTUALLY
ONE OF OUR FIFTEEN HARD TO
COUNTER MY GRAPHICS AND WE WE
ARE BEING AS RESTORE RESOURCEFUL
AS POSSIBLE WITH THE BUDGET THAT
WE DO HAVE.
BUT A COUPLE OF STRATEGIES ARE --
ALSO THROUGH OUR SECTOR OUT
REACH.
WITH THE HEALTH SERVICES
INDUSTRY --
WORKING WITH --
FOR EXAMPLE DEPARTMENTS LIKE --
HELP THE SOCIAL SERVICE AND THIS
IS THE IN THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL ADDITIONAL EARMARKED --
FOR WORKING THROUGH WOMEN
INFANTS AND CHILDREN PROGRAMS --
INCLUDING THAT CLINICS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO THE
HEALTH SERVICES INDUSTRY IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT AND TERMS OF OUR
PART OF OUR STRATEGY AND MAKE
SURE WE REACH THE ZERO TO FIVE
AND THIS --
THE THIRD OF FIVE OF THE
CHALLENGE THAT IS PARTICULARLY
PREVALENT AMONG LET THE IN ALL
RECENT IMMIGRANT FAMILIES AND
ALSO SOME OF THE ASIAN AMERICAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER SO.
VERY IMPORTANT WORK.
OKAY I'M SORRY PLEASE MORE OF IT
JUST DOESN'T SEEM LIKE.
MAYBE WITH WE JUST CAN.
NO TALK MORE OFF LINE BUT JUST
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE IT'S MATCHING.
THE HARD TO COUNT AT THAT AGE.
YOU KNOW WITH THE RESOURCES THAT
ARE BEING SPENT IN TOTAL SO.
I WOULD JUST URGE.
LOOK AT THAT AGAIN BECAUSE I IT.
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE AND I'VE BEEN
WITH THE CAMPAIGN SO WE SAY ON
THE GROUND ON THE GROUND AND
THEN WE SPEND.
YOU KNOW ZILLION DOLLARS ON
MEDIA -- AND
WE DON'T REALLY DO AS AGAIN
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE HAVE OUR
SCHOOLS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHILD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS OF A FIRST QUESTION IS --
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE SPECIFIC
MEASURES THAT ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE OR TO BE IMPLEMENTED?
A TO SAFEGUARD THE AN
INDIVIDUAL'S PRIVACY AND DOZENS
THERE'S A NUMBER OF DATA POINTS
THAT ARE PERTINENT AND RELEVANT --
TO PROTECTING YOUR PRIVACY
WHETHER IT'S OF THE COLLECTION
OF THE DATA ITSELF OR THE
TRANSMISSION OF THE DATA OR
DISTORTED THAT IT DATA.
WHETHER OR NOT THE DATA INCLUDES
TO CITIZENSHIP QUESTION OR
OTHERWISE I THINK THERE'S A
NUMBER YOU KNOW THERE'S A NUMBER
OF IMPORTANT AREAS THAT WE NEED
TO SAFEGUARD AGAIN USERS HAVE
BEEN PUT IN PLACE OR A TO BE
IMPLEMENTED --
SO THAT WE CAN --
YOU KNOW --
SHARED THE INDIVIDUALS OF THEIR
PRIVACY BEING PROTECTED
[inaudible]
HELLO SIR.
SO.
THIS IS WHERE --
YOU KNOW AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
THE U. S. CENSUS BUREAU HAS.
IT ME THIS IS MY CONSTITUTION
ABSOLUTELY I REMEMBER BEING PART
OF THE TWO THOUSAND CAMPAIGN I
WAS FOR THE CALIFORNIA COMPLETE
CALENDAR THEN GOVERNOR DAVIS.
THAT WAS AND STILL IS WILL BE.
ONE OF THE CHIEF --
CHALLENGES IS.
ENCOURAGING PROCESS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WE CAN --
REASSURE WE ARE --
THEN HAVE ASKED THE BUREAU AND
WE'RE EXPECTING TO HAVE --
YOU KNOW MORE TOOLS MORE
COLLATERAL MORE --
WHETHER IT'S INFOGRAPHICS
WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE BECAUSE
THERE ARE DISTINCT NEEDS AMONG
WHETHER IT'S A TRIBAL --
GOVERNMENT OR WHETHER IT'S A
PARTICULAR --
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
ASKING FOR A DIFFERENT WAY OF
REASSURING AND HAVING THAT
LANGUAGE BUT THAT'S A PROTECTION
THAT.
BY CONSTITUTION --
IT EXISTS BUT IT IS ONE OF THE
CHIEF CHALLENGES AND WE PLAN TO
DEFINITELY GET THAT INFORMATION
OUT HOW DO WE AT THE STATE LEVEL
MONITOR WHAT THE GOVERNMENT.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT IS IS
DOING THE RIGHT THING WHETHER OR
NOT THERE DO YOU KNOW BASICALLY
PROTECTING THE PRIVACY OF THE
INDIVIDUALS.
ARE. FOR LACK OF A BETTER TERM
IT'S NOT AN OVERSIGHT SITUATION
BUT YOU KNOW WE AT LEAST WE NEED
TO KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S BEEN
GOING ON AND HOW THEY'RE USING
THE COMPUTER SYSTEM AND AND SO
ON SO FORTH.
RIGHT SO WE WE'VE ENGAGED QUITE
A BIT WITH THE U. S. CENSUS
BUREAU ON THE ISSUE OF PRIVACY
OF THE DATA --
AS YOUR WHERE THEY'RE THE ONES
ACTUALLY DO THE ENUMERATION
COLLECT THE DATA AND THEREFORE
STORE IT NOT US --
AND A LOT OF WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
WE'RE MAKING WE'RE GOING TO
PAINSTAKING A LINKS TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE NOT COLLECTING PERSONAL
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION OF THE
PEOPLE THAT WE'RE CONDUCTING NOT
REACH.
TO BUT HAVING SAID THAT WE'VE
ENGAGED QUITE A BIT.
SO THAT WE CAN HELP WITH THAT
MESSAGING TO OUR COMMUNITY BASED
PARTNERS --
ON THE GROUND SO THEY CAN THEN
RELAY THAT TO FOLKS --
WE WE RUN INTO CERTAIN
CHALLENGES WITH THEM WE HOLD THE
WEAPON ARE SPECIFICALLY RELATED --
TO DATA PRIVACY --
YOU KNOW THE THE WILLINGNESS TO
SHARE ALL THEIR EFFORTS IS IT IS
NOT NECESSARY THEIR FOR FEAR OF
IF THEY MAKE CERTAIN THINGS
PUBLIC AND THEY WOULD ACTUALLY
LEAD TO POTENTIAL ISSUES OF
PEOPLE TRYING --
TO SO BURKE WHAT THAT THE
SAFEGUARDS THAT THEY WOULD PUT
IN PLACE TO IT'S POSSIBLE TO
FORCE TO BASICALLY GET IN TOUCH
WITH YOUR OFFICE TO SEE WHAT HAS
BEEN GOING ON TO CUT.
ON MONITORS SORT OF FOR LIKE A
YES ABSOLUTELY AND WE WE LIVE
LED TO SHARE THE PRESENTATION
FROM OUR WEAPON ARE WITH YOU AS
WELL CONTACT SECOND QUESTION
DEALS WITH THE OVERALL PICTURE.
HI IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE PAST DUE TO PREVIOUS OUR
SENSES --
ENDED UP --
IN UNDER COUNTS SO --
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE LESSONS
THAT WE HAVE LEARNED FROM THOSE --
EXPERIENCES A SPECIFICALLY
WHETHER IT WAS IT WAS IT BECAUSE
OF THE LANGUAGE ACCESS OR IN THE
SELECTION OF COMMUNITY GROUPS OR
YOU KNOW VERY SPECIFIC ITEMS
FROM THE PREVIOUS TO OUR SENSES
THAT WE CAN LEARN FROM.
AND TO AVOID BASICALLY JUST I'M
AROUND.
SO I I THINK THE VERY FIRST
THING THAT WE LEARNED WAS THAT
IT.
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHATEVER OUTREACH WE DO IS
DONE BY TRUSTED MESSENGERS
THAT'S WHAT WAS LEARNED IN THE
PREVIOUS CENSUSES THAT YOU CAN'T
DO IT AT A STATEWIDE LEVEL HERE
IN SACRAMENTO REALLY NEEDS TO BE
DONE IN THE COMMUNITY.
BY THOSE ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
THE DAILY INTERACTION WITH THE
POPULATION THE ONES THAT THEY
TRUST THE MOST --
SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE WITH OUR CAMPAIGN IS
MAKING SURE WHERE.
FUNDING --
THOSE THOSE LOCAL ETHNIC
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
GET THAT MESSAGE OUT BECAUSE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE THE MOST
TRUSTED PEOPLE WHEN WHEN
SOMEBODY COMES AND SAYS HEY
PARTICIPATE IN THE CENSUS AGAIN
YOU DON'T WANT TO SEE MYSELF.
TELLING YOU TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE CENSUS YOU NEED THE RIGHT
PEOPLE TO DO IT SO THAT THAT'S
PROBABLY THE FIRST AND FOREMOST
THING THAT WE LEARNED IN THAT
WERE TRYING --
TO EMPLOYMENT AS OUR STRATEGY
HERE'S TO FUN THAT WHICH IS WHY
WE'RE PUSHING THE DOLLARS DOWN
TO THE LOCAL.
YEAH GRANTED GRANTED THAT THE
FUNDING SITUATION OR LACK THERE
OFFICE WILL YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
FIRST AND FOREMOST BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT IT DIRECTOR FUNDING AS YOU
KNOW THE NEXT IMPORTANT QUESTION.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AND IT'S ONE WORD
DOLLARS.
THANK YOU I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE CBO'S ROLE
IN HOW THAT --
I'M ASSUMING OF COURSE THEY GET
THE MONEY AND THEN THEY'RE
FINDING SMALLER CBO'S TO
DISTRIBUTE THAT TWO WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
I'M FROM EIGHT AT CONSTITUENCIES
STANDPOINT I CAN IMAGINE THAT
THIS MAY CAUSE --
SOME CONCERNED WITH OUR OUR
LITTLE NONPROFITS WHO MAY GET
THE MONEY OR MAY NOT GET THE
MONEY WITH AN ART ARE DISTRICTS
SO THAT'S WHY I HAVE SOME OF
THESE QUESTIONS IN ANTICIPATION
OF THINGS THAT MIGHT HAPPEN
ESPECIALLY.
I MEAN I LOVE THE UNITED WAY
SENIOR COUNTY YOU SIT ON THE
BOARD -- I
THINK THEY REPLACE BEING HAVE
ONE OTHER NOW LATINO ON THEIR
BOARD ON WHICH IS NICE BUT
PROBABLY NOT --
FULLY EMBRACED BY THE COMMUNITY
IN THAT SENSE RIGHT --
SO IS THERE ARE.
GUIDELINES FOR THE CBO'S WITH
THREE THE SEAT SMALLER CBO'S
ACTING LEFT TO EACH REGION ARE
THEY GONNA UP FRONT THE MONEY OR
THEY THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TIME
HERE IT'S ON PAYMENTS AND
REIMBURSEMENTS --
SO AS OF RIGHT NOW WE HAVE NOT
PUT OUT SPECIFIC GUIDELINES FOR
THE SUBCONTRACTING FROM A CBO
DOWN TO THE CBO'S.
AND WE DON'T WANT TO INSTITUTE A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH THEM
KNOWING THAT EVERY --
ENTITY WHO WE MADE IN A WAR TO
MAY OPERATE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY SOUND SO NOW THAT
WE'VE MADE THOSE AWARDS WE ARE
NOT GOING THROUGH THE ACTUAL
LEADING OF THE CONTRACTS IT'S
GOING TO TAKE A COUPLE WEEKS.
IN SOME OF THOSE THINGS WILL BE
DETERMINED AS WE HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM --
BUT WE DO WANT TO GIVE THEM THE
FLEXIBILITY TO HOPEFULLY MAKE
THE RIGHT DECISION ON HOW THEY
WANT TO DO THE SUBCONTRACTING
FROM A TECHNICAL PERSPECTIVE.
FROM EIGHT ORGANIZATION MATCH UP
PERSPECTIVE --
IF THERE ARE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE INTERESTED AND
SUBCONTRACTING OPPORTUNITIES
WITH THE AN ADMINISTRATIVE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION WHO
GOT AN AWARD.
I'M ADRIAAN IS TEAM WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO AND WE JUST SENT
THIS OUT ON FRIDAY WE ARE
WEBSITE AS WELL.
AS WE'VE BASICALLY CREATED AN
INTEREST FORM SO IF YOU'RE AN
ORGANIZATION AND YOU CAN GO TO
OUR WEBSITE YOU CAN ENTER YOUR
INFORMATION FOR YOUR
ORGANIZATION WHAT --
REGION OF THE STATE YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN --
I IS THERE A PARTICULAR --
TARGETED --
HARD TO COUNT AS THEY THEN
CONDUCT THEIR REGULARLY
SCHEDULED MEETINGS WITH AC BILLS
THEY WILL MATCH THEM UP AND THEN
BRING THEM TOGETHER IN A ROOM SO
THAT THEY CAN HAVE THAT OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT THEIR
CAPABILITIES ARE.
AND WHAT THEY CAN POSSIBLY FIND
SO FOR OUR PURPOSES A WIN THESE
RULES COME DOWN OR NO RULES IT
SOUNDS LIKE NO NO PRESCRIPTIVE
RULES --
WILL THERE BE SO IT AS WE ARE
CONTACTED BY SOME OF THESE
GROUPS A WHO DON'T GET GRANTS OR
BE WHO GET GRANTS BUT THE
PAYMENT IS NOT TIMELY OR THEY
HAVE SOME DISPUTES ABOUT.
WHAT'S BEING REIMBURSED BECAUSE
I GUARANTEE IT LIKE THIS IS WHAT
I ANTICIPATE HEARING --
WILL THERE BE SOMEBODY THAT WE
WILL BE IN TOUCH WITH WILL THERE
BE LIKE AN ARMY SPOKESMAN IN
YOUR OFFICE THAT WILL DEAL --
WITH THE A CBO ARE WE GONNA BE
RESPONSIBLE.
FOR DIRECTLY TRYING TO GET.
THE UNITY HAVE STAFF WITHIN OUR
OFFICE SHOULD THERE BE PAYMENT
ISSUES BETWEEN THE THE AT AND
MINISTRY OF AN A COMMUNITY BASED
ONE LIKE WISE VERSUS THE STATE.
ADMINISTRATIVE --
ON WE HAVE A SCHEDULE OF
PAYMENTS THAT'S LAID OUT IN THE
R. S. P. FOR WHICH WERE GIVEN TO
THE AWARDS SO PAYMENTS WILL GO
OUT OF PARTY THAT SCHEDULE SO
MEAN THE DELIVERABLES ARE MET --
SO IT'S WERE PRETTY UP FRONT
TRANSPARENT ABOUT HOW WE'RE
SENDING OUT THE MONEY TO OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WE'LL HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THEM ON WHAT'S THE BEST APPROACH
FOR THEM BEFORE WE LET THEIR
CONTRACT AND WHAT ARE THOSE
DELIVERABLES.
IT'S IT'S BEEN FOR THE MOST PART
IT IS WITH THE YOUR TD PLANS
THEIR IMPLEMENTATION PLANS AND
THEN THE FOLLOW UP TO THAT
INCLUDING ALL THE DATA THAT GOES
ALONG WITH THAT.
THAT WE WANT TO PUT INTO OUR
STATEWIDE --
ONLINE TOOLS THAT WE CAN MAP
WHAT'S BEING DONE FOR PURPOSES
OF SEEN HOW EFFECTIVE WE ARE
HOPEFULLY DEPLOYING THE
RESOURCES CHOI AND TO WEAR AREAS
WHERE WE SEE ISSUES AND I I
THINK THIS IS REALLY TOUGH FOR
ME THAT THIS IS A BALANCE RIGHT
SO.
PROBABLY THE MOST EFFECTIVE
CBO'S ARE THE LEAST LIKELY TO BE
EFFECTIVE IN FILLING OUT THAT
PAPERWORK BUT THEY'RE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE IN ACTUALLY REACHING
THE COMMUNITY.
WE KIND OF HAVE A A DISCONNECT
BETWEEN THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ACTUALLY IN THE COMMUNITY AND
THOSE PEOPLE CAN HIRE GRANT
WRITER OR SO THAT'S ONE REASON
WHY WE WENT WITH THE A. CDOS
BECAUSE THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO HAVE
BE THE EXPERTS IN PROVIDING
ADMINISTRATIVE OVERSIGHT
ADMINISTRATIVE CAPABILITIES TO
HELP.
THOSE SMALLER CBO AND THEY'LL BE
CHOOSING THEM I'M SORRY THIS IS
LIKE BUT THEY'LL BE CHOOSING
THEM HOW LIKE BASED ON THEIR
STAFF THEIR BOARD WILL CHOOSE
WITH.
IT'S JUST KIND OF A A BIG
DISCONNECT I I WOULD THINK
BETWEEN.
THE A. CBO'S AT LEAST IN AND MY
REGION AND THE ACTUAL CBO IS ON
THE GROUND AND I'M JUST
WONDERING WHO'S.
PROVIDING ARE YOU JUST FEEL
CONFIDENT THOSE CHOICES THAT
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE MORE
RELATIONSHIPS AND WE SEE.
THIS IS THE A A REALLY
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION AND THIS
IS WHERE THE REGIONAL PROGRAM
MANAGERS ON THE OUT REACH TEAM.
REALLY PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE AS
LEADERS.
THEY WILL HERE FOR A AND THEY
HAVE BEEN HEARING FROM SOME OF
THE SMALLER CBO'S.
A WITH ANY TO REGION WHETHER
IT'S WITHIN THE CITY OF
COMMUNITY AT CETERA.
AND SO THE RULE THE RPM REGIONAL
PROGRAM MANAGER --
IS FACILITATING THOSE
INTRODUCTIONS ULTIMATELY FOR THE
RPM WHERE THEY HOLD THAT THE
PRIME CONTRACTOR ACCOUNTABLE
WHETHER IT'S A COUNTY WHETHER
IT'S A ADMINISTRATIVE CBO OR
EVENTUALLY THE ONES WILL
ANNOUNCE ON FRIDAY THE STATEWIDE --
CBO'S IT'S IN THE PROGRAM
ELEMENTS THE REQUIREMENTS THAT
MUST BE AND ANY OF THE STRATEGIC
PLANS YOU KNOW FROM LANGUAGE AND
COMMUNICATION ACCESS --
STANDARDS YOU KNOW SPECIFIC --
TO EACH REGION LIKE JUSTIN SAID
EVERY REGION AND COMMUNITY.
THEY'RE IN VERY DISTINCT --
OR WHETHER IT'S A VOLUNTEER PLAN --
INNOVATIVE WAYS OF REACHING THE
HARD TO COUNT FOLKS GIVEN THE
UNIQUE ELEMENTS THIS TIME OF
WHAT THE SENATE CENSUS BUREAU
EXPECTS --
FROM DIGITAL ONLINE RESPONSE.
AT CETERA SOCIAL MEDIA HARPER
LOCAL --
TACTICS SO THEY'RE ELEVEN
DISTINCT ELEMENTS --
THAT.
ARE REGIONAL PROGRAM MANAGERS
WILL BE LOOKING AT THROUGH.
CONSTANT COMMUNICATION WITH THE
PRIME CONTRACTORS AND ALSO WITH
THE SUBS EVENTUALLY WE HAVE
BUILT IN A PROCESS WHERE THE
CONTRACTORS ARE REQUIRED TO
REPORT THEIR MONTHLY MEETINGS.
TO THE RPM ON HOW THEY ARE WHICH
THE RPM WILL LOOK AT THOSE
ELEVEN ELEMENTS AND PROVIDE
FEEDBACK ON YOUR MISSING --
A CRITICAL LANGUAGE WHETHER IT'S
MYSTICAL INVENTOR COUNTY AND
CLEARLY THERE'S A HARD TO COUNT
SIGNIFICANT POPULATION THERE
THAT SPEAKS MYSTICAL AND THEY
HAVE THEY DON'T HAVE THAT IN
THEIR PLAN.
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA PULL THEM
ACCOUNTABLE --
OR RPM'S FOR THE PAST TWO MONTHS
AS THE TEAM HAS BEEN GROWING
THEY HAVE BEEN REACHING OUT PRO
ACTIVELY.
TO THE COUNTIES THEY'RE IN
CONTACT WITH COUNTY LEADS ACROSS
THE DIFFERENT REGIONS --
NOW THAT THE A. CBO'S HAVE BEEN
AWARDED THEY'VE BEEN REACHING
OUT TO THE TO THE CENSUS LEADS
WITHIN THE CBO SO --
DEFINITELY WILL AS YOU HEAR FROM
YOUR CONSTITUENTS --
AND THEN THE THIRD CALL THE
THIRD ROUND OF CALLS OUR TEAMS
HAVE BEEN BUSY --
MAKING ARE REACHING OUT --
TO YOUR YOUR DISTRICT STAFF. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY USE THAT
YOUR STUFF ARE AWARE OF OUR
PROGRAM AND AND MAKE SURE THE
ADDRESS YOUR CONCERNS AND
QUESTIONS.
GREAT THANK YOU --
NEXT UP WE HAVE.
THIS NOVEMBER COLORADO.
THANK YOU --
SO CAN YOU ALSO SHARE WITH ME
AGAIN THE THE PRINTED AND THE
DIGITAL --
MATERIALS WILL BE OUT.
AND THE VETTING PROCESS FOR THE
TESTING ESPECIALLY FOR THE
DIGITAL --
REFERRING TO THE US CENSUS
BUREAU -- SO
MY UNDERSTANDING IS.
AND LATE MARCH --
EVERYONE WILL --
NOT EVERYONE BUT THOSE HAVE BEEN
SELECTED WILL ALL GET LIKE A
POSTCARD IN THE MAIL.
ON THAT POSTCARD YOU'LL BASS
IT'LL BASICALLY HAVING A UNIQUE
IDENTIFIER NUMBER FOR YOUR
HOUSEHOLD --
AT THAT POINT IN TIME THEY WILL
OPEN UP THE CENSUS TO OUR OPEN
UP THE PROCESS WHILE YOU GO
ONLINE -- TO
HOPEFULLY.
VOLUNTARILY FILL OUT THE THE
CENSUS FORM --
APRIL FIRST IS THE ACTUAL CENSUS
DAY IN AND OF ITSELF --
THIS PROCESS WILL CONTINUE WHERE
YOU'LL GET DO YOU ACTUALLY GET
IN THE MAIL THE FORM --
SO IF YOU DON'T UTILIZE THE
ONLINE PROCESS YOU WILL
EVENTUALLY BE FOLLOWED UP BY THE
US CENSUS BUREAU --
WITH A MALE FORM --
IT AGAIN THAT'LL THAT OCCUR ONCE
OR TWICE I BELIEVE AND THEN
AFTER THAT IF YOU DON'T RESPOND
TO THE MAIL FORM YOU'LL ACTUALLY
HAVE SOMEBODY FROM THE US CENSUS
BUREAU COME TO YOUR HOUSEHOLD
AND ULTIMATELY KNOCK ON YOUR
DOOR.
AND HOPEFULLY GET YOU TO FILL
OUT THE FORM IN PERSON --
THERE ARE MULTIPLE WAYS WHERE
YOU CAN FILL OUT THE FORM CAN BE
ONLINE YOU CAN DO IT VIA
TELEPHONE --
OR IN PERSON --
AND EITHER THROUGH ONE OF OUR
QUESTIONNAIRE SYSTEM CENTERS ARE
CHAOS THAT WE'RE GONNA SET UP OR
THROUGH SOME TYPE OF COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS SET UP SOME
PROCESS TO USE A TABLET.
OKAY AND SO TO KIND OF FOLLOW UP
ON WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER THÅU
ASKING.
HOW ARE WE PREPARING FOR DEALING
WITH CYBERSECURITY --
FAKE NEWS --
YOU KNOW BOB SO I MEAN THERE'S A
HYPERSENSITIVITY AROUND WHAT
PEOPLE SEE AND BELIEVE TO BE
TRUE ON SOCIAL MEDIA --
YOU KNOW SOME OF THOSE PLATFORMS
HAVE LESS CREDIBILITY NOW WITH
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES SO HOW ARE
WE PREPARING FOR THEM.
SO PART OF OUR MEDIA ARE
INCLUDES A REQUIREMENT RELATED --
TO DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGNS AND
THINGS THAT GET REPORTED.
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT SOME OTHER --
TECHNIQUES FROM A COUPLE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WE'VE BEEN CONTACT WITH THAT
COULD HELP REPORT THAT
INFORMATION MORE VASTLY TO US
THAT WE CAN REACT QUICKER WHEN
PEOPLE SEE.
ON THIS TYPE OF CAMPAIGNS --
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL --
SO DID MY FINAL QUESTION SERVE.
GOING OFF OF THAT AND ALSO WHEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZWAS
ASKING THEM IT'S ABOUT THIS
NOTION AROUND TRUSTED MESSENGERS
AND PARTNERING WITH CBO'S --
IN THE COMMUNITY YOU KNOW YOUR
IDEA OF A TRUSTED MESSENGER AND
MY IDEA OF A TRUSTED MESSENGER
MAY NOT BE THE SAME.
RIGHT AND SO AS WE ARE
CONSIDERING NONTRADITIONAL YOU
KNOW.
CBO'S OR NONTRADITIONAL
COMMUNITY LEADERS REACHING OUT
TO THOSE FOLKS THAT REALLY KIND
OF HAVE --
CREDIBILITY WITHIN COMMUNITIES.
I HAVEN'T REALLY BEEN HEARING.
A LOT ABOUT THAT AND I ACTUALLY
THINK THAT WE HAVE UNINTENTIONAL
THERE IS BIAS.
IN WHO WE CONSIDER TO BE TRUSTED
MESSENGER AND WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SOMETHING AS SERIOUS.
AS COUNTING EVERYONE SOMETIMES I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT AND EVEN
WITHIN THE SYSTEMS THAT WERE
DEVELOPING THAT WE LOOK TO SAY.
HEY YOU KNOW MY MAKING SOME
ASSUMPTIONS.
ABOUT THE KIND OF TRUSTED
MESSENGER THAT I'D WANT TO WORK
WITH SO THAT WE'RE WILLING TO
CONTRACT WITH BECAUSE YOU KNOW
ABC ORGANIZATION MIGHT BE GREAT.
BUT POOKIE.
MAY ACTUALLY HAVE THE BEST
RELATIONSHIP.
AND HAVE THE LONGEST TENTACLES
INTO THE COMMUNITY BUT IN OUR
EFFORT TO BE PROFESSIONAL AND
OUR EFFORT TO BE KIND OF
INCLUSIVE IN OUR EFFORT TO BE
ALL OF THESE THINGS.
ARE BIAS.
ENCOURAGES US TO MARGINALIZE
EVEN SOME OF THOSE YOU KNOW
COMMUNITY GROUPS --
YOU KNOW NONTRADITIONAL.
COMMUNITY --
STAKEHOLDER SO CAN WE KIND OF
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE I THINK IF WE'VE DONE
THIS MULTIPLE TIMES AND WE'VE
STILL BEEN UNDER COUNTY.
THEN THERE'S SOME THINGS THAT
WERE NOT DOING RIGHT THAT MAYBE
WE CONTINUE.
TO YOU KNOW WANT TO DO AND IT'S
LIKE JUST I HOPE THAT WE STOP
HITTING HER HEAD AGAINST THE
SAME WALL.
SO CAN YOU SPEAK TO THEM.
AND ANOTHER WAS A LOT
[inaudible]
SURE.
THOSE WERE ALL EYES AND EARS ON
A LOCAL LEVEL REALLY COME INTO
PLAY BECAUSE I KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
YOU ALL ARE TALKING ABOUT. FOR
US IT --
AGAIN BECAUSE WE WERE RELATIVELY
LEAN AND MEAN TEAM WE DEFINITELY
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
GUARDING THE THE THE DOLLARS
THAT ARE INVESTED WE HAVE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE CBO --
STRUCTURE HOWEVER --
THE MEMBERS OF THE OUT REACH
TEAM --
WORKING IN IN YOU KNOW HIP TO
HAVE WITH WHETHER IT'S MEMBERS
OF YOUR FIELD STAFF THE COUNTY
THE CITIES WITHIN THE COUNTIES
BECAUSE WE ARE FORCING FOR
EXAMPLE THE CITIES I MEAN THE
COUNTY SO DEFINITELY EVEN THOUGH
WE DON'T CONTRACT WITH THE CITY
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT THOSE CITIES ARE ARE
INCLUDED IN THE IN THE EFFORT --
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL EYES
AND EARS LOCALLY.
ARE ARE INFORMING US GIVING US
FEEDBACK ON SOME POSSIBLE --
COLLABORATORS THAT WE MAY NOT
YET HAVE HAVE AT THE TABLE I
THINK THAT'S WAS ILLUSTRATED BY.
THE FACT THAT WE WILL BE
REQUIRING THE CONTRACTORS WITH
WITH OUR OFFICE --
TO CHECK IN.
MINIMALLY EVERY MONTH REALLY
IT'S IT'S ONE WEEKLY BASIS YOU
KNOW MAKING SURE THAT --
IF WE HEAR WHETHER IT'S SOMEONE
FROM YOUR OFFICE OR SOMEONE IN
THE COMMUNITY SAYING HEY I'M
I'VE GOT AN EXPERTISE IN THIS
AREA AND I REALLY WANT TO BE
PART OF THIS PROCESS.
THAT WE ALLOW THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT YOU KNOW
MARRYING THEM UP WITH THE WITH
THE CONTRACTORS THAT WERE
WORKING WITH BECAUSE WE
ABSOLUTELY --
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ALLOW --
THOSE --
OPPORTUNITIES TO HAPPEN LAKE
LOCALS IS IT YOU KNOW LA HAD THE
HOMELESS COUNT DATE FIGURE OUT
WAYS TO BE VERY GRASSROOTS AND
TO EXPAND THEIR REACH AS WIDE AS
POSSIBLE.
YOU KNOW I MEAN I REMEMBER WHEN
WE WERE ENROLLING FOLKS AND
COVER CALIFORNIA.
SO MANY CHALLENGES UNTIL THE
ELEVENTH HOUR WHEN PEOPLE
REACHED OUT AND SAID HEY AND IT
WAS A SIMPLE AS COMING UP WITH
AN IDEA LIKE PUT A KIOSK IN THE
MALL.
YOU NOBODY SHOULDN'T HAVE THAT
SHOULDN'T COME UP AT THE
ELEVENTH HOUR.
U KNOW WHAT I MEAN
SO.
MAYBE I CAN EXPAND A LITTLE BIT
I MEAN ALL THESE AREAS ALL THAT
WE'RE MAKING IT WORKS IS ALL
PARTICIPATE IN WHAT'S CALLED A
LOCAL COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEE.
AND OUR RPM'S ARE ALSO --
ATTENDING THESE LOCAL COMPLETE
COUNT COMMITTEE SO WE HAVE ONE
AT THE STATE LEVEL OR GETTING
IDEAS AND FEEDBACK --
FROM FROM WHAT WE'RE DOING BUT
ALL THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
ARE ARE ARE AND THE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
PARTICIPATE IN LOCAL ONES WHERE
THEY SHOULD BE GETTING THAT TYPE
OF INFORMATION ABOUT WHO IS THE
BEST ENTITY. TO DO OUTREACH TO
THE SPECIFIC GROUP AND OUR AREA
IN DOING THAT THAT AIM AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WE'RE WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO BE TOO PRESCRIPTIVE AT
THE STATE LEVEL JUST FOR THE
REASON THAT YOU MENTIONED IS
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT GONNA KNOW
KNOWING US WE TYPICALLY PUT A
LOT.
OF REALLY STRICT REQUIREMENTS ON
THINGS BUT WE WANT THEM TO HAVE
SOME FLEXIBILITY TO DO THAT
BETTING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WHAT
WHO IS THE BEST ORGANIZATION TO
DO THAT OUT REACH --
WE CAN'T PRESCRIBE THAT HERE SO
THAT WE CAN BE AS HELPFUL AS
POSSIBLE AND MAKING SURE THAT
THE RIGHT INFORMATION IS GETTING
TO THE RIGHT GROUPS IN OUR
DISTRICT.
THAT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL THE
OTHER THING.
I THINK YOU MENTIONED EARLIER
THAT BANGING OUR HEADS AGAINST
THE SAME WALL WE HAVE NEW TOOLS
THIS YEAR THAT WE'VE NEVER HAD
BEFORE.
THEY'RE MUCH MORE PRECISE RIGHT
DOWN INTO THE NEIGHBORHOODS --
OF THE HARD TO COUNT AREAS SO WE
CAN RAPIDLY DEPLOY PEOPLE ONCE
WE HAVE THE UNDERSTANDING IS
ANYTHING ON IT AND JUSTIN HAVE
DESCRIBED THE PROCESS IF WE ARE.
LEARNING THROUGH THE DATA
COLLECTION THAT THERE ARE AND
THROUGH OUR COORDINATION WITH
OUR OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT THERE ARE
CERTAIN AREAS THAT WHETHER IT'S
BECAUSE OF MISTRUST OR OTHER
KINDS OF THINGS THAT WE'RE NOT
GETTING WE CAN RAPIDLY DEPLOY.
INTO THOSE AREAS THE TRUSTED
MESSENGERS TO COLLECT THAT AT TO
HELP --
ORGANIZE THOSE THOSE INDIVIDUAL
HOUSEHOLDS OR PEOPLE AND MAKE
SURE WHETHER TO HOMELESS AREA OR
AT AND NEIGHBORHOOD --
WE WILL DEPLOY THE THE I
COORDINATED EFFORT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IN PEOPLE WITH FIFTEEN
MILLION PEOPLE WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED THAT ARE GOING TO BE
VERY DIFFICULT ACCOUNT.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE NEW TOOLS BUT
YOU ALSO HAVE NEW DANGERS SO YES
WE DO DARK MEDIA IS VERY
FRIGHTENING.
AND WE WE'RE GOING TO DO RAPID
DEPLOYMENT AROUND OUR MEDIA IS
WELL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER I'M BURKE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
FEW QUESTIONS.
HOW LONG DO YOU ANTICIPATE WILL
TAKE AN INDIVIDUAL FILL OUT A
FORM?
WE'VE I THINK THE CENSUS OFFICES --
WAS IT TEN MINUTES WELL.
WE ONLY US AND OUR COMMITTEE
ASKED THAT AT A RECENT QUARTERLY
MEETING AND THE ESTIMATE IS
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY MINUTES --
WE'VE ALSO LEARNED FROM THE
BUREAU THAT --
ONE MUST COMPLETE THE ONLINE
QUESTIONNAIRE AND ONE SITTING IN
OTHER WORDS.
IT'S NOT A PROCESS WHERE ONE CAN
SIT AND STARTED SAVE IT AND COME
BACK TO IT LATER SO IT HAS TO BE
COMPLETED.
ONCE SO IF IT TAKES IN.
SO IT TAKES TWENTY ABOUT HEAD OF
HOUSEHOLD IS THERE IS A LONGER
PERIOD OF TIME IF YOUR HEAD OF
HOUSEHOLD LET'S SAY YOU'VE GOT
THE HOUSEHOLD WITH FOUR MEMBERS
HOW LONG WOULD THAT TAKE.
THE SENSE OF THIS SO I I THINK
THEY GIVE US AN AVERAGE SO IT'S
SOME ORGAN SOMERBY QUICKER
SUMMER BE LONGER JUST DEPENDING
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE IN YOUR
HOUSEHOLD SO SOMEWHERE AROUND.
WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE AVERAGE
FIFTEEN MINUTES I TENANTS --
INFORMED US WAS FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY MINUTES.
OKAY --
DEPEND ON HOW MANY PEOPLE IN THE
HOUSEHOLD UHHUH.
THAT SOUNDS KIND ALONG TO ME --
ALL RIGHT SO IN TERMS OF THE
ONLINE.
APPLICATIONS ARE THEY THE
PROCESS BEING TESTED RIGHT NOW
NOT THAT THERE'S EVER BEEN
NINETY ISSUE WITH THE
GOVERNMENTAL.
BILL OR ORGANIZATION JUST
CURIOUS --
SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS IS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS DONE
THEIR ONLINE TESTING BUT I MEAN
I WOULD NEED TO GET A SPECIFIC
RESPONSE FROM THEM THEY'RE THE
ONES ACTUALLY ARE DOING THE
ENUMERATION PROCESS AND DOING
ALL THAT THEY DID A A
COMPREHENSIVE --
FEEL PASSED AND I BELIEVE IT WAS
SOMEWHERE IN DELAWARE IT WAS IN
PROVIDENCE RHODE ISLAND IT'S A
SINGLE LOCATION WHERE THEY HAVE
TESTED.
OKAY AT ARE THEY GONNA TESTING
CALIFORNIA AT ALL [inaudible]
NOW [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
IN -- IN
ORDER TO I THINK THERE'S
CONSENSUS THAT WE WANT TO HAVE
IS ACCURATE ACCOUNT AS IS
HUMANLY POSSIBLE OR EVEN
ELECTRONICALLY POSSIBLE --
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT WE NEED
AS LAWMAKERS TO DO TO FACILITATE
THAT SO FORGET EXAMPLE THIS.
IS ONE ONE EXAMPLE SCHOOLS --
ANYTHING WE NEED TO CHANGE THE
CODE. TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR US
TO BE ABLE --
TO FOR EXAMPLE IN PARENT TEACHER
NIGHT MAKE SURE THAT THAT WE'RE
COUNTING EVERYBODY.
WILL SAY ONE THING.
TO ONE WHERE WE HAVE COMMITTED
ALREADY TO SOME OF YOUR STUFF --
WITH BECAUSE WE HAVE HEARD FROM
A FEW LEGISLATORS ALSO.
THAT WE WILL PROVIDE --
TALKING POINTS THAT YOU MAY
INSERT AND WE WOULD HIGHLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO INSERT IN ANY
FORM OR PUBLIC SPEAKING
ENGAGEMENT WHETHER IT'S AT A
SCHOOL. TO JUST START TO EDUCATE
AND IMPRESS UPON YOUR
CONSTITUENTS THE IMPORTANT.
THAT THAT'S THE THAT I
APPRECIATE THAT THAT'S A LITTLE
DIFFERENT THAN THE QUESTION I'M
ASKING SO IS THERE SOME CHANGE
IN THE LAW.
THAT NEEDS TO BE ME I I GET THE
WILL GET TALKING POINTS AND WE
SHOULD BE.
PROSELYTISING IT WILL DO THAT SO
IS THERE ANYTHING IN LAW THAT
NEEDS TO BE CHANGED I GOT YOU I
ALSO GOT MORE RESOURCES PART I
GOT THAT PART BUT I'M AWARE OF
AND THEN YOU NEED.
FOR FOR ANY KIND OF CHANGE IN
STATUTE --
THAT WOULD ENGAGE THE
LEGISLATURE ANY DIFFERENTLY THAN
I THINK IT WAS WONDERFUL THAT
YOU ALL APPOINTED A PERSON AT
THE DISTRICT LEVEL TO BE A
CENSUS POINT OF CONTACT THAT WAS
ENORMOUSLY HELPFUL TO US --
AS WELL AS HAVE SOMEBODY HERE
INSTEAD REACH OUT TO BUT I'M NOT
AWARE OF ANY --
STATUTORY CHANGE THAT HAS COME
UP IN ANY OF OUR CONVERSATIONS
EITHER WITH THE BUREAU OR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COMPLETE COUNT
COMMITTEE --
NOT AWARE OF SO FOR EXAMPLE
CONDITION OF ENROLLMENT AND ONE
OF THE UNIVERSITIES OF
CALIFORNIA WHEN THE CAMPUSES.
IS IT OKAY IF WE ASK IS A
CONDITION ONE MOMENT.
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT YOU'VE BEEN
PARTICIPATED IN THE CENSUS OF
BEEN ENUMERATED.
POLLY HANSON YOU KNOW WHAT IT
WILL TAKE YOUR COMMON APPRECIATE
YOUR INPUT WE'RE IN THE PROCESS
RIGHT NOW OF DEVELOPING THE
HIGHER END.
ENGAGEMENT --
OUR SELF IS OUR SERVICE ALL
RELATIVELY NEW WE FULLY
DEVELOPED THE K. THROUGH TWELVE
YOU KNOW JUST TO MENTION THE
INVESTMENT IN THE FUNDING I'M
FORTY COUNTY OFFICES OF IT
ACROSS THE STATE.
THE HIGHER EDUCATION PIECE WE
ARE.
WE ARE STILL.
DEVELOPING AND FINALIZING.
SOMEONE TO TAKE YOUR QUESTION I
YOUR COMMENT AND HAVE OUR TEAM.
LOOK INTO THAT SPECIFIC QUESTION
YEAH THERE'S A SUGGESTION WE WE
SENT DEVICES BY LOWERING TUITION --
I I'LL JUST SAY AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO HAVE THAT THERE'S GREAT IF
THERE'S IDEAS OUT THERE THAT YOU
HEAR THAT WE HAVE IN HERE WE
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR WHAT THOSE
IDEAS ARE SO THAT WE CAN TAKE
THEM INTO CONSIDERATION AND HOW
WOULD THAT WORK AND EVERYTHING
THAT WE'RE DOING --
YOU HEAR ABOUT IDEAS YOU KNOW I
WIN RIGHT OKAY SIX FLOOR.
I KNOW YOU'VE THOUGHT THROUGH
THIS.
ANY.
CONTACTED WHETHER OR NOT WE CAN.
AND IF WE CAN WHETHER WE WANT.
TO FOR EXAMPLE GETTING A
DRIVER'S LICENSE TO WE WANT TO
MAKE THAT PART OF GETTING A
DRIVER'S LICENSE HAVE YOU
PARTICIPATE IN THE CENSUS I
REALIZE IT'S A SENSITIVE ISSUE.
BUT IT'S NOT MORE SENSITIVE THAN
THAN THAN THE THE CITIZENSHIP
QUESTION WE WE'VE I FIND THAT TO
BE INSIDIOUS THAT DOESN'T
CITIZENSHIP QUESTION POTENTIALLY
ON THE BALLOT BUT BUT WE WANT TO
COUNT EVERYBODY.
SO I GUESS MY QUESTION TO YOU IS
WHETHER WE EXPLORED ALL
LEGITIMATE.
WAYS TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE GETS
COUNTED BUT NOT.
NOT NOT INTIMIDATE ANYBODY.
I THINK THE ONE THING WE HAVE
CONSIDERED AND THOUGHT THROUGH
AND TALKED ABOUT.
ALMOST SINCE THE BEGINNING WHEN
CENSUSES MOVED INTO GOV OPS IS
USING STATE ENTITIES THAT ARE
THE TOUCH POINTS I THINK A
DROWNING MENTIONED WITH FOR
EXAMPLE.
THE OTHER IMPORTANT TOUCH POINTS
THAT THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
TOUCH SERVE GOVERNMENT SERVICES
FOR IS TO USE THEM AS
INFORMATION --
SOURCES SO NOT NOT ASKING BUT
PUSHING OUT INFORMATION HOW
IMPORTANT CENSUSES HOW IMPORTANT
THEIR PARTICIPATION IS --
THAT WE INDEED WILL DO.
OKAY I GOT THANKS I GOT THE
CARROT PART OF CENTER PAN.
THANKS VERY MUCH AND AGAIN I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
RESPONSES SORT QUESTIONS --
SHOWS THINKING LIKE IT'S APRIL
WE SHOULD GIVE HER ONE LIKE A
DOLLAR TAX DEDUCTION FOR THE
FINAL ON THE STATE TAXES.
OKAY SAME TIME --
SO I THINK THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT --
WE'VE --
PROP IS TOTALLY OF COURSE THIS
IS THE U. S. CENSUS WE'RE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
EVERYONE CALIFORNIA BUT WE HAVE
TO INTERFACE WITH THE U. S. AT
THIS OFFICE.
I KNOW THAT SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE MADE SOME
REMARKS ABOUT --
I THINK UNFORTUNATELY THE
CURRENT MINISTRATION --
MAYBE SELLING SOME THIS TRUSTS --
IN BOTH --
THOSE DIRECTLY IN ACTIONS TO
CENSUS RELATION THIS AS A
QUESTION BUT ALSO INDIRECTLY
THROUGH THE TYPE OF RHETORIC WE
ALSO KNOW THOUGH THAT --
THE CENSUS BUREAU PROFESSIONALS
WHO ACTUALLY STAFF TO BURROW I
THINK ARE VERY DEDICATED AND AND
WANT TO SEE A SUCCESSFUL SENSES
THAT IS CONSTITUTIONAL --
BUT I GUESS MY QUESTION THOUGH
IS WITH THE CENSUS OFFICE.
DO YOU FEEL THAT --
GIVEN YOUR ACTIVITIES RIGHT NOW
IS THIS IS THIS SOMETHING WHERE
POLICE.
ANTICIPATES ANY CHALLENGES IN
TERMS OUR INTERFACE WITH THE
CENSUS OFFICE ARE --
IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO HAVE
THAT KIND OF RAPID FEEDBACK YOU
GET A D. ESPECIALLY WHEN CENSUS
TIME COMES AROUND I MEAN.
WE'RE TALKING AND IT'S LIKE A
CAMPAIGN RIGHT AND SO YOU'RE
THAT LASTED IS THAT LAST MONTH
BEFORE ELECTION DAY WHEN
EVERYONE'S GOT TO MAIL IN
BALLOTS IN NEEDHAM WITH THE TURN
IT IN RIGHT SO YOU DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF TIME.
TO MESS AROUND LOOKING TO SPEAK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE U. S.
CENSUS OFFICE.
YES THE THE OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE US CENSUS BUREAU
REGIONAL OF THE WHOLE WESTERN
REGIONAL TEAM --
IS EXCELLENT YOU KNOW WE ARE HIP
TO HIP WE LIKE TO DESCRIBE IT WE
HAVE TO BE.
WE JUST HAD A JOINT OF FIRST
STREET TO STRATEGIC MEETING LAST
WEEK. FOUR DAYS AGO HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WITH THEIR THEIR
NEWLY HIRED --
OUTREACH COORDINATOR SO OVERSEE
THE PARTNERSHIP SPECIALISTS AND
THEY'RE ALSO STILL GROWING.
YEAH I'VE GOT TO PEOPLE MORE TO
HIRE THEY HAVE OF A HANDFUL MORE.
AND OF COURSE THEN THEY'LL GET.
HUNDREDS OF ENUMERATORS AND WE
WILL BE HAVING MORE THAN JOINT
MEETINGS TO UNDERSTAND HOW TO
COORDINATE HOW TO COLLABORATE
HOW.
TO MAKE SURE THAT FOR FOR OUR
PURPOSES HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WE ABSOLUTELY --
THROUGH OUR ACTORS BECAUSE THAT
IS ONE OF THE REQUIREMENTS IS A
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT HOW WILL
THEY HELP FACILITATE MAKING SURE
THAT FOLKS.
SOME OF THESE NEWLY TRUSTED
MESSENGERS FOLKS --
IN THE COMMUNITY.
HAVE A SHOT AT THESE THE US
CENSUS BUREAU JOBS AS THE
NUMERATORS BECAUSE THEY ARE THE
TRUSTED MESSENGERS.
SO IT'S IT'S EXCELLENT AND YOU
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF DETAIL
BEHIND ALL THAT BUT JUST TO SAY
THAT.
THEIR HANDS A LITTLE BIT TIED IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEY SAY IN TERMS
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
WASHINGTON DC.
AT THE DEPARTMENT LEVEL.
AND IN TERMS OF IT WOULD YOU
KNOW WE TALK ABOUT JUSTIN
MESSENGERS AND SO FORTH --
YEAH -- YOU
TALKED ABOUT THIS CERTAINLY DID
PORTENTS OF THE REGIONAL PROGRAM
MANAGERS --
BUT I THINK WHAT YOU HEAR IS --
YOU AND GET YOU KNOW THE
REGIONAL THE AC --
BUT TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY ABLE TO THAT THEY'RE
TOUCHING EVERYONE AND I KNOW
THAT ONE THE CHALLENGES I THINK
SOME PEOPLE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
IS IS THAT AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
WHAT HAPPENS USING IN A CBO IS
AN INTERFACE BECAUSE OF THE
STATE.
WE HAVE CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS WE
HAVE ON OUR MONEY APPRECIATE
ACCOUNTABILITY PART AND
CERTAINLY I WANT PEOPLE TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE BUT ALSO WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE.
THE ELSE SO MY COLLEAGUES RAY
MENTIONED --
EFFECTIVE PEOPLE MAY NOT BE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE OUT ITS THEY
DON'T HAVE YOU KNOW --
THEY MEAN I'D BE YOU KNOW THEY
MEAN I'VE IN THAT YOU KNOW HAVE
SOME KIND OF TAX STATUS OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT COULD BE AN
INDIVIDUAL RIGHT OUR GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS.
AND HOW TO BE SURE WE GET DOWN
TO THAT AND ACTUALLY FRANKLY
ALSO ON THE MEDIA SIDE.
RIGHT -- SO
YOU KNOW YOU START TALKING OKAY
GREAT THE BIG MEDIA COMPANIES
EASY YOU START DRILLING DOWN
WEDNESDAY AT THE MEDIA WHAT YOU
MEAN BY ETHNIC MEDIA RIGHT AND
AND SO WE REALLY DOWN OR MEDIA
THING.
AGAIN AND SO I'M HOPING IS IS
THAT MAYBE YOU CAN JUST TOUCH ON
IT TO DO IT YOU KNOW WE ALL HAVE
DISTRICT OFFICES SO WE DON'T
KNOW EVERYBODY BUT THEY KNOW A
LOT OF PEOPLE --
AND CERTAINLY WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S A ROLE FOR THE REGIONAL
PROGRAM MANAGERS TO BUT THE
GREEN THAT --
THERE COULD BE SOME KIND OF
REQUIREMENT THAT IS THEY'RE
DOING TO MEDIA BUYS AND THEY'RE
ON THE LOCAL LEVEL AND THEY'RE
DOING THAT OUR REACH THAT THEY
ACTUALLY CHECK IN AND THAT WE
GET INPUTS ARE DISTRICT OFFICES
GET INPUT INTO BE SURE THAT
THEY'VE.
GOT THEY'VE ACTUALLY HAD PEOPLE
THAT MAYBE OUR DISTRICT OFFICES
OF WORKED WITH A NO THROUGH.
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT --
THAT -- WE
HAD THAT WE GET SOUTH BEACH SO
IS THAT SOME ANSWERING
ABSOLUTELY AS I MENTIONED BEFORE
I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE MEDIA BUT
I'LL SPEAK TO THE ON THE OUT
REACH AS I MENTIONED.
BEFORE THE REGIONAL PROGRAM
MANAGERS OR REQUIRED YOU KNOW
THEY'VE THEY'VE.
EVERY WEEK THEY ARE CHECKING AND
REACHING OUT JUST WITHIN THE
PAST TWO WEEKS SO I I JUST.
I I THINK THAT THERE'S AROUND ME
TO CUT IT OFF BY IT AND BUT WE
ARE STILL SHOWING TIME I MEAN I
GUESS I WANT TO BE SURE IS THAT.
NO DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS AND I
YOU KNOW I I HAVE A LOT OF FAITH
IN MY THE ACBL IN MY AREA AND
I'VE WORKED WITH THEM BEFORE BUT
YOU KNOW PEOPLE HAVE BLIND SPOTS
THEY HAVE PEOPLE THERE USED TO
WORKING WITH AND SOMETIMES
THAT'S NOT ALWAYS THE PEOPLE
WHOM.
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT DECLARE --
MARGINALIZED POPULATIONS ARE
COMMUNITIES --
SOME ARE BETTER AT WORKING WITH
SOME THAN OTHERS AND SO WE WANT
TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
COVER ALL THOSE BLIND SPOTS AND
IN WE HAVE SOME BLIND SPOTS IN A
DISTRICT OFFICES BUT I THINK WE
START OVERLAPPING BE SURE
THEY'RE SUFFICIENT.
THEN -- TO
SURE WE CAN GET THOSE RESOURCES
INTO THIS IT AND AND TO ALL THE
PARTS OF OUR COMMUNITY AND I
APPRECIATE THAT.
THE ANSWER IS YES AND I LOOK
FORWARD HOW WE FOLLOW THROUGH ON
OUR QUESTION I ALSO HAVE.
IS -- IS IN
TERMS OF LANGUAGE ACCESS --
ARE YOU GONNA HAVE LANGUAGE
ACCESS REQUIREMENTS ARE GONNA
FORCE ON THE COUNTY CPOS IN THE
MEDIA TO BE SURE THAT WE'RE AT A
NO THE SPOKE.
TO SOME OF THAT BUT IT TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE REACHING OUT TO ALL
COMMITTEE CERTAINLY SOMETHING
IMPORTANT FOR MANY COMMITTEES
INCLUDING THIS --
OUR API COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO
MANY OTHERS AS WELL SO --
ARE YOU GONNA HAVE REQUIREMENTS
TO BE SURE THAT --
NOT JUST LIKE THE TOP FIVE
NECESSARILY.
IT MEANS GET FAR MUCH FARTHER
DOWN WE KNOW THAT A FORTUNE THE
US CENSUS TO REDUCING THE NUMBER
OF LANGUAGES THAT THEIR OF
PUTTING THINGS INTO AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL SO THAT MAKES EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
PEOPLE.
WHO ARE REACHING OUT AND AND AND
AT THE STATE OUR STATE OUT REACH?
YES IT WILL BE REQUIRED --
LAST WEEK WE PROVIDED AN INTERIM%
SET OF STANDARDS WHICH THEY WERE
INTERIM BECAUSE THEY'RE MEANT.
TO GET INPUT FROM OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS --
FROM ANY OF YOU AND ANYONE FROM
THE PUBLIC WHICH WE WE HAVE BUT
THEY ARE REQUIREMENTS --
EVERY REGION WILL BE DIFFERENT --
WE ARE CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS
OF OF RECEIVING --
AND ANALYZING TO DETERMINE WHAT
THAT THRESHOLD SHOULD BE --
YOU KNOW PER REGION BUT FOR THE
BIDS AS AN EXAMPLE WE ASK THAT
EACH BIDDER FOR THE REGIONALLY
CBO CONTRACTS.
THAT THEY TALK ABOUT A MINIMUM
OF SIX LANGUAGES IN THEIR
PARTICULAR REGION THE TOP.
SIX BUT MOST RESPONDED WITH A
BID THAT INCLUDED --
TWELVE OR MORE AND WE WILL
REQUIRE EVERY REGION WILL BE
DIFFERENT IT DEPENDS --
IT DEPENDS ON YOU KNOW.
HOW MANY LANGUAGES --
ARE WE ARE WE REACHING --
99% OF THE POPULATION IT ALL
AGAIN WE HAVE OUR LANGUAGE AND
OUR RE AND LANGUAGE AND
COMMUNICATIONS ACCESS MANAGER WE
FULLY -- SET
ASIDE IN OUR BUDGET FOR ONE FULL
TIME STAFF BECAUSE THIS IS SUCH
AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF THE
OUT REACH --
BUT I KNOW I'M FREE SHEET THAT
AND I THINK --
WELL WHEN YOU'RE OF IN THE THE
PERSONAL CHECK WITH.
CHAIR BERMAN YET BUT I JUST WANT
TO MENTION THAT SO WHY ALSO
WANTED SO AGAIN AYE SIR BACK TO
REITERATE ON THE DISTRICT
OFFICES SO.
I THINK THAT WOULD LIKE TO WORK
WITH YOU IN MORE DETAIL EXACTLY
LIKE WHAT THE ROLE --
VARIOUS DISTRICT OFFICES CAN
PLAY IN PROVIDING INPUT AS TO
WHICH MEDIA --
THE LOCAL ACADEMIC LOCAL MEDIA --
THAT SHOULD BE INVOLVED --
AND AS WELL AS OF COURSE --
I DON'T COME EVEN ORGANIZATIONS
FRANKLY THE PEOPLE AND
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SHOULD BE
REACHED OUT --
TO TO TO BE SURE WE HAVE AT AND
THE ROLE THAT OUR DISTRICT
OFFICE COMPLAIN PROVIDING DOWN
INPUT BASHING THE DECISION
MAKING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AT YOUR PAN AND WE
HAVE HAD YOU AND I HAVE AN
AGENCY CONNECT BUT MY STAFF --
BRIEF ME AND AND SO I FULLY
AGREE WITH YOUR YOUR DESIRE TO
HAVE A SEPARATE HEARING JUST ON
LANGUAGE ACCESS ISSUES THAT THEY
WILL PROBABLY ALSO HAVE A
SEPARATE HEARING.
SPECIFICALLY ON THE MEDIA
CAMPAIGN STRATEGY IS THAT GETS A
LITTLE MORE DEVELOPED ONCE THE
THE FOLKS REPLIED OUR FEES --
SO --
QUESTION THAT I HAD IT WAS THE
TO THE LEGISLATURE SHOW THAT THE
STATEWIDE OUR REGION
COMMUNICATION STRATEGY.
IS SCHEDULED TO BE FINALIZED BY
DECEMBER OF TWENTY NINETEEN IS
THAT CORRECT --
I BELIEVE YOU'RE REFERRING TO
THE STATEWIDE OUR REGION
COMMUNICATION STRATEGY THE JOCKS
EXACTLY AND SEPTEMBER.
I THINK IT'S IT'S MOSTLY A
FINALIZED TOWARDS THE END OF
THIS CALENDAR YEAR THAT IS
CORRECT TOWARD THE END OF INDIAN
IN ON PLANETS ROCK KIND OF SOUND
NOW WE'RE GONNA BE SEEKING. TO
ADD TO IT AS WE GET ALL THE
FEEDBACK AND WE GO THROUGH
BASICALLY OUR IMPLEMENTATION --
CONVENIENCE FOR LACK OF A BETTER
WORD THAT WE'RE DOING OVER THE
SUMMER AND HAS PLAN START
DEVELOP WILL BE FOR UP THE SOCKS
SO THAT WHEN WE HIT WE HAVE THE
TWENTY TWENTY WERE READY TO GO
OKAY AND THAT THAT MAKES ME A
LITTLE NERVOUS --
IN JUST IN THE IN THE SENSE THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE FINALIZING THE
STRATEGY ONLY THREE MONTHS
BEFORE.
CENSUS DAY --
TWENTY TWENTY AND I KNOW THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE --
YOU KNOW THE THE ROBUST PROCESS
AND A LOT OUR REGION
COMMUNICATION MEET HEARINGS
WHICH I KNOW YOU ALL OF ALREADY
HAD --
INCLUDING TWENTY FOUR LAST YEAR --
SO I GUESS WHAT I WOULD SAY IS
DON'T AND WE CAN'T WAIT UNTIL
TOO LATE BEFORE YOU TAKE BECAUSE
INEVITABLY WE'RE GONNA FIND OUT
THAT SOME PARTS OF THE PLANE
DON'T AREN'T WORKING IN ONE THE
TO TO CAN I CHANGE.
DIRECTION.
AND JUST TO CLARIFY THE BY
REGION THE IMPLEMENTATION
PLANNING WORKSHOPS WHICH JUST TO
MENTION WHICH IS KIND OF LIKE
LOOSELY THE SECOND ROUND OF
CONVENING --
MANY OF YOUR YOUR STUFF OR
INVOLVED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WHICH WAS A READINESS ASSESSMENT
THIS YEAR.
THE IMPLEMENTATION PLANNING
WORKSHOPS WHICH RUNS --
JUNE THROUGH SEPTEMBER THEY ARE
SCATTERED THROUGHOUT THE STATE
TWENTY SEVEN OF THEM.
WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF PLANNING
THOSE THAT'S WHERE THE
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS --
WILL BECOME FINALIZED.
BEFORE THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND.
START TO HAPPEN COME JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY THAT'S WHERE ALL
THE PARTNERS COME TOGETHER THE
CONTRACTORS MEMBERS OF YOUR IN
FACT WE WE REALLY WANT THE STUFF.
IN YOUR RESPECTIVE OFFICES TO BE
PART OF THE RPM'S PLANNING
COMMITTEE.
GOING TO BRING THIS THIS OR LIKE
A KITCHEN CABINET EYES AND EARS --
PER REGION TO HELP PLAN THE THE
RIGHT FOLKS ARE THERE NOT JUST
THE CONTRACTORS WITH SOME OF
THESE --
TRUSTED MESSENGERS SOME OF THESE.
ALL CBO SOME OF YOU KNOW I WORK
WITH THEM BEFORE IN THE PAST --
THEY JUST BLOSSOM WITHIN THE
PAST TWO THREE YEARS CERTAINLY
TONS OF AFTER SOCIAL MEDIA TOOK
OFF AND ANYWAY THE POINT BEING
THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE RIGHT FOLKS ARE AT THESE --
WORKSHOPS THAT WILL HELP THE
CONTRACTORS --
FINALIZE THEIR THEIR PLANS.
SO THAT THEY CAN HIT THE GROUND
RUNNING SO TO SPEAK COME JANUARY
PERFECT.
BOXES LIKE AN UMBRELLA --
GUIDING --
YEAH DOCUMENTS I WORRY A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT HITTING THE GROUND
RUNNING COME JANUARY I THINK
WHAT WE REALLY NEED TO DO IS.
ESSENTIALLY DESENSITIZE THE
CENSUS RIGHT MAKE IT SOMETHING
NORMAL MAKE IT SOMETHING THAT
OBVIOUSLY EVERYONE IS
PARTICIPATING IN MAKING SURE
THAT.
EVERYONE IS EDUCATED ABOUT IT
YEAH AND BE AN EVEN MORE
CHALLENGING TASK --
AND SO JUST KEEP THAT IN MIND
THIS YEAR --
KIND OF FORMULATING YOUR
TIMELINE IS IS THE EARLIER THE
BETTER WHEN IT COMES TO STARTING
TO REACH OUT OBVIOUSLY THE HEAVY
LIFT WILL COME.
IN TWENTY TWENTY BUT BUT DON'T
JUST WAIT UNTIL THEN TO OKAY NEW
YEAR'S EVE TO TO GET THAT
PROCESS STARTED --
I HAVE.
THE RPM'S GONNA BE DOING A LOT --
AND I WORRY THAT THEY MIGHT BE
DOING. TOO MUCH OR OR HAVE TOO
MUCH ON THEIR PLATE --
TO BE ABLE TO BE EFFECTIVE AT
THAT ALL THE DIFFERENT TASKS ON
A SOME OF THEM --
ARE GOING TO BE ORGANIZING FOR
LACK OF A BETTER WORD IN.
THE HALF DOZEN OR MORE COUNTIES --
THEY HAVE TO BE ORGANIZING WITH
THE THE LOCAL CBO'S --
THE DISTRICT OFFICES FOR
DIFFERENT LEGISLATORS --
THE DIFFERENT --
COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEE IS AS A
BEEN ANY KIND OF THOUGHT ABOUT
ARE YOU KNOW IT IS THAT WORKLOAD
MANAGEABLE FOR THEM TO REALLY
ALSO BE ABLE TO KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON AND BE --
COORDINATING THE EFFORTS IN
THEIR REGIONS.
THUS THE DESIGN OF
ADMINISTRATIVE CBO.
AND WITH THAT STRUCTURE AND
OPERATION --
THE WORK IS --
MANAGEABLE YOU'RE RIGHT THAT IT
IS A HUGE WORKLOAD --
YOU KNOW IF I GOT MY GENERAL
MANAGEMENT OF BUSINESS DEGREE.
THIS IS LIKE.
BOTH WAYS IT WAS MY DREAM JOB
WITH -- KIND
OF LIKE A YOU KNOW STRATEGIC
MANAGEMENT BUT THAT THAT IS WHY
THE DESIGN AS IT IS MAKES SENSE
AS OPPOSED TO CONTRACTING WITH.
INDIVIDUAL CBO'S CONTRACTING
WITH INDIVIDUAL CITIES BECAUSE
OF THE THE BUDGET THAT WE'VE
BEEN ALLOCATED AND THE RESOURCES
BEHIND THAT THE THAT STRUCTURE
WORKS RIGHT NOW SOME COUNTY --
SOME REGIONS ARE LITTLE.
HEAVIER ON THE COUNTY SIDE.
I'LL GIVE YOU A GREAT EXAMPLE --
YOU KNOW REASON ONE HAS LIKE
TWENTY SEVEN COUNTIES --
HOW HOWEVER YOU KNOW LA HAS ONE
COUNTY HOWEVER ONLY HAS NINETY
CITIES THAT HAVE?
A SIGNIFICANT --
HARD TO COUNT POPULATION WITHIN
THEM SO WE TAKE A LOOK AT ALL OF
THOSE FACTORS.
AND DIVIDED UP THE WORK LOAD
ACCORDINGLY.
PLAYING A GAME OF CHESS SINCE
SEPTEMBER AS WE'VE BEEN ADDING
STUFF TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY EDUCATING FOLKS ON
THE GROUND VARYING DEGREES OF
AWARENESS OF THE CENSUS AND ITS
VALUE AND IMPORTANCE --
BUT WE'VE BEEN DOING THE EDUCATE
THE OXYGEN EDUCATION PHASE GOES
ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
AND JANUARY ACTIVATION THAT'S
KIND OF LIKE GET OUT THE VOTE
IT'S SORT OF LIKE WHEN WE
STARTED WAS REALLY ACTIVATE
FOLKS THAT'S WHAT THAT IS I'LL
JUST ADD TO IS THAT.
FROM OUR LAST LEGISLATIVE REPORT
THAT WE PROVIDED WE ACTUALLY DID
A REASSESSMENT WE LOOKED AT THE
RPM WE ACTUALLY BUMPED UP BY
ADDING A COUPLE TO SMALL STAFF
GUNS WITH THE LEVELS THAT WE
COULD FEEL COMFORTABLE WE ADDED
AN ADDITIONAL LEAD. TO THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AREAS THAT WE
HAVE A LEAD IN NORTHERN SOUTHERN
AND CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AND WE
ADDED AN ADDITIONAL --
RPM POSITION IN GENERAL TO HELP
COVER THE WORKLOAD THAT WE
FORESAW COUNTY --
AND THEN A QUESTION ON THE THE
THE FUNDING OVERVIEW WHAT IS
STATE PROGRAMMATIC COSTS I KNOW
IT'S A LINE ITEM UNDER EVERY
DIFFERENT CATEGORY --
RIGHT YEAH BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT
OUR STATE PROGRAM COSTS AT THE
COST OF ACTUALLY RUNNING OUT
REACH CAMPAIGN THAT IS THE COST
OF A TREE ON THE STAFF AND THE
TERMS OF THEM WORKING IN THE
FIELD --
WITH OUR PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS
UNDER ADMINISTRATION AND IT'S
NOT AN ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
MINISTRY OF COSTS ARE TYPICALLY
OR THINGS LIKE HUMAN RESOURCES
LEGAL GOD BUDGET --
THOSE TYPES EFFORTS HERE AT
HEADQUARTERS GOTCHA --
AND THEN I GUESS MY LAST
QUESTION IS [inaudible]
THERE.
A LOT OF DIFFERENT WELL OF KNOW
ALSO THAT FOR ANOTHER TIME THE
MY LAST COMMENT I GUESS BECAUSE
IN A RUNNING VERY LATE --
IS SO DIFFERENT ONE AGREED WITH
THE CONCERNS OR REYES ON THE
EDUCATION BUDGET --
AND JUST MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT YOU KNOW --
TRYING TO FEWER RESOURCES TO A
VERY -- THE
END TO A VERY IMPORTANT POOL OF
OF HARD TO COUNT.
CALIFORNIANS --
AND THEN I ALSO CHINA WAS
SOMEBODY MY OFFICER THERE TODAY --
FROM THE REPRESENTS DIFFERENT
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENTS --
AND THE THREE DID SIXTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT WAS
DEDICATED DIRECTLY TO TO I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE OTHER YOU KNOW
REVENUE STREAMS AND AND
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS TO TRY TO
REACH.
TRIBAL MEMBERS BUT THE THREE TO
SIXTEEN THOUSAND DIRECTLY TO
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS SEEM LIKE A
VERY SMALL SUM --
AND SO I KNOW THAT YOU ALL HAD A
BIG CONVERSATION WITHOUT WITH
THE STATEWIDE COMPLETE CHARACTER
COMMITTEE LAST WEEK I'M SURE
HE'LL BE HAVING FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS BUT JUST WANT TO
ENCOURAGE YOU. TO TO REASSESS
THAT -- AND
THAT'S ALL OF QUICK QUESTION.
THIS IS GOING TO BE TAKING --
PLACE.
DURING THE PRIMARY AND GENERAL
ELECTION AND I'M SORRY.
WE HAVE A LOT WILL LIKE GOING ON
AND AND SO HAVE YOU TAKEN THAT
INTO ACCOUNT AND AND
SPECIFICALLY WITH --
ISSUES LIKE --
MEDIA BUYS AND HOW MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE THEY COULD BE AND AND
COMPETING IN IT WHEN YOU HAVE
REALLY COMPETITIVE DISTRICTS ARE
ALSO GOING TO BE COMPETING WITH.
A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE THAT ARE
KNOCKING ON DOORS AND AND YOU
MIGHT HAVE --
RESIDENTS THAT ARE NOT OPENING
THE DOORS ANYMORE HAVE YOU TAKEN
ALL THAT INTO ACCOUNT.
WE HAVE WE HAVE THOUGHT OF THOSE
CHALLENGES OF WHETHER OR NOT AND
WE ARE WE ARE ABLE TO COMBAT ALL
THAT'S GOING TO GOING ON IN THAT.
FIRST HALF OF THE NEXT CALENDAR
YEAR WITH THE PRIMARY
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY THE
OLYMPICS AND OTHER THINGS.
IT'S GONNA BE IT'S HARD TO KNOW
BUT WE DEFINITELY HAVE SOME
COMPETITION OUT THERE FOR
PEOPLE'S ATTENTION ON THIS TOPIC.
AND FINANCIALLY FOR THINGS LIKE
MEDIA BUYS.
ARE YOU IT ARE YOU EXPECTING
THAT IT'S GONNA BE MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN.
WOULD BE NOW.
WE HAVEN'T DISCUSSED THAT
SPECIFICALLY BUT AS JUSTIN SAID --
WE DEFINITELY HAVE AND ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW --
COMPLICATED THE CALENDAR IT IS --
WE WILL WE WILL DISCUSS OR IF HE
THAT SAT ON WE'LL GET A BETTER
SENSE ONCE WE GET BACK OUR
RESPONSES TO OUR P. WE ENGAGE
ARE THE POTENTIAL MAMA WAR EASE
WHEN WE GO THROUGH OUR
NEGOTIATION PERIOD THEY WILL LET
US KNOW WHAT THEY'RE SEEN WHAT
THEIR POTENTIAL.
COSTS ARE GONNA BE FOR ME AND MY
CENTER MARK.
THE LOCATIONS IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING CORRECT THAT
YOU'LL.
YOU MEAN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WILL BE IDENTIFIED HOUSEHOLDS
THAT HAVE AND HAVE NOT COMPLETED
THE CENSUS FORM.
SO WE WILL BE WORKING WITH THE
HAT U. S. CENSUS BUREAU THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE PROVIDING US WITH
RESPONSE RATES SO --
I THAT BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO BE
IS A KIND OF POSSIBLE BUT CAN WE
SAY THE NUMBER OF HOUSEHOLDS HAS
NOT OR HAS FILLED OUT A SURVEY.
I DON'T KNOW IF I'M GONNA WE'RE
GONNA GET TO THAT.
LEVEL OF DETAIL FROM THEM BUT WE
SAID NO LIKE WITHIN THIS BLOCK
GROUP AREA --
WHETHER OR NOT 10% OF HOUSEHOLDS
HAVE RESPONDED OR 15% RESPONDED
SO WE'LL KNOW GENERALLY WHERE
WE'RE AT ON THE RESPONSE RATES
FOR GET SPECIFICS AND I'VE
TRACKED I GUESS I'M.
LOOKING AT IT FROM.
THE PERSPECTIVE OF HAVING GONE
THROUGH ALL OF US HAVE GONE
THROUGH CAMPAIGNS AND YOU CAN
TELL WHO'S VOTER HAS VOTED.
YOU GET OUT THOSE WHO HAVE NOT
VOTED BUT WE WON'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION SUCH THAT WE CAN GO
TO A HOUSEHOLD AND IDENTIFY THAT
HOUSEHOLD.
THAT IS NOT.
BEEN NUMEROUS RIGHT THAT IS MY
UNDERSTAND I'M NOT GONNA HAVE
INDIVIDUAL HOUSEHOLD INFORMATION
FROM THE OKAY.
NOW WAS STANDING THAT CAN CAN WE
STILL DO I'VE BEEN COUNTED
BUTTONS LIKE COULD DO I VOTED
BUTTONS OF THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
LITTLE STICKERS.
THAT IS A FANTASTIC IDEA AND WE
CAN DEFINITELY LOOK INTO MAKING
SURE THAT GETS INCLUDED.
THANKS.
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENT ON
THAT.
OKAY WELL --
SEE THAT'S NO THE QUESTIONS ONLY
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE AND PRESENTING I WOULD MAKE
NOTED IS FIVE TWENTY NOW I THINK
OUR NEXT PANELS. FOR FOR FOR
BEING HERE AND WAITING FOR OVER
ALSO VERY INTERESTED IN WHAT YOU
HAVE TO SAY SOURCE SECOND PANELS
WORKING WITH STATE LOCAL
PARTNERS AND A LOT OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT THAT OUT REGION LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP SO I THINK THIS
PANEL CAN HELP US WITH THIS.
WE HAVE US STEFANIA RAMIREZ IS
DIRECTOR OF STRATEGIC
INITIATIVES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION THE ACBL
WORD RECIPIENT FOR REGION EIGHT
LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
IN THIS ROLE SHE IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR CCF'S IN DOLLAR GRANT MAKING
COMMUTING GAUGE WHEN FUNDRAISING
COMMUNICATIONS CAMPAIGN WELCOME.
WE HAVE JUDY ROBINSON HAS THE
PRINCIPLE PLANNER AND THE TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS MANAGER FOR
SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
SO WE ARE LUCKY TO HAVE HER
RIGHT HERE LOCALLY IN MY OWN
DISTRICT DISTRICTS SIX YEARS A
TWENTY FIVE YEAR TRACK RECORD OF
CLEVERLY YOUR SUPPORT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS COMMITTEE PLANNING
DEVELOPMENT AND PARKS AND HEALTH.
AND CUT WE HAVE COLLEEN STEVENS
IS THE DIRECTOR OF MARKETING FOR
COVERED CALIFORNIA.
IN THIS ROLE SHE MANAGES THE
DEVELOPMENT IMPLEMENTATION
EVALUATION MARKETING CAMPAIGNS
FOR THE INDIVIDUAL SMALL
BUSINESS MARKETS YET PRILIGY
SERVICE BRANCH CHIEF FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PART PUBLIC CULTS.
THE BATTLE CONTROL CAMPAIGN
WHICH ESTABLISHED ARE HIGHLY
REGARDED MULTI ETHNIC MARKETING
CAMPAIGN I KNOW THAT WHEN WE
ALLOCATED MORE FUNDING LAST YEAR
IN STATE BUDGET WE ACTUALLY
POINTED OUT TO COVER CALIFORNIA
SO I THINK THE EXPERIENCE WE
COVER CALIFORNIA WILL BE VERY
VALUABLE AS WELL SO THANK YOU
ALL. FOR BEING HERE --
VERY EAGER TO HEAR YOU ALSO I
KNOW THAT WE'RE RUNNING LATE
COLLEGE EYES FOR THE LATE TO
HELP THAT SO.
THAT'S WORKING OUT WITH YOUR
SCHEDULE BUT I DEFINITELY WANT
TO HEAR WHAT YOU HAVE TO SAY SO
WELCOME.
RIGHT OFF WITH THE THIS REMARKS.
GREAT.
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE JOINT
SENSES SELECT COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY ON EFFORTS TO
ADVANCED --
A FULL COUNT IN LA COUNTY IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE AND I METIS --
DIRECTOR OF STRATEGIC
INITIATIVES AT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION WE ARE ON
ONE OF THE OLDEST COMMUNITY
FOUNDATIONS IN THE NATION.
CCF HAS SERVED LA COUNTY
STARBURST CAM UNITIES AND DONORS
FOR OVER A CENTURY.
WE WORK TO ADDRESS ROT CAUSES
ARE PRESSING CHALLENGES THAT
PREVENT THE MOST VULNERABLE IN
OUR REGION FROM THRIVING IN THE
AREAS OF EDUCATION.
HOUSING HEALTH AND IMMIGRATION.
AND ACHIEVING A COMPLETE COUNT
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS IS A
CORE PRIORITY FOR US HAVING
PARTICIPATED IN THE TWENTY TEN
CENTS A SEPARATE AS WELL.
THE FORMIDABLE CHALLENGES THAT
THE CENSUS PRESENTS REQUIRES THE
KIND OF COMMITMENT AND
LEADERSHIP BEFITTING THE
STRENGTH AND THE PRESERVATION
AND SERVE THE PEOPLE THAT WE
SERVE.
SO THE CORNERSTONE OF THE CENSUS
EFFORT IS OUR COLLABORATIVE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF LA.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND PHILANTHROPIC PARTNERS.
IT IS BECAUSE OF THOSE EXISTING
PARTNERSHIPS KNOWLEDGE IN CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT GRANT MANAGEMENT
EXPERIENCE AND PLANNING EFFORTS
TO DATE SINCE.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT WE BELIEVE
CCF WAS SELECTED TO SERVE.
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSCORE THAT A GUIDING
PRINCIPLE. FOR CCAF IS PROMISE
ON LEVERAGING STATE RESOURCES
AND COORDINATING WITH THE
STATE'S.
COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEE TO
ENSURE THAT LOCAL EFFORTS ARE
COORDINATED AND THINGS UP WITH
THE STATEWIDE CAMPAIGN.
SO WE BELIEVE LA COUNTY IS THE
EPICENTER OF STATEWIDE EFFORTS
FOR A COMPLETE COUNT.
WITH MORE THAN THREE MILLION
PEOPLE LIVING IN CENSUS TRACTS
CLASSIFIED AS HIGH RISK OF AN
UNDERCOUNT.
THE LA REGION IS THE HARDEST
ACCOUNT COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IN THE NATION.
MORE OVER OUR INCREDIBLE ETHNIC
DIVERSITY AND GEOGRAPHIC
COMPLEXITY.
REQUIRE HYPER COORDINATION
ONGOING COLLABORATION.
AND SIGNIFICANT RESOURCE THAT.
TO GIVE SOME CONTEXT THERE ARE
CURRENTLY A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE DIFFERENT LANGUAGES SPOKEN
IN LA.
COMMUNITIES ARE SPREAD ACROSS
EIGHTY EIGHT DIFFERENT CITIES
WITH AN ARRAY OF EIGHTY ONE
SCHOOLS DISTRICTS.
SO WHAT'S GOING ON IN LA AND
WHAT IS THE FOUNDATION DOING TO
SUPPORT CENSUS OUTREACH EFFORTS.
I'M GONNA HIGHLIGHT FIVE KEY
POINTS THIS --
TODAY.
SO NUMBER ONE WE ARE SECURING
AND STREAMLINING RESEARCH THAT'S
FOR COMMUNITY BASED EFFORTS.
SO SEE SEE I'VE HAD SECURED
LOCAL DOLLARS TO LAUNCH A
STREAMLINED SINGLE SOURCE
FUNDING AND REPORTING. FOR
COMMUNITY BASED GROUPS WORKING
WITH.
AND ON IN THE HEART TO COUNT.
GROUP SOME POPULATIONS.
IN ADDITION TO THE REGIONAL
FUNDS THAT THE STATE HAS
PROVIDED CCF HAS BEEN WORKING ON
RAISING AN ADDITIONAL TEN
MILLION DOLLARS. TO SUPPORT
DIRECT SENSE OF OUTRAGE. TWO WE
ARE SUPPORTING A COMMUNITY
DRIVEN PLAN FOR EDUCATION AND
MOBILISATION.
SO IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CENSUS
POLICY IN ADVOCACY INSTITUTE --
NETWORK SORRY WE HELPED
ESTABLISH THE LA REGIONAL CENSUS
TABLE.
WHICH BROUGHT TOGETHER NEARLY A
HUNDRED OR SERVING A VARIETY OF
POPULATIONS DEAN'S HARD TO COUNT
TO DEVELOP OR REGIONAL PLAN OF
ACTION FOR LA.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN THE CENSUS UP
THE ALLEY REGIONAL CENSUS TABLES
ABOUT FAME TABLE GREW AND REACH.
AND IS NOW CONVENING HYPER LOCAL
ACROSS --
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS SIX
DESIGNATED.
REGIONS IN THE COUNTY SO FROM
ANTELOPE VALLEY TO LNG BEACH TO
SOUTH LA [inaudible] TO POMONA --
THESE MEETINGS ARE CREATED TO
ENSURE THAT ALL VOICES ARE HEARD.
IN THE PLANNING PHASE.
AND THE COLLECTIVE LEARNINGS ARE
ALSO OCCURRING.
DURING THE IMPLEMENTATION
STATIONS.
SO THESE MEETINGS ARE BRINGING
TOGETHER NOW HUNDREDS OF
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING AFRICAN AMERICANS
LATINOS ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDERS
SOUTHEAST ASIANS.
NATIVE AMERICANS CHILDREN --
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
IMMIGRANTS LGBT Q. COMMUNITY
MEMBERS --
TO JUST JUST TO NAME A FEW.
THREE IN ADDITION TO CCAF IN
ADDITION CCF HAS ESTABLISHED A
STEERING COMMITTEE COMPRISED OF
TEN LEADING --
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
TO HELP --
TO REALLY SERVE AS ADVISORS TO
THE FOUNDATION TO HELP WAS WITH
SETTING FUNDING PRIORITIES. TO
SHAPE AND LAUNCH A UNIFIED --
CAMINO AND TO ADVICE ON THE
BALLOT A SHOULD METRICS THAT
MAKES SENSE FOR THEM AND THAT'S
ALSO VALUE. TO THEM.
SO SOME OF THE ORGANIZATIONS ARE
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE NOT LA --
CALIFORNIA CALLS CALIFORNIA
NATIVE BOOK PROJECTS ELLIE VOICE
BUCKLEY MOVE YOU TO FULL LONG
BEACH FOR ITS SOUTHEAST LA
COLLABORATIVE ANTELOPE VALLEY
PARTNERS FOR HEALTH.
AND ADVANCEMENT PROJECT
CALIFORNIA.
NUMBER.
FOUR WE KNOW THIS IS A LANDMARK
CENSUS AS SUCH LEARNINGS FROM.
THIS EFFORT WILL BE CRUCIAL IN
FUTURE AND CIVIC ENGAGEMENT --
CAMPAIGNS SO WE ARE BEGINNING TO
ALSO MAP OUT --
EVALUATION CRITERIA TO SET A
PLAN IN ACTION.
AND LASTLY NUMBER FIVE OVER THE
NEXT TWO MONTHS SEE SEE APPLE
RELIEF AN INITIAL COUNTY WIDE
REQUEST FOR PROPOSALS.
AROUND IDENTIFIED CENSUS OUT
REACH TACTICS SUCH AS COMMUNITY
EDUCATION AND ORDERED OR CAMPUS
SAYING ASSISTANCE CENTERS TO
NAME A FEW --
AT WHAT OUR GOAL BEING TO REALLY
PROVIDE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WITH THE FUNDING
THAT THEY NEED BY THE SUMMER OF
TWENTY NINETEEN SO THAT THEY CAN
BUILD THEIR CAPACITY AND START
TO IMPLEMENT THEIR THEIR PLANS
INTO ACTION.
SO TO CLOSE WE BELIEVE THAT
COMMUNITY --
PARTNERS MUST HAVE A LEADING
VOICE IN OUR EFFORTS.
THAT THE FLOW OF RESOURCES
SHOULD BE INFORMED BY THEIR
NEEDS.
AND THAT ON THE GROUND
ORGANIZING AND COMMUNITY
EDUCATION WILL WIN THE DAY FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS.
BUT ORDINATION IS ESSENTIAL AND
IT MUST BE NOW.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND THE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS RAMIREZ
MS ROBINSON.
THANK YOU TO THE OF THREE
COMMITTEE CHAIRS AND ALL THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
ALSO APPRECIATE YOU STAYING LATE --
TO FOR THIS HEARING --
MY NAME IS JUDY ROBINSON ON THE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS MANAGER FOR
SACRAMENTO COUNTY --
IT IS AN HONOR AND AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY BEFORE
YOU TODAY --
I'VE ALSO HAD THE PLEASURE OF
WORKING WITH SOME OF YOUR STAFF
AS WELL AS STATE CENSUS STAFF
SINCE JANUARY OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AND THEY'RE AWESOME.
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IS MOST
APPRECIATIVE OF THE NEARLY EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS WE WILL RECEIVE IN STATE
FUNDING TO SUPPORT CENSUS OUT
REACH.
WE HAVE SIGNED THE STATE
CONTRACT AND ARE CURRENTLY
DEVELOPING OUR STRATEGIC AND
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS IN
COLLABORATION WITH A COMPLETE
COUNT COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WE'RE VERY EXCITED THAT THE
SACRAMENTO REGION COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION WAS SELECTED AS
REGION ONE A CBO.
TOGETHER WE'RE COMMITTED TO
SUPPORTING THE STATE AND
DEPLOYING SENSES OUT EDUCATION
AND ASSISTANCE TO OUR ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION RESIDENTS TO
ACHIEVE A COMPLETE COUNT.
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IS ONE OF THE
TOP TEN HARDEST ACCOUNT COUNTIES
IN CALIFORNIA.
SACRAMENTO IS ONE OF THE THREE
MOST DIVERSE CITIES IN THE STATE
AND HOME TO MOST OF THE TO MOST
OF THE REFUGEES.
RE SETTLEMENTS IN THE NATION.
OUR LOCAL STATE UNIVERSITY CSU
SACRAMENTO HAS 46% OF ITS
STUDENT POPULATION IS FIRST
GENERATION IMMIGRANTS.
WITH OVER THIRTY DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES SPOKEN.
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
AHEAD AND WERE PREPARING TO MEET
THEM.
IN SUPPORTING THE STATE'S
GUIDANCE OUR COMMUNITY OUT
REGION ENGAGEMENT PLAN IS
UTILIZING TRUSTED COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND
COMMUNITY MESSENGERS TO REACH
THE HARD TO COUNT COMMUNITIES
AND RESIDENTS.
AND BECAUSE OF OUR CLOSE
COLLABORATION WITH THE REGION
FOUNDATION STARTING LAST APRIL.
THEY'RE BRINGING IN THE
COMMUNITY PIECE OF ARE SO WE
ALSO ENGAGED ALL OF OUR CITIES
LAST APRIL I'VE BEEN MEETING
REGULARLY WITH THEM.
OUR COMMUNITY GOVERNMENT --
AND PARTNERSHIP COORDINATION AND
COLLABORATION WILL BUILD
CAPACITY LEVERAGE RESOURCES AND
AVOID DUPLICATION.
A COMPLETE COUNT SENSES FOR
SACRAMENTO COUNTY WILL BE
ACCOMPLISHED BY APPLYING
COMMUNITY DESIGNED AND COMMUNITY
CENTERED OUT READ STRATEGIES.
THEY WILL BE INNOVATIVE
COMPREHENSIVE AND COHESIVE
RESULTING IN STRENGTHENING
COUNTY WIDE MULTI SECTOR
COLLABORATION.
THIS WILL BE DONE IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR COMMUNITY AND LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS.
WORKING WITH THE COMMUNITY WE
FORMED A COMPLETE COUNT
COMMITTEE STRUCTURE WITH TWO
STEERING COMMITTEES GOVERNMENT
AND COMMUNITY.
THEY'VE BEEN MEETING SINCE LAST
FALL.
THE COMMUNITY COMMITTEE IS
CARRYING THE LOAD OF HARD TO
COUNT GROUPS AND ARE THE TRUSTED
MESSENGERS DURING THE MOST
CRITICAL AND LABOR INTENSIVE
WORK.
THEY UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE
AND ARE HIGHLY MOTIVATED.
THE COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEES
AND THEY'RE WORKING GROUP'S ARE
CREATING AN EXTENSIVE INVENTORY
OF RESOURCES ASSETS AND
FACILITIES WHICH IS BEING PUT
INTO A MINISTRY AT A G. TO
INFORM OUR STRATEGIC INFORMATION
AND IMPLEMENTATION PLANS.
AND IDENTIFY GAPS SO THAT WE CAN
ADDRESS THEM.
THE WORKING GROUP'S CURRENTLY
HAVE OVER THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY ORGANIZATIONS INVOLVED AND
ARE CONTINUALLY ADDING MORE TO
GROW COMMUNITY IN ORGANIZATIONAL
CAPACITY.
OVER THOUSAND HOURS HAVE BEEN
DONATED TO DATE.
WE'RE LEVERAGING LESSONS LEARNED
FROM LAST NOVEMBER'S VOTERS
CHOICE ELECTION WHICH SAW THE
HIGHEST VOTER TURNOUT FOR MID
TERM GENERAL ELECTION.
IN COUNTY HISTORY.
CLOSE COORDINATION WITH THE
COMMUNITY LEVER THERE'S AN HARD
TO COUNT COMMUNITIES A SHARED
PARTICIPATION EVENTS ARE ALL
PART OF OUR OUTREACH PLAN.
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
COMMUNITY TO PLAN EVENTS ACROSS
THE COUNTY IN PARTICULAR HARD TO
COUNT NEIGHBORHOODS.
EVENTS WILL BE HELD AT SCHOOLS
LIBRARIES PARKS COMMUNITY
CENTERS CHURCHES HEALTH CENTERS
AND HOUSING COMPLEXES.
WE WILL BE HIRING COMMUNITY
RESIDENTS TO HELP WITHOUT REACH
WE'RE PLANNING LOCAL EVENTS WITH
A LIBRARY VAN AND POTENTIALLY
FOOD TRUCKS.
AND TO GO TO THE RESIDENTS TO
MAKE THIS AS EASY AS POSSIBLE
AND GET CENSUS QUESTIONNAIRES
COMPLETED AS EARLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND YES MORE FUNDING IS NEEDED --
FOR SACRAMENTO AND ACROSS THE
STATE FOR COUNTIES AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
I MENTIONED SACRAMENTO'S
DIVERSITY BUT THE STATE FUNDING
DISTRIBUTION FORMULA DIDN'T
ACCOUNT FOR THE BROAD VARIETY OF
LANGUAGES SPOKEN.
THE DIFFERENCES IN CULTURES AND
THE INCREASED COST TO ENGAGE
WITH THESE VERY DIFFERENT GROUPS.
SACRAMENTO COUNTY NEEDS AN
ADDITIONAL THREE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS TO IMPLEMENT
WITH THE STATE IS ASKING OF US.
THESE FUNDS WILL SUPPORT AND NOT
DUPLICATE FUNDING CBO'S.
A DUPLICATE THE FUNDING THAT
CBO'S WILL BE RECEIVING.
THERE WILL BE STATE LANGUAGE
ACCESS REQUIREMENTS AND THE
HOMELESS COUNT WILL NEED LOCAL
RESOURCES AND NAVIGATORS ALL
REQUIRING ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
IMPLEMENT.
FURTHER THERE IS NO FUNDING FOR
HIGHER ED AND LIBRARIES THERE'S
A MINIMAL AMOUNT OF FUNDING
GOING TO K. THROUGH TWELVE
SCHOOLS.
HOWEVER AS EARLIER MENTIONED
THAT'S A SMALL AMOUNT TO BE
SPREAD ACROSS THE STATE AND
SACRAMENTO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION FOR EXAMPLE WILL
RECEIVE. FIFTY THREE THOUSAND TO
SURE WAS SIXTEEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WITH AND STUDENTS.
HIGHER EDUCATION LIBRARIES ARE
BEING REFERRED TO THE COUNTIES
COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEES FOR
FINANCIAL SUPPORT AND THE LIST
GOES ON THE ONE POINT TWO
MILLION ALLOCATED FOR REGION ONE
CBO'S IS WOEFULLY UNDERFUNDED.
REGION ONE HAS SEVENTEEN VERY
DIVERSE COUNTIES AND COVERS THE
LARGEST YEAR GRAPHIC AREA IN THE
STATE.
SACRAMENTO'S PORTION OF FUNDING
IS THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH IS
NOT NEARLY ENOUGH TO SUPPORT THE
WORK OUR CBO'S WILL BE DOING.
UNLIKE OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE
SACRAMENTO HAS NOT RECEIVED
FUNDING FROM FOUNDATIONS TO HELP
WITH THE CENSUS WORK.
SACRAMENTO CBO'S WILL NEED
ADDITIONAL TWO MILLION DOLLARS
IN FUNDING TO COVER THE TO IN
FUNDING TO DO THE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND WORK. FOR DISSIPATING
CONDUCT OF ANTS.
PROVIDE EARLY CENSUS
PARTICIPATION IN NON RESPONSE
FOLLOW UP.
WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY I WANT TO ASSURE YOU THAT
THERE IS GREAT COLLABORATION
OCCURRING AT ALL LEVELS AND WILL
CONTINUE.
THAT WE'RE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER.
THEY WERE QUESTIONS ANSWERED
EARLIER NEXT TIME ALLOWS WOULD
LOVE TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THOSE --
THANK YOU AGAIN [inaudible]
HI.
HI AM COLLEEN STEVENS AND I
MARKETING DIRECTOR FOR COVER
CALIFORNIA.
AND I AM PLEASED TO TO ALLOW ME
TO SHARE SOME INSIGHTS INTO WHAT
WE LEARNED.
IN RAMPING UP COVERED CALIFORNIA
IN TERMS OF MARKETING.
SO THAT LOTS OF OUR SIMILARITIES
BETWEEN THE TACIT COVER
CALIFORNIA HAD IN THE TASK YOU
HAVE BEFORE YOU --
BOTH OF US NEEDED TO REACH
HARDER TO AND USING TRUSTED
MESSENGERS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
BOTH OF US ARE USING A
COMBINATION OF GROUND TROOPS AND
OUR MARKETING EFFORTS.
BOTH OF US ARE NEED TO WORK BOB
COORDINATE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND ARE WORKING UNDER. FOR LACK
OF A BETTER WORD RIDICULOUS TIME
LINES TO GET THESE THINGS DONE.
FOR COVER CALIFORNIA WE DID A
LOT OF PLANNING JUST AS YOU DID
AND ONE OF THE LAST COMPOSED TO
BE ADDED IN REALLY FLESHED OUT
WAS THE MARKETING CAMPAIGN.
IN MAY OF TWENTY THIRTEEN WE
MAILED ON OUR CONTRACT WITH OUR
ADVERTISING AGENCY.
IN JULY OF THE SAME YEAR WE
HIRED OUR FIRST MARKETING STAFF.
AND BY SEPTEMBER WE HAD A FULL
COMPLETE CAMPAIGN IN THE
MARKETPLACE PROMOTING COVER
CALIFORNIA.
BASED ON THE TYPE TIMELINE WE
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL
EXCEPT FOR A COUPLE OF THINGS.
WHAT IS WE ENDED UP WITH A
REALLY GREAT ADVERTISING AGENCY
THAT WENT THE EXTRA MILE OVER
AND OVER AGAIN THEY DID THINGS
THAT ARE IMPOSSIBLE TO DO THAT
GO AGAINST EVERYTHING YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO AND THEY WERE
SUCCESSFUL --
IT WAS A BIG ENOUGH AGENCY TO
GET THE JOB DONE BUT WAS ALSO
FLEXIBLE ENOUGH THAT IT COULD
BRING IN ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
WOULD WE NEED THAT THEM AND THAT
WAS OFTEN --
WE WERE ALSO LUCKY THAT COVER
CALIFORNIA WAS ABLE TO HIRE A
FEW PEOPLE.
MYSELF INCLUDED WHO ALREADY HAD
WORKED ON MARKETING CAMPAIGNS
WHO KNEW THE STATE RULES AND HOW
TO MANAGE A CONTRACT AND HOW TO
GET THE MOST OUT OF YOUR DOLLARS.
LASTLY WE HAD A VERY SUPPORT OF
LEADERSHIP TEAM AND THAT
LEADERSHIP TEAM DID A LOT OF
WORK IN TERMS OF GETTING AROUND
STATE PROCESS NOT THAT GETTING
AROUND IS THE WRONG PHRASE. TO
MAXIMIZING STATE PROCESSES SO WE
DIDN'T GET BOGGED DOWN IN STATE
PROCESSES WHICH SOMETIMES
HAPPENS.
COVERED CALIFORNIA INVEST ABOUT
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
ON MARKETING OUTREACH AND THAT'S
A COMBINATION OF OUR COMMUNITY
GROUNDS ARE OP COLUMNS AND A
MARKETING CAMPAIGN.
THE ACTUAL ADVERTISING BAD
BUDGET ITSELF IS BETWEEN FORTY
ONE AND FORTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
WITH A LARGER AMOUNT SPENT IN
THE FIRST YEAR COVERS CREATIVE
RESEARCH PRODUCTION COLLATERAL
SOCIAL MEDIA.
AND TV AND RADIO PLACEMENT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE FUNDS GO TO
BY MEDIA TIME.
SO I'M OFTEN ASKED WHY THIS
MEDIA COST SO MUCH MONEY.
AND CAL IS BASED ON HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE ANTICIPATED TO SEE
ANY GIVEN AT AND A STATE LIKE
CALIFORNIA WHERE THE SIZES SO
LARGE -- IT
COST MORE COOPER JUST LARGE
CALIFORNIA HAS WITHIN IT IF TALK
OF THE TOP TWENTY GENERAL
MARKETS IN THE UNITED STATES
THREE OF THE TOP GENERAL MARKETS
IN FOR THE ENGLISH MARKET.
AND FIVE OF THE TOP LATINO
MARKETS OF THE UNITED STATES.
AND I COULD GO WITH OTHER
MARKETS BUT YOU GET THE PICTURE.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE HAVE
LEARNED THAT IS WORK
SUCCESSFULLY FOR US IS A LAYERED
APPROACH TO BUYING MEDIA.
THERE ARE MORE MEDIA CHOICES
THAT ANYBODY COULD POSSIBLY
AFFORD TO BUY.
AND MEDIA'S CONSUMPTION OF
PEOPLE'S CONSUMPTION OF MEDIA
VARIES BY THEIR AGE THEIR INCOME
THEIR EDUCATION AND WHAT'S
AVAILABLE TO THEM. TO GIVE YOU
JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF HOW THIS IS
COMPLICATED IF YOU THINK OF THE
LATINO POPULATION AND I'M A TALK
ABOUT WHAT HE WAS VERY BROADLY.
THEIR PEOPLE ONLY SPEAK SPANISH
THEIR LATINOS WHO FEEL VERY
TACTILE THE COMMUNITY BUT THEY
ONLY SPEAK ENGLISH AND THEN THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN BETWEEN WHO
CAN SPEAK BOTH LANGUAGES.
SO IF WE JUST BOUGHT SPANISH
LANGUAGE MEDIA WE WOULDN'T REACH
THE PEOPLE AND THERE'S A BIG
PART SENATOR PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO DON'T SPEAK
SPANISH WHO ARE VERY MUCH RELATE
TO THAT CULTURE.
SO WE BY SPANISH MEDIA IN THE IN
CAN TELL SPECIFIC SHOWS THAT
HAVE HIGH VIEWERSHIP OF LATINOS
AND WE ALSO BY THOSE SHOWS.
AND FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
BILINGUAL WE MAKE SURE THAT THE
MESSAGES THAT RUN IN SPANISH TV
AN ENGLISH TV ARE COMPLEMENTARY
SO IT'S NOT A CONFUSION FOR THE
PERSON WHO'S WATCHING BOTH
LANGUAGES.
AND THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF
ONE LANGUAGE THERE'S A DIFFERENT
THAT DYNAMIC FOR ALMOST EVERY
ETHNIC COMMUNITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO WE'VE ALSO FOUND.
THAT HAVING ONE STATEWIDE AGENCY
WITH ETHNIC SUBCONTRACTORS WITH
EXPERTISE IN REACHING THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
COMBINED WITH THE STATE WIDE
STRATEGIC PLAN WORKS BEST.
SO THAT WE END OF SPEAKING WITH
ONE VOICE HAVING CONSISTENT
MESSAGING AND CLEAR MESSAGING
FOR EVERYBODY.
WHILE THE PLAN IS STATEWIDE IT
IS INFUSED WITH.
ETHNIC IN LANGUAGE AND HYPER
LOCAL MEDIA TO ENSURE WE HAVE
THE STRONGEST MEDIA [inaudible]
PENETRATION.
WHILE WE HAVE GREAT CONTRACTORS
IT REMAINS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE STATE STAFF TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ALWAYS THINK ABOUT
DIVERSITY WE'RE ALWAYS TRYING TO
MAKE SURE ARE WE REACHING.
THE NEEDS OF THE POPULATIONS
WERE TRYING TO GET TO AND THEN
THAT COULD BE ETHNIC OR LANGUAGE
OR GEOGRAPHIC.
I HAVE WORKED AND NO OTHER
PROGRAMS WHERE THEY USED MORE
REGIONAL APPROACH AND WHILE IT
SOUNDS GOOD THERE ARE SOME
DOWNFALLS TO USING A MORE
REGIONAL APPROACH.
WANTED CAUSES HORRIFIC PROBLEMS
INTERESTS ACCORDING ATION YOU
GET IN CONSISTENT MESSAGING THE
BIG COUNTIES CAN DO IT BETTER
THE SMALL COUNTIES HAVE VERY
LITTLE TO NO FUNDING --
IT CAUSES INCREASE PRODUCTION
COST AND DUPLICATE COSTS AND
LASTLY THERE BUYING EFFICIENCIES
WHERE YOU COULD REALLY MAP OUT.
A PROGRAM --
SO THAT YOU GET THE MOST OUT OF
THE DOLLARS AND I SHOULD ADD ONE
MORE.
MEDIA THE CIRCLED MEDIA GOES OUT
IS NOT BASED ON COUNTY LINES SO
SOME COUNTIES MIGHT GET THREE
DIFFERENT STATIONS I MEAN.
YOU KNOW MAYBE MAKE IT SAN
FRANCISCO MEDIA THEY MIGHT GET
SACRAMENTO MEDIA AND THEY MIGHT
GET SHE GOT ME TO GET JUST
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU ARE --
MEDIA CAMPAIGNS ARE UNIQUE AMONG
OTHER KIND OF CAMPAIGNS AND YOU
WILL FIND THIS AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD AND YOU GET OPINIONS
FROM PEOPLE.
EVERYBODY IS AN EXPERT ON MEDIA
EVERYBODY HAS AN OPINION ABOUT
MEDIA.
WHOEVER RUNS THIS CAMPAIGN WILL
LIKELY FIND THAT THEY ARE COSTLY
APPROACH WITH IDEAS FOR THE NEXT
GREAT COMMERCIAL.
MEDIA VENDORS ROUTINELY GO
AROUND THE STATE STAFF AND GO
STRAIGHT TO THE HEAD OF THE
DEPARTMENT --
TO PITCH THEIR PRODUCTS.
EVERY SINGLE WEEK.
SOMEONE IS TRYING TO SELL ME
THEIR BRAND NEW SOFTWARE A NEW
SPORTS TEAM SPONSORSHIP A NEW
MEDIA PLATFORM AND IF I JUST
SPENT MY MONEY WITH THEM.
I WOULD END UP DOING BETTER OR
THAT ALL WILL BE RIGHT WITH THE
WORLD.
SO MY JOB OR WHOEVER RUNS THIS
CAMPAIGN'S JOB.
IS TO BE DISCIPLINED. TO USE
THEIR ADVERTISING AGENCIES AND
THEIR EXPERTISE BOTH IN THE
GENERAL MARKET AND ETHNIC
MARKETS TO MAKE DECISIONS THAT
ARE SOUND AND MAXIMIZE THE
INVESTMENT.
MY JOB IS TO STAY ON STRATEGY TO
MAKE SURE WE DELIVER ON THE
GOALS OF THE PROGRAM AND TO
UTILIZE OUR MEDIA PARTNERS. TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE DOING THE BEST
JOB TO MAXIMIZE RESOURCES.
AND TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
ACHIEVE THE GOALS OF THE PROGRAM.
I THINK I MISSED A PIECE OF
PAPER MAYBE HAD.
SO YOU GUYS HAVE A TOUGH JOB
AHEAD OF YOU.
AND I DON'T ENVY YOU AT ALL
THAT'S THAT'S WITH THE MISSING.
IS A PIECE OF PAPER SAID.
YES IT DOES.
I THINK I WANT TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT COVERED CALIFORNIA THAT
WITHIN OUR STAFF HAS A LOT OF
GOOD EXPERIENCE IT IN LOTS OF
THINGS BOTH I THANK ABOUT
MARKETING BUT ALSO IN TERMS OF
COMMUNITIES CBO'S DIFFERENT WAYS
TO REACH OUT TO PEOPLE AND WE
ARE ALWAYS WILLING TO SERVE.
AS A RESOURCE FOR OTHER STATE
AGENCIES [inaudible]
YOUR THANK YOU ARE TO DAHLE
THREE VERY MUCH I KNOW WHEN I
STARTED --
ENGAGING IN CENSUS EFFORTS.
SOME OF THE FIRST PEOPLE TO COME
AND AND PRESS US WHERE THE
FOUNDATIONS AND IN THE
FOUNDATION WORLD --
AND I'M PRETTY SURE THEY PROMISE
US THEY'RE GONNA MATCH AS ONE
FOR ONE IN TERMS OF STATE
SPENDING SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO THAT ALTHOUGH I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY ANTICIPATED WE SPENT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AT THAT TIME --
BUT OUR FOUNDATIONS ARE SUCH A
CRITICAL PARTNER --
IN TERMS OF REACHING OUT TO THE
WHO THOSE TRUSTED MESSENGERS ARE
TO HAVING DEVELOP RELATIONSHIPS --
AND SO --
YOU KNOW ARE GONNA BE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT --
IN TERMS OF HOW WE CAN ACTUALLY
BE SUCCESSFUL IN THIS EFFORT --
IS THE THE THE COUNTY
GOVERNMENTS I REPRESENT.
SAN MATTEO COUNTY IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY --
AND I KNOW THAT THEY'VE BEEN
WORKING AS HARD AS ANYBODY --
ON THIS AND IN CAN MEANING THAT
THE LEVEL COMPLETE COUNT
COMMITTEES AND YOU KNOW WE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT KNOWING WITH
THOSE TRUST MESSENGERS ARE AND
AND ARE COUNTIES.
ARE THE ONES WHO OFTEN HAVE
WORKED WITH THEM AND HAVE
CONTRACTS WITH THEM ALREADY --
IN PLACE AND SO REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE AND
THEN COVER CALIFORNIA YEAH.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT COVER
CALIFORNIA FOREVER IS THE GOLD
STANDARD --
SO IS A REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE AND PROVIDING YOUR
EXPERTISE DIDN'T ONE QUESTION
AND IS. ONE OF THE VERY FIRST
ASK MISTY EVENTS IT.
IF YOU WERE US AND AND YOU WERE
FACING THIS TASK AND AND KIND OF
YOU KNOW THE THE GO DAY WAS ALSO
APRIL FIRST EVEN THOUGH IT'S
KIND OF MARCH TWENTY THIRD BUT
FOR SOME REASON WE SAY TABLE
FIRST --
WHEN WOULD YOU BE?
ON THE AIRWAVES AND WHEN WOULD
YOU BE ACTIVELY --
DO PUSHING OUT MESSAGE YOUR YOUR
MESSAGE.
TO TO THE VOTER I'D SOME VOTERS
CONSTITUENTS TO THE FOLKS.
I CAN SPEAK A LITTLE BIT TO THIS
BASED ON WHAT WE LEARNED IT
COVER CALIFORNIA YEAH SO WHEN
COVER CALIFORNIA STIRRED.
IS STARTED ADVERTISING IN
SEPTEMBER FOR AN OPEN ENROLLMENT
THIS STARTED ON OCTOBER FIRST.
AND WHAT HAPPENED WAS WE GOT A
LOT OF PEOPLE SIGNED UP WHO HAD.
MAYBE BEEN HUNGRY FOR INSURANCE
IT WAS A PENT UP DEMAND AND
SIGNED UP RIGHT AWAY.
AND WE HAVE FOUND IN SUBSEQUENT
LEADERS NO MATTER HOW MUCH WE
SAY GET OUT THERE AND DO IT
EARLY SO WE'VE LEARNED TO GO
AROUND DATES SO WE FRIDAY A PREP
PEOPLE FOR THE FACT THAT THE
OPEN ENROLLMENT PERIOD IS COMING
WE OP WROTE IT AT A LOWER LEVEL.
TO START WITH AND DO STRATEGIC
PLACEMENT AND THEN AS A GETS
CLOSER RATCHETED UP.
AND AGAIN THIS IS WE JUST
FINISHED OUR SIX YEAR AND IT'S
THE SAME PATTERN EVERY TIME NO
MATTER HOW MUCH NOTICE WE GIVE
THEM.
RIGHT AROUND THOSE FINAL
DEADLINES IS WHAT EVERYBODY DOES
IT SO -- I
REALLY.
LOOK AT THE MEDIA AND STRETCH IT
OUT IN SUCH A WAY THAT IT'S
REALLY THERE WHEN YOU NEED IT
THE MOST AND NOT DO A LOT OF UP
FRONT ADVERTISING.
SO YOU ACTUALLY STILL HAVE TIME.
THAT'S THAT'S HEARTENING TO HEAR
[inaudible]
AND THE JUDY YOU SAID YOU WANT
TO ANSWER --
YEAH YOU SAID YOU WANT ANSWERS
IN THE EARLIER QUESTIONS --
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT THEN TO ALL
THREE OF YOU IF YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS.
OR COMMENTS BASED ON SOME OF THE
OTHER QUESTIONS THAT WERE ASKED
PLEASE DON'T DON'T.
DON'T HOLD BACK.
GREAT THANK YOU.
DID YOU WANNA JACKSON THING
SENATOR PAN.
FOR WHAT YOU GOING TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION I HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS THAT I WANT
TO ASK THEM.
GREAT --
THANK YOU SO --
THERE WAS A QUESTION THAT CAME
UP EARLIER ON AROUND EDUCATION
AND FORTUNATELY SACRAMENTO
COUNTY ALONG WITH FRESNO COUNTY
IN LA COUNTY OR THE THREE
OFFICES OF EDUCATION ON VETERAN
THAT ARE INVOLVED --
WITH CREATING CURRICULUM AND
I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE SEEN THE
CURRICULUM AND IT'S IT'S IT'S
AWESOME.
AND THEY WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE CENSUS NIGHTS LIKE YOU
HAVE BACK TO SCHOOL NIGHTS AND
AND AND THOSE TYPES OF THINGS
AND AND IN MY COMMENTS I I
ALLUDED TO THAT YOU KNOW.
THE THE K. TWELVE FUNDING REALLY
NEEDS TO BE OR INCREASE FUNDING
TO THE CBO'S OR COUNTIES IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO SUPPLEMENT
MORE --
EDUCATIONAL ACTIVITIES TO BE
ABLE TO USE SCHOOLS AS OUR
PARTNERS ON THE IDEA OF OF
POSTER CONTESTS THE AND BEING
ABLE TO RECOGNIZE THE ON THAT
THAT THE STUDENTS AT DIFFERENT
AGES AND AND MANY OF THOSE
CHILDREN BRING THEIR PARENTS IN
TWO OF THE SCHOOLS AND YOUTH.
AND AND BEING ABLE TO ASSIST IN
COMPLETING THE CENSUS THOSE ARE.
A NUMBER OF THE DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
DOING IN SACRAMENTO THAT CAN BE
REPLICATED ACROSS THE STATE BUT
YOU KNOW WHAT WE WERE WE ALREADY
WELL AWARE OF WHAT'S GOING ON AT
THE STATE LEVEL WITH SO MANY OF
THE DIFFERENT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND TEACHERS THE AND YOU.
KNOW THEY'RE ALREADY OVERWHELMED
AND SO WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT IN INCENTIVIZE
THEM FAR AND ABOVE WHAT THEY
CURRENTLY HAVE AND AND CHRIS AND
THAT IN ALSO A PLACE TO HIGHER
EDUCATION AND THEN ALSO --
Là OUR OUR OUR LIBRARIES THAT
WE ARE TRYING TO THE ON ALL WORK%
TOGETHER ON THERE WAS A
SUGGESTION ACTUALLY THAT WAS
MADE THAT WENT TO ONE OF CENTER
OF BERKS QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT
MAY BE THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT DO
IT AND THERE IS --
THE LET YOU KNOW OR FROM THROUGH
MID APRIL BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
MORE THAN A WEEK --
BUT SIMILAR TO THEIRS VOTER
EDUCATION WEEK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ALREADY DOES.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WOULD
FURTHER HELP --
SUPPORT SCHOOLS SO I I I OFFER
THAT TO YOU --
THERE'S PROBABLY A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT THINGS AS FAR AS YOU
KNOW TALKING MORE LOCALLY ABOUT
HOW WE'RE MAKING SURE THAT WERE
ENGAGING WITH THE RIGHT
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND HOW IS IT THAT WE'VE GOT THE
RIGHT FOLKS AT THE TABLE AND AND
AND WE SPENT MONTHS WITH THE
REGION.
FOUNDATION --
AND A NUMBER OF OTHER WELL
RESPECTED ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS
THE COUNTY VETTING ORGANIZATIONS
AND VETTING THEIR CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICERS WERE THERE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE CAPACITY THAT
THEY WERE WELL RESPECTED THAT
THEY HAD LEADERSHIP --
CAPABILITIES AND CAPACITY AND
THAT THEY WERE REPRESENTING THE
RIGHT GROUPS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE HARD TO COUNT WERE IN FACT
COVERED IN IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
AND WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE VERY
PLEASED WITH HOW AMAZING THAT
COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEE --
IS IS REPRESENTED --
AND THEN WANTED KINDA LAST POINT
THAT HASN'T COME UP IN ANY OF
THE CONVERSATIONS IN AND AROUND
THE THAT THE CENSUS AND ALL.
AND I KNOW THAT WE TALK ABOUT --
NUMBER OF CONGRESSIONAL SEATS WE
TALK ABOUT STATE --
LOSS OF OF FUNDING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHAT WE DON'T
HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT IS HOW THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA USES CENSUS
DATA.
AND I'VE WRITTEN A TON OF GRANTS
ON BOND GRANT THAT'S GOING
THROUGH --
FUNDING RIGHT NOW HAS MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS THAT GOES I GO OUT ON
A PER CAPITA BASIS.
SO AS WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL OF
THIS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE I MEAN
HOW IS THIS GOING TO AFFECT THE
DATA AND HOW WE DISTRIBUTE
FUNDING TO OUR OWN STATE.
AND WE AND WITH IT IF IF IF WE
DON'T GET IT RIGHT YOU KNOW WE
RUN SERVICE SEVERE RISK OF
LOSING REGIONS THAT YOU KNOW IN
SIGNIFICANT PARTS OF OF THE
STATE.
ARE BECAUSE OF THE IMBALANCE IN
AN ACCURACY OF THE DATA THAT
WE'RE COLLECTING SOUGHT I REALLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
THAT ON OUR RADAR --
AND HONE IN BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
CONNECTING THE DOTS TO ALL THE
FUNDING CALIFORNIA DISTRIBUTES
ON YOUR CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS
NAME IT DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
CARVE OUT.
SO THOSE ARE A FEW OF THE POINTS
I WANT TO CIRCLE BACK.
TO THANK YOU.
SO I WANTED TO EXPAND ON ONE
AREA THAT I HAD SPOKEN TO ABOUT
LAYERED MEDIA.
SO WE DO AND USE THAT.
MAJOR MARKETING CAMPAIGN TO DO
AN UMBRELLA CAMPAIGN TO EDUCATE
PEOPLE TO MOTIVATE THEM TO TELL
THEM WHAT THE DEADLINES ARE.
AND I HAVE BEEN BUYING ETHNIC
MEDIA FOR THIRTY YEARS SO I'M.
A BIG BELIEVER.
BUT IN THE BROAD KIND OF REACH
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO THEIR ART
ETHNIC MEDIA IN ALL THE AREAS
YOU NEED THERE TO BE ETHNIC
MEDIA.
AN ETHNIC MEDIA FOLLOWS WHERE
THERE'S POPULATIONS.
SO --
THERE'S A LOT OF ASIANS THE BAY
AREA BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO LIVE THERE BUT IF YOU
LIVE OUTSIDE THAT AREA OR LA
THERE MIGHT NOT BE ANY MEDIA.
THAT REACHES PEOPLE WHO DON'T
SPEAK THE LANGUAGE SO YOU HAVE
TO REALLY LOOK AT LAYERING AND
DIFFERENT KINDS OF MEDIA TO
REACH DIFFERENT AGE GROUPS AND
DIFFERENT KINDS OF PEOPLE --
AND YOU ALSO HAVE TO THINK OF
THE BEST EXAMPLE I COULD BE GIVE
IS OF ANY USE THE SACRAMENTO BEE.
I WOULD DISSECT WILL BE EVERY
DAY IF YOU PUT AN AD IN THE
SACRAMENTO BEE ONCE A WEEK FOR
THE WHOLE NEXT YEAR.
I'LL READ IT A COUPLE TIMES BUT
I WILL READ IT EVERY SINGLE DAY
BECAUSE AFTER AWHILE GET USED TO
IT.
BUT I READ THE SECOND MAYBE IT
EVEN IF YOU USE THAT PAPER EVERY
SINGLE WEEK.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO WILL NEVER
READ THE SACRAMENTO BEE AND HAS
NOTHING TO SAY WITH THE QUALITY
OF THE MEDIA OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT SO YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOME
PEOPLE ARE GOOD ONLY LISTEN.
AND TO SOCIAL MEDIA SOME PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO WATCH TELEVISION
SOME PEOPLE ARE GOING TO SEE A
BILLBOARD SOME PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO READ THE NEWSPAPER YOU HAVE
TO DO A VARIETY OF THINGS
BECAUSE YOU CAN COUNT ON ONE OR
TWO VEHICLES TO GET EVERYBODY
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT THAT.
SIMILAR AND IT --
VIEWERSHIP AB ETHNICITIES AND
THERE'S A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
FACTORS BUT MARKETING CAMPAIGNS
HAVE A WHOLE MARKETING AGENCIES
OF PEOPLE SO MEDIA HAVE REALLY
HOLD THEIR ABILITY TO PINPOINT --
HOW TO SELL YOU A PRODUCT AND
THE CENSUS IS IN A VERSION --
I KIND OF PRODUCT --
THE OTHER THING I BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU'RE LOOKING AT A REGIONAL
APPROACH.
I WOULDN'T.
THE FIRST YEAR OF COVER
CALIFORNIA WE LET OUT LOTS AND
LOTS AND LOTS OF GRANTS AND WE
HAD PEOPLE AT FAIRS AND FARMERS
MARKETS EVERY PLACE YOU CAN
THINK OUT THERE WITH THEIR
LITTLE.
NOT KIOSK WOULD LIKE A TABLE AND
BROCHURES AND THINGS TO HAND OUT.
AND IT WAS AND PEOPLE WOULD COME
TO BE YOU NEED TO PROMOTE WHEN
I'M DOING OUT OF THE AT THE
FARMERS MARKET.
IN SOME CASES THERE WOULD BE A
THOUSAND EVENTS.
OVER A WEEKEND.
SO YOU CAN'T REALLY PROMOTE A
THOUSAND EVENTS AND WHAT WE
ENDED UP DOING IS COLLAPSING
THOSE AND HAVING THE DATES AND
HAVING THE LOCATIONS AND ALL
HAVE HAVING ALL POSTED ON OUR
WEBSITE.
SO THAT PEOPLE AND WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO GO TO THE
WEBSITE TO FIND OUT WHERE THE
EVENTS WERE SO THAT THEY CAN
SIGN UP.
BUT JUST AS TO DO AN AD FOR EACH
ONE OF THOSE OF THOUSANDS OF
FANS WOULD BE --
AND IN LOS ANGELES YOU KNOW THE
EVENT IS ON THE WEST SIDE AND
YOU KNOW EVERYBODY HERE IS IT
BUT NOBODY'S GOING TO DRIVE FROM
THE EAST SIDE TO THE WEST SIDE
TO GO TO A FARMER'S MARKET
UNLESS THIS IS ONE REALLY
TERRIFIC FARMERS MARKET.
SO -- BY
COLLAPSING IT WOULD PUTTING ON A
WEBSITE REALLY ALLOWED PEOPLE
WHO JUST WANTED TO GO OUT AND
FIND AN ACTIVITY LIKE THAT TO
LOCATE THEM WITHOUT --
I'LL OR FIND ONE IN THEIR
COMMUNITY THAT WAS EASIEST FOR
THEM TO REACH.
THANK THANK YOU OFFER FOR BEING
HERE ACT --
SERVICE REPAIRS.
LA.
HUGE HATE --
AND YOU TALKED ABOUT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES --
SO.
ACTUALLY WELL YOU'RE A CBO YOU
HEARD ACTUALLY EVEN FROM MEMBERS
FROM LOS ANGELES SAYING WELL WE
NEED TO FIND COOKIE I GUESS
THAT'S THAT.
SO I SO WHAT SO WHAT DO YOU SEE
IS THE CHALLENGES FOR USE THE
CBO RIGHT BECAUSE YES MONEY FROM
THE STATE STATES GO SAY YOU NEED
TO COUNT FOR ALL THE MONEY
HERE'S OUR METRICS ETCETERA AND
THAT'S WHAT WE DO AND DEBTS
REASONABLE WE ACTUALLY DEMAND
THAT OVER.
AGENCIES.
AND IN MEANTIME IS IS THAT --
THERE'S POKEY WHO.
THEY USE THIRTY SOUNDS IT IS
THIRTY DOES EVERYBODY KNOWS
EVERYBODY IN SOME NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND RIGHT WHO WHO KNOWS
EVERYBODY NEIGHBORHOOD TO GET
PEOPLE MOVING IF THEY NEED.
TO FRANKLY ISN'T EVEN A
ORGANIZATION RIGHTS PERSON.
AND YOU KNOW TO GIVE LOTS OF
OTHER THINGS SHE'S DOING SO --
SO WHAT HAS HAD HAD TO HIDE AND
YOU'RE LIKE HEY I WANT TO HELP
OUT WITH THE CENSUS.
AND SHE'S LIKE WELL [inaudible]
WHY?
THE BETTER SO IT WAS A TO TELL
ME WHAT YOU SEE IS THE
CHALLENGES --
FOR THAT SO I COLLEAGUES ARE
SAYING WELL WE NEED WE NEED TO
WE NEED TO FIND AND GET COOKIE
INVOLVED YEAH I THINK --
OBVIOUSLY THE FOUNDATION DIDN'T
MAKE THE ASSUMPTION THAT WE
WOULDN'T EVEN KNOW WE WERE IN
APPLY FOR REGIONALLY CVO IT
WASN'T UNTIL OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS CAME TO US AND SAID.
HEY WE'D LIKE FOR YOU TO DO THIS
YOU GUYS HOW THE BACKBONE TO DO
IT YOU GUYS HAVE THE CAPACITY SO
THAT WAS A RULE THAT WE WERE
INTENTIONAL ABOUT TAKING.
THAT BEING SAID BEFORE THAT WE
WERE WORKING --
REALLY SINCE LAST YEAR TO RACE
THAT TEN MILLION DOLLAR.
POLLS FIND --
WITH OTHER FOUNDATIONS TO REALLY
SUPPORT THOSE COMMUNITY BASED
GROUPS. ONE OF OUR CONCERNS TO
BE QUITE CANDID WITH SERVING AS
A REGIONAL A CBO IT'S THE THE
CONFINEMENT THAT SUCH A
STRUCTURE CAN ALSO BRING YOU
KNOW YOU ONLY GET THEIR MONEY
AFTER YOU MEET A CERTAIN SET OF
CRITERIA AND IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE
YOU KNOW.
WE HAVE TO SHOW PROOF YOU KNOW
WE HAVE TO BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THE STATE.
BUT GROUPS NEED THE MONEY RIGHT
NOW ARM UP YOU KNOW THEIR
CAPACITY THEY NEED --
A NEED MESSAGING NOW THEY NEED
TO KNOW WHAT THEY CAN ACCOUNT --
FOR AND SO.
I DO WORRY SOMETIMES THAT THE
FUNDS THAT WILL TRICKLE BACK
FROM REGIONALLY CBO WON'T BE AS
FLEXIBLE --
AND ALSO WON'T BE IF TIMELY SO
THAT'S PART OF THE REASON WHY
CCF REGARDLESS ABOUT HAS
CONTINUED TO SORT OF PARTNER
WITH OTHERS --
IT WITH THE CITY OF LA TO REALLY
SORT OF HAVE POOL A POOL FULL
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
MEET THOSE DEMANDS --
DOES THAT HELP ANSWER OKAY YET --
AND THEN I GUESS THE OTHER
QUESTION I KNOW THAT --
SOME OF BERMAN I AND WE BUT WE
WENT DOWN --
TO HIS DISTRICT TO AND TALK TO
SOME FOUNDATIONS I I DID IT I DO
HEAR FROM US --
MY OWN COUNTY HERE ABOUT THE
WELL -- SOME
AREAS HAVE.
MORE OR FEWER RESOURCES IN TERMS
WE WE DID HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH SOME THE FOUNDATIONS ABOUT
TWELVE IN WHEN IT COMES TO
GOVERNMENT MONEY.
RIGHT.
THERE'S OFTEN IT'S PUBLIC MONEY
DIRECTORS STRINGS THAT HAVE TO
BE ATTACHED STIRS LEVEL OF
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT.
MAKES IT MUCH HARDER TO GET DOWN
TO THE GRASS ROOTS --
ARE YOU ARE YOU LOOKING AT ALSO
IN ADDITION TO THIS OR THE STATE
MONEY AND SO FORTH TO HAVING
THIS CONVERSATION FOUNDATIONS OR
SOMETHING WE CAN DO TO TRY TO
ENCOURAGE FOUNDATIONS ALSO TO
HELP GIVES I GUESS SOME MORE
FLEXIBLE MONEY THAT MIGHT BE
THAT THAT THE THAT MIGHT.
BE HELPFUL IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
GET MONEY DOWN INTO THE GRASS
ROOTS.
ALL ALSO.
SHARE THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE DONE TO DATE IN TERMS
FOR ME PLAN --
TO OUR CAMPAIGN WAS TO REALLY
SATISFIED --
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR EXAMPLE FOR RAPID RESPONSE
GRANTS THERE ARE THINGS THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO KNOW UNTIL
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY HITS.
SO MAYBE THE STATE CAN ALSO
THINK OF SOMETHING SIMILAR TO
THAT LIKE HAVING A RESERVE
THAT'S REALLY YOU KNOW SMALL
GRANTS WORK WE DON'T HAVE TO
PULL SO MANY STRINGS ATTACHED
IT'S REALLY JUST.
A THOUSAND DOLLARS TO PRINT
COPIES YOU KNOW.
A FEW THOUSAND DOLLARS TO GET
SUPPORT FROM YOU KNOW A
CONSULTANT TO REACH X. Y. Z. OR
TO HIRE.
STAFF YOU KNOW THAT CAN GO OUT
THERE AND DO COUNTY SEEING --
PROVIDES CAN SING SUPPORT OR YOU
KNOW KNOCK DOOR TO DOOR SERVICES
SO.
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT I
YOU KNOW I WOULD RECOMMEND I
THINK.
DS AND YOU KNOW THE THE COMPLETE --
COUNT COMMITTEE HAS DONE A
WONDERFUL JOB AT KEEPING YOU
KNOW CONVERSATIONS VERY OPEN
WITH FOUNDATIONS I THINK WE
INVITE MORE --
THAT'S DEFINITELY SOMETHING.
THE WAIT FOUNDATIONS ALSO
PARTICIPATE ADD AS PART OF THE
STATE WIDE FOUNDATIONS TABLE SO
THE OF PART BANDAGES COMING
TOGETHER TO REALLY TALK ABOUT
THE CENSUS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WERE CONSTANTLY DISCUSSING.
IS HOW DO WE PLAN TOGETHER WITH
THE STATE WE DON'T YOU KNOW IT'S
IT'S HARD TO MAKE FUNDING
DECISIONS BECAUSE WE ALSO HAVE.
OUR STAKEHOLDERS THAT YOU KNOW
DEMAND CERTAIN THINGS OUT OF US
AND ALSO ONE TRANSPARENCY AND
THAT WANT TO KNOW THAT WERE
REALLY USING OR STEWARDING
RESOURCES APPROPRIATELY RIGHT
LOOK SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE CONTINUE TO GET HIT WHEN WE
TALK TO OTHER.
FOUNDATIONS TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO
INVEST IN THE CENSUS IS WELL WHY
STEPHANIE AT LIKE THE STATE HAS
YOU KNOW RELEASED ALL THIS
AMOUNT.
YOU HAVE THIS AMOUNT SO WHAT'S
REALLY WHAT'S THE NEED --
OUT THERE AND UNTIL WE KNOW AT A
SLOWER PACE.
WE JUST DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE
SO I THINK AGAIN ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS AND MORE PLANNING
MEETINGS TOGETHER I THINK IT'S A
WELCOME OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE HAD
SOME BUT I THINK.
IT COULD BE THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
ESPECIALLY AS WE START TO THINK
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW ETHNIC MEDIA --
OUT REACHING TO THEM IN CREATING --
MEDIA PARTNERSHIPS I SEE THE
STATE'S SORT OF TAKING ON THAT
LEADERSHIP ROLE AND REALLY
NEGOTIATING THE BIG CONTRACTS
BUT ALSO PARTNERING WITH
FOUNDATIONS THAT ARE ON THE
GROUND AND THAT ARE THINKING
MORE REGIONALLY AT AT WHAT CAN
WE TAKE ON LIKE FOR EXAMPLE
RADIO IN LA.
AND AN ORANGE COUNTY IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND IT ACTUALLY --
HAS SHOWN THAT IT HAS IT REACHES
THE AUDIENCES THAT WE WANT SO
IT'S NOT ALWAYS GOING TO BE THE
BIG YOU KNOW LACKEY NO NETWORK
THAT WE NEED --
IT MIGHT BE THAT SO WHO'S GOING
A FEW SCHOLARSHIP BILLS LIKE THE
SMALLER MEDIA STATIONS HOW DO WE
PARTNER TO KNOW THAT TO IT TOO
YOU KNOW COLLECTIVELY WITH THE
STATE TO KNOW THAT LIKE HEY YOU
GUYS ARE GOING TO HANDLE THIS
PIECE THIS IS WHERE PLAN TO BE.
CAN COMING --
MESSAGE TESTING AND PLATFORM I
KNOW YOU KNOW.
FOUNDATIONS LIKE MYSELF HAVE
INVESTED IN IT INCLUDING AN
ORANGE COUNTY AND SAN BERNARDINO
FOR EXAMPLE BECAUSE THERE WERE
NO FUNDING PARTNERS DOING
ANYTHING IN THAT REGION AND SO
WE KNEW.
THAT.
DOING IT NOW MIGHT BE TOO LATE
BECAUSE BY THE FALL EARLY NEXT
YEAR.
WE HAVE TO WE HAVE TO BE READY.
SO --
THINKING ABOUT MAYBE LIKE A
WEBSITE THAT --
MAYBE THE STATE CAN ALSO HELP US
MANAGE OR AGAIN PAY FOR WHERE
NON PROFITS --
OR COMMUNITY BASED GROUPS CAN
REALLY ACCESS THAT MESSAGING
THAT HAS BEEN ALREADY VETTED IN
CUSTOMER --
CUSTOMIZE AND THEY CAN TAKE THAT
AND ALSO REPORT BACK ON IT OR
ALSO TAKE THOSE LEARNING THANK
CREATE.
CONTENT THAT IS CUTS MY CITY
THAT COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE
[inaudible]
SO.
RIGHT THANK YOU --
AND THEN ESPECIALLY --
THOMAS AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN MY
DISTRICT.
YOU MENTIONED ABOUT THAT AND I
THINK WHAT WE AND THE THE SPENCE
IS RELATED TO THAT IS I THINK
THAT I I UNDERSTAND IT'S ONE THE
REASONS THAT YOU THINK
SACRAMENTO SERVE UNDER FUNDED
TERMS OF BE ABLE TO HAVE ENOUGH.
MATERIALS IN DIFFERENT LANGUAGES
IS THAT DO YOU SEE THAT IT'S THE
STATE THAT SHOULD PROVIDE THE
MATERIALS AND REYES DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES THAT CAN BE DELIVERED
ARE WE LOOKING AT LOCAL I MEAN --
WHERE DOES THE THE IT AND TO
REALLY TAKE PLACE --
AND ALSO I RECOGNIZE THAT
CERTAINLY SOME OF THE LANGUAGES
ACTUALLY. FOR MAY COMMUNITIES
ARE NOT PRIMARILY I MEAN THAT
ARE PROBABLY WRITTEN RIGHT IT'S
ACTUALLY VERBAL OR SOMETHING SO
IT'S NOT LIKE --
I CAN JUST PRINT OUT A BUNCH OF
FLYERS IN THAT LANGUAGE AND
THAT'S GOING TO WORK SO COULD
YOU SPEAK. TO TO THE SECOND MOST
COUNTIES CHALLENGES REGARDING
LANGUAGE AND AND AND THEM OUT OF
FUNDING YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU --
YES AND SO IT IS IT IS THE THE
ASPECT OF DIFFERENT CULTURES AND
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES AND
DIFFERENT WAYS IN WHICH THEY
COMMUNICATE IN WHAT MESSAGING
WORKS WITH ONE DOESN'T WORK --
WITH ANOTHER.
AND SO --
THROUGH OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THEY DO KNOW HOW
TO COMMUNICATE WITH FOLKS IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES --
BUT IT'S GOING TO TAKE MORE
JEWEL CONTACTS AND IT'S GOING TO
TAKE A FAR FAR BROADER.
GROUP OF OF INDIVIDUALS TO BE
ABLE TO REACH OUT IN ALL OF
THESE DIFFERENT YOU KNOW DIVERSE
WAYS YOU KNOW IT WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY VERSES.
IF WE HAD THE SAME NUMBER THAT
WERE -- THAT
WAS YOU KNOW ME BEING MOSTLY YOU
KNOW VIETNAMESE AND HISPANIC YOU
KNOW IS IT TOO AS OPPOSED TO YOU
KNOW THIRTY PLUS YOU KNOW TYPE.
SO THERE'S THE THE INCREASED
AMOUNT IN IN BEING ABLE.
TO CREATE WE HAVE TO CREATE
DIFFERENT MESSAGING FOR A LOT OF
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES AND AND AND
COMMUNITIES AND AND I THINK
THOSE WERE DISCUSSED EARLIER
ABOUT THE DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF
THE WAY THAT WE HAVE TO DO THAT --
AND THEN THE OTHER IS AND AND WE
WE WE TOTALLY SUPPORT --
TO LANGUAGE ACCESS AND AND AND
MAKING SURE THAT THINGS ARE
ACCEPTABLE FOR INDIVIDUALS OF OF
ALL DIFFERENT YOU KNOW
DISABILITIES OR ABILITIES --
AND AND SO WITH THAT IT'S NOT A
YOU KNOW A ONE OFF OF YOU KNOW
YOU CREATE THIS AND THEN AND
THEN YOU PUT IT OUT AGAIN
DIFFERENT GROUPS COMMUNICATE AND
AND WE'VE BEEN --
YOU KNOW FOLKS HAVE GOT
DIFFERENT HEARING IT LISTENING
DEVICES YOU KNOW WE CAN HAVE A
TRANSLATOR IT'S IT'S STILL
DOESN'T MEAN THAT IT'S GOING TO
BE YOU KNOW QUITE ACCURATE SO
WERE OR WANTING TO HIRE
INDIVIDUALS FROM THIS COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS MORE
SPECIFICALLY IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
YOU KNOW WHERE THEY CAN TALK
WITH THEIR NEIGHBORS AND SO THEY
THEY SEE THAT HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT OR OR COLLEGE STUDENT
THAT'S BEEN IN THEIR COMMUNITY
AND NOW.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE ALSO SHOWING UP
A COMMUNITY MEETINGS THAT'S PART
OF THE COMMUNITY BUILDING YOU
KNOW THAT WERE ALSO TRYING TO
ACHIEVE WITH THE THROUGH THIS --
THE STATE WIDE BASIS IS TWO ONE
ONE AND THEY OFFER TRANSLATION
SERVICES AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S OFFERED.
ACROSS THE STATE --
AND THERE'S OPPORTUNITY TO GROW
THAT CAPACITY I THROUGHPUT YOU
KNOW POTENTIALLY A STATE
CONTRACT BUT YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
YOU KNOW CALL 211- AND YOU NEED
A TRANSLATOR SOMEBODY STILL HAS
TO PAY THAT COST AND SO THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT'S FACTORED
INTO OUR BUDGET --
YOU KNOW WE ARE BUILDING A
WEBSITE FOR THE COUNTY AND FOR A
RESIDENTS BUT IT'S NOT GOING TO
BE IN SIX DIFFERENT LANGUAGES
ARE MAINTAINED IN SIX DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES.
IT SHOULD BE --
BUT AGAIN IT TAKES ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO TO TO DO THAT TYPE OF
THING.
SO YOU KNOW AGAIN YOU KNOW IT'S
IT'S IT'S IT'S THE DIVERSE THE
NATURE OF THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
OF OF CULTURES AND LANGUAGES.
THAT THEN JUST MAKES REPLICATION
OF OF ALL OUT REACH A LITTLE BIT
MORE COSTLY MUCH NEEDED YOU KNOW
BUT THAT ADDS TO THE COST.
SO I WOULD YEAH.
I WOULD ADD ONE THING TO YOUR
CONVERSATION --
I THINK THAT THERE'S IN SOME
WAYS A BENEFIT FOR THE STATE TO
DO A LOT OF THE TRANSLATING.
SPEAK ADD MAKING I UNIVERSAL OR
EVERGREEN PIECES SO THAT PEOPLE
COULD MAYBE PUT THERE ARE LIKE
STAMP.
PRINTED TO PERSONALIZE IT --
BECAUSE THE THINK OF A TERRACE
AND I HAVE A PERSONAL PREJUDICE
ABOUT TRANSLATING.
BOB EVERY DOCUMENT EVER WRITTEN
THAT ISN'T PUBLICLY RELEASED I
HAD AT LEAST TWO PEOPLE READ IT
AFTER I WROTE IT TO MAKE SURE
WAS RIGHT.
AND WE ALL MAKE MISTAKES BUT
THERE'S SOMETHING STRANGE WITH
TRANSLATIONS WERE PEOPLE ASSUME
BECAUSE A PERSON SPEAKS
VIETNAMESE THEY ARE TRANSLATING
IT PERFECTLY.
AND IT JUST AS YOU WOULD DO IT
IN ENGLISH AND YOU WOULD HAVE
MULTIPLE PEOPLE REVIEW IT YOU
NEED TO HAVE MULTIPLE PEOPLE
LOOK AT IT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S NOTHING LOST IN THE
TRANSLATION.
AND SO THAT'S I THINK A JOB IS
EASIER THAN IN THE STATE WIDE
BASIS AND THE PERSONALIZED TO
THE COUNTY BECAUSE I THINK THAT
MANY COUNTIES DO NOT HAVE
ANYWHERE NEAR THE RATE RESOURCES
OUR CAPACITY TO TRANSLATE INTO
THE NUMBER OF LANGUAGES JUST THE
BASIC LIKE WHICH IS.
NOT THE UNIQUE LANGUAGES THE
BASIC LANGUAGES THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO NEED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RIGHT WELL I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL SO MUCH FOR FOR BEING HERE I
KNOW THAT THAT'S RUNNING LATE.
AND STAND WE'VE BEEN THROUGH A
SINGLE PLANE BESTS HUH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR PERSONS
FOR BEING HERE AND AND THANKS SO
MUCH FOR SHARING WHAT YOU HAD
SURE THE IT'S BEEN VERY.
VALUABLE INFORMATIVE TO US NOW
THANK YOU PLEASURE THANKS MUCH
OKAY SO -- I
THINK WE'LL MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IT WAS A SIGN UP SHEET
THERE IF PEOPLE WANT TO LINE UP
AT THE MICROPHONE --
GONNA ASK IF YOU CAN TRY TO KEEP
YOUR COMMENT TO A MINUTE.
AND ALWAYS FEEL FREE TO SUBMIT
AND WELL THE SO --
AND I SHE ACTUALLY THINKS THAT
MICROPHONE OVER THERE USE THAT.
ONE OKAY AND THE OTHERS SIGN IN
SHEET SO THAT WAY WE HAD WE KNOW
WHO.
SO YOU SAY YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AT THEN --
YOUR YOUR YOUR COMMENT.
HI AM CRAZY CASTRUM NAVAJO AND
THE CHAIR OF THE LA CITY COUNTY
NATIVE AMERICAN INDIAN
COMMISSION I WANTED TO JUST ADD
TO SENATOR BERMAN COMMENTS ABOUT
THE FUNDING ALLOCATION TO TRIBES --
MOST TRIBES ARE RECEIVING AS
ZERO DOLLARS OR ONE THOUSAND OR
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS TO CONDUCT
OUTREACH WHICH IS SORELY
INSUFFICIENT FOR SUCH A HARD TO
COUNT OUR POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND SO --
YOU KNOW NATIVE PEOPLES
NATIONALLY IN THE LAST CENSUS
WERE THE HARDEST ACCOUNT WE'RE
IF WE HAD A 5% UNDER COUNT WHICH
IS TWICE AS MUCH AS ANY OTHER
POPULATION --
AND THERE'S STILL TIME TO
CORRECT THIS SOME REALLY
APPEALING TO THOSE BODIES
LEADERSHIP TO INVESTIGATE THIS
AND TO REALLY SUPPORT
AUGMENTATION OF FUNDING AND I
WILL BE SUBMITTING A LETTER WITH
A LOT MORE DETAILED INFORMATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
CENTER SEE AROUND SANTANA
REPRESENTING CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION WE ARE A
COMMUNITY BASED CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION LOCATED IN SAN
FRANCISCO'S CHINATOWN.
AND SINCE OUR INCEPTION IN
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE WE HAVE
WORKED ON THE CENSUS FOR THE
LAST FIVE DECADES.
OUR COMMITMENT REMAINS THE SAME
IS TO HELP ENSURE AN ACCURATE
COUNT OF OUR HARD TO REACH
POPULATIONS.
THIS LAST WEEK THE STATE CENSUS
OFFICE WRISTS A RELEASE THEIR
DRAFT LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN.
AND WE THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO LOOK AT THAT
PLAN WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF THE
FEDERAL EFFORTS AND THE LOCAL
EFFORTS.
SO WE ALONG WITH OTHER CIVIL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS HAVE GRAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT --
THE FEDERAL BUREAU SAID PLAN IN
REACHING OUR LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT COMMUNITIES AND OUR
MANY DIVERSE --
LANGUAGE COMMUNITIES SO IN CHAU
THE FEDERAL BUREAU STE PLAN
ACTUALLY DISCRIMINATES AGAINST
SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S RESIDENTS
WHO ARE LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT WHO ARE REFUGEES
ASIANS PACIFIC ISLANDERS.
LANGUAGES OF LESSER DIFFUSION
AND ARE NON WRITTEN LANGUAGES --
AND SO.
GIVEN I THINK IN ADDITION THIS
MAKES OUR LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN
EVEN MORE CRITICAL AND IT'S EVEN
MORE CRITICAL BECAUSE THIS
LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN WILL INFORM.
THE STATE'S.
OUTREACH EFFORTS AND IT WILL
INFORM THE STATE'S MEDIA EFFORTS
SO -- MISTER
HOWARD TALKED ABOUT THE GROUND
GAME IF CALIFORNIA WANTS TO RUIN
THE GROUND GAME WE MUST MAKE
SURE OUR LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN IS
REALLY --
OPERATIONAL AND SO I IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I'LL JUST GIVE
YOU ARE ONE PRIMARY
RECOMMENDATION IS THAT THE PLAN
FOCUS ON OPERATIONALIZE SEEING
HOW LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED.
IN SPECIFIC LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT COMMUNITIES
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES NOT --
YOU KNOW THAT SPEAK IN.
THE MIST ECHO OR IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND FAILURE TO DO SO.
BUT TO CONFRONT THESE
OPERATIONAL CHALLENGES WILL
REALLY JEOPARDIZE THE EFFICACY
OF ALL THE STATE CENSUS DOLLARS
THAT HAVE BEEN INVESTED THANK
YOU.
Q. AND I THINK AS I INDICATED
WILL PROBABLY DO BE DOING SOME
CONSIDERABLE FOLLOW UP ON THAT
ISSUE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM YOU MORE THERE.
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS GABBY TACKLE I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
SACRAMENTO ACT AN AFFILIATE OF
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M ALSO THE CO CHAIR FOR
SACRAMENTO.
AND FOR OUR REGION REGION ONE
WE'RE JUST ONE WE HAVE TO SPLIT
ONE POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS --
FOR SEVENTEEN COUNTIES AND WE
KNOW THAT SACRAMENTO WE WE NEED
TO EXTRA RESOURCES IN ORDER TO
DO THE AVERAGE THAT WE NEED AND
WE HAVE A LOT OF LEARNINGS.
FROM -- AS
TO THE WOMAN'S SHARE EARLIER
FROM THE ACA WORK AND EVEN LAST
YEAR'S --
VOTERS CHOICE AND SO --
JUST WANT URGE THAT IF WE REALLY
TRULY WANT EVERYBODY IN OUR
COMMUNITY TO COUNT WE NEED TO
ALLOCATE ADDITIONAL FUNDS.
FOR OUR REACH IN NOT JUST AS
SACRAMENTO BUT THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU --
I MEANING NIXEUS AND I'M WITH
THE COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS CALIFORNIA WHERE THE
NATION'S LARGEST MUSLIM CIVIL
RIGHTS GROUP.
WE ARE ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
CENSUS POLICY ADVOCACY NETWORK
OR SEE PAN WHICH COVERS OVER --
FIFTEEN CBO ORGANIZATIONS THAT
SPECIFICALLY TARGET AND AND
SUPPORT SUPPORT THE HARD TO
COUNT POPULATIONS.
AND WE ECHO WHAT HAS BEEN STATED
LANGUAGE ACCESS PROGRAM BUT
PARTICULARLY THE IMPORTANCE OF
FOCUSING ON ENSURING THAT CBO'S
HAVE ADEQUATE FUNDING INTERESTED
MESSENGERS.
BUT JUST FOR JUST LOOKING AT THE
MUSLIM COMMUNITY REPRESENT%
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION FOLKS.
I'M WITH THE INCREASE ISSUES AND
SURVEILLANCE BUT AND ALSO SAFETY
GIVEN RECENTLY WITH NEW ZEALAND --
IT'S GOING TO BE REALLY
DIFFICULT --
INSURING THAT THE MESSAGE GETS
OUT AND TRUSTED MESSENGERS ARE
INCLUDED SO WE REALLY URGE.
THAT -- MORE
FOCUS IS MADE TO SUPPORTING
CBO'S AND AND AND TRUSTING
TRUSTED MESSENGERS TO GET THE
RIGHT THE WORD OUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
A SUBPOENA ME DOES NOT NOW WITH
CHILDREN NOW CHILDREN NOW --
FOCUSES ON CHILDREN'S HEALTH
EDUCATION WELL BEING ALL ISSUES
CHILDREN AROUND CHILDREN. TWENTY
SIX AND WE'RE JUST HERE.
TO STRESS THE IMPORTANCE OF
ENSURING THE ANY MARKETING AND
OUTREACH --
MATERIAL.
FOCUSES ON INCLUDING CHILDREN
AND COUNTING YOUR CHILDREN
COUNTING INFANTS --
AND THEN ALSO MAKING SURE THAT
OUR PARENTS AND FAMILIES KNOW
ALL THE RESOURCES AND FOCUSING
ON THAT --
TRISTEN MESSENGERS THAT GET THE
WORD OUT IN THE WELCOME.
GOOD EVENING MADISON BY ON
BEHALF OF THEM ALAMEDA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HERE TO
BRIEFLY --
VOICE THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
ADDITIONAL FIFTY FOUR MILLION
FOR CENSUS OUTREACH EFFORTS AND
AS THE TWENTY FIFTH HARDEST
ACCOUNT COUNTY IN THE NATION WE
APPRECIATE ANY ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS IN THIS EFFORT TO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT --
SEEN OTHER PEOPLE ON THE
MICROPHONE --
A TURN YES OKAY THAT I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF EVERYONE WHO'S --
TESTIFIED HERE THIS HEARING WAS
PARTICULARLY THINK I GOV OPS AND
THE THE THEIR SENSES TEAM I ALSO
WANT TO THANK ALL OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS WHO ARE WORKING
TOGETHER.
THANK YOU ALL.
FOR ALL OF YOU STICK OUT TO THE
END TO GET PUBLIC COMMENT AS
WELL -- THIS
JOINT INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF
THE SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
THE TWENTY TWENTY UNIT UNITED
STATES CENSUS AND ASSEMBLY
SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE CENSUS
IS NOW ADJOURNED THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELL DONE